[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre grande
émission parlementaire du mercredi on
est ensemble jusqu'à 17h et au programme
dans une heure les questions d'actualité
au gouvernement c'est le temps fort de
votre après midi aux commentaires alice
bardot dans l'hémicycle et pour les
réactions quand un calme est dans la
salle des conférences
à tout à l'heure de l'émotion aux
questions après la mort lundi de 13
militaires engagés dans l'opération
barkan au mali l'heure est encore à la
douleur et au chômage
mais le débat commence la france
insoumise remettent en cause la présence
française sur place
d'autres réclament des efforts européens
on y revient dans un instant enfin le
débat sur les retraites bat il sortir du
flou après avoir reçu les partenaires
sociaux pendant deux jours le premier
ministre edouard philippe a dit toute sa
détermination à l'instant il a précisé
tout à l'heure le calendrier des
annonces des annonces qui devrait
intervenir mi décembre environ
on y revient également tout à l'heure et
n'hésitez pas à commenter cette émission
avec le hashtag qu âgées
[Musique]
et on va tout de suite rejoindre et
alice bardot dans l'hémicycle du sénat
car dans une heure maintenant vont
commencer les questions d'actu et il va
notamment être question du mali après la
mort lundi de 13 militaires engagés dans
l'opération marque analystes eh oui tam
l'un des sujets du jour c'est bien sûr
la situation au mali vous l'avais dit au
lendemain de l'annoncé de la mort de
treize militaires français dont le fils
du sénateur jean marie bockel l'émotion
devrait toujours être vivent ici au
sénat après l'hommage d'hier dans
l'hémicycle mais un débat s'est ouvert
celui de la présence de troupes
françaises au sahel il y aura deux
questions à ce sujet tout à l'heure l'un
des autres sujets du jour c'est la
réforme des retraites et un climat
social de plus en plus tendu à la proche
de la date fatidique du 5 décembre jour
de grève nationale mais le premier
ministre a réaffirmé à l'instant sa
détermination pour mener à bien cette
réforme et cela devrait se ressentir
tout à l'heure dans l'hémicycle voilà
pour le programme je vous retrouve donc
tout à l'heure juste avant l'ouverture
de la séance des questions d'actualité
merci beaucoup à l'iss pour toutes ces
explications alors en 24 heures on est
passé de l'émotion et de l'hommage au
débat qui s'ouvre sur la présence
française sur place tout de suite les
explications de béatrice faisant ils ont
marqué une minute de silence en hommage
aux treize militaires français morts au
mali hier dans la collision accidentelle
de deux hélicoptères un drame national
qui touche tout particulièrement les
sénateurs je suis certain qu'au moment
nous allons partager ce moment de
recueillement
vous aurez une pensée pour ses treize
militaires pour leur famille et plus
particulièrement pour une famille chère
à notre coeur que nous croisons au
quotidien dans notre assemblée
je crois que c'est aussi un hommage que
nous devons rendre à ses hommes
leur courage est au service de la france
en effet parmi les victimes figurent
pierre bockel fils de l'ancien ministre
et sénateur du haut rhin
il était lieutenant et avait 28 ans
notre peine est immense
notre fils était un des deux pilotes
celui du coup leur une chine que le sait
bien c'est la quatrième fois qu'il
venait en opex au mali et s'il accepte
de vous parler c'est aussi un peu pour
lui pour lui rendre hommage car je n'ai
évidemment par le lequel rosselat hier
soir une cérémonie était organisée en
mémoire de l'ensemble du 5e régiment
d'hélicoptères de pau avant l'hommage
national qui aura lieu lundi aux
invalides et tout de suite on va
rejoindre calme match quand un calme est
qu'il se trouve dans la salle des
conférences à votre micro andré
reichardt sénateurs et l'air il est
également président du groupe france
afrique de l'ouest bonjour andré
reichardt
effectivement on voit cette émotion
depuis hier très forte également les
interrogations et qui se posent
notamment sur la présence de la france
dans cette zone d'afrique
est-ce que selon vous est la partie dans
la france à ce conflit elle est
indispensable elle est indispensable
bien sûr puisqu'elle a été demandée par
les pays concernés rappelons-nous bien
sûr notre intervention s'est faite à la
demande de rafic du mali alors la
question bien sûr est de savoir ce qu'on
y fait encore est-ce que
goût de maintenant quelques années notre
présence est indispensable chez votre
opinion alors je pense que oui bien
entendu il suffit de voir que au mali
cela continue même si dans nord ça se
calme un petit peu on voit que
maintenant c'est le centre du mali s'est
naturellement l'est toujours mais ce qui
est beaucoup plus grave c'est que c'est
que la gangrène est à l'oeuvre et j'ai
eu l'occasion de poser une question
d'actualité concernant le burkina faso
il y à peine quinze jours maintenant il
faut éviter que ce soit le tour du
burkina faso alors on entend aussi
l'appel de christian cambon le président
au sénat de la commission de la défense
qui réclament l'aide d'autres pays
européens surtout des aides un des
moyens en hommes
est ce que ça peut être quelque chose
qui peut se passer dans les prochaines
semaines ça c'est à espérer c'est c'est
un constat que nous dressons la france
est bien seul dans dans ce conflit mais
j'ai le sentiment qu'un certain nombre
de pays voire de nombreux pays d'europe
ne se rendent pas compte que que ce que
l'on fait à l'heure actuelle dans le
sahel c'est ni plus ni moins qu assurer
notre propre liberté
c'est notre propre sécurité à nous l'a
simplement en france qui est en jeu et
donc à faire comprendre ça à d'autres
pays d'europe c'est indispensable moi je
milite pour ça ma question d'actualité à
l'époque
enfin iliad époque à quinze jours ne
portait que sur cela pas des moyens
supplémentaires de barkan
franchement on n'a pas beaucoup plus à m
ont fait déjà quatre mille hommes là-bas
bien et on en est appelé toutes parts je
citais le burkina faso si on pouvait
être au burkina faso un peu plus présent
ils seraient ils seraient ravis
bien sûr on va ce quasi consensus
politique en france sur le fait qu'il
faut continuer l'opération barkan il ya
la france soumise qui elle de son côté
appelle un débat et pour jean luc
mélenchon il ya une perte de sens dans
cet organe dans cette opération qu'est
ce que vous répondez aux leaders de la
france soumise m'écoutais je ne sais pas
qu'est ce qu'il entend par perdre deux
sens moi j'ai eu l'occasion d'aller dans
ces pays à l'une ou l'autre occasion
tout particulièrement au mali à gao près
de l'endroit de ce drame moi j'ai vu
qu'il y avait du sens moi j'ai vu qu'il
y avait une armée française qui qui
étaient là pour pour faire du bon
travail et qui le fait et je n'ose pas
penser à l'état dans laquelle seraient
l'afrique de l'ouest à l'heure actuelle
si la france n'y avait pas été et je
répète c'est absolument anormal que nous
y soyons seul merci beaucoup andré
reichardt et on verra dans l'hémicycle
induira des questions qui seront
consacrés à la situation au mali
effectivement nous allons avoir
l'occasion de revenir sur cette question
du mali tout au long de cette émission
mais pour l'heure on va passer aux
premiers débats de cette émission alors
que le sénat est en plein débat
budgétaire
on va s'intéresser à cette question le
budget 2020 est il vraiment vers le
gouvernement fait valoir des efforts à
la hauteur de l'urgence climatique érigé
en priorité mais les associations jugent
que le compte n'y est pas pas facile d'y
voir clair dans la bataille des chiffres
mais on va essayer avec la dernière
difficile de savoir combien le
gouvernement entend vraiment consacré à
l'écologie
l'exécutif vente les 32,2 milliards
d'euros affecté au ministère de la
transition écologique soit une
augmentation de plus de 800 millions
d'euros pour 2020 moi je vois plutôt une
ambition une ambition une volonté qui
est celle aujourd'hui du gouvernement
que de mener à bien cette nécessaire
transition écologique mais surtout de
mener ce qu'on appelle la transition
écologique et solidaire parce que il n'y
aura de transition que si effectivement
le mot solidaire est affirmé et
réaffirmé et on le voit dans le cadre
des mesures qui seront proposées pour ce
projet de loi de finances 2009
l'opposition dénonce un affichage cette
somme incluant certaines dépenses sans
rapport avec l'écologie
et quand bercy additionne ministère par
ministère tous les crédits affectés à la
transition écologique
le résultat paraît moins ambitieux 16,4
milliards d'euros seulement
des sommes qui restent en tout cas loin
des objectifs annoncés dans une feuille
de route du gouvernement l'an dernier
qui chiffrait des besoins en matière de
transition énergétique entre 45 et 85
milliards d'euros par an il faut la
volonté politique
ensuite les chiffres en face et comment
avec les moyens que l'on là parce qu'ils
ne sont pas exponentielle
comment
on fait nos politiques et là on est
véritablement dans la question du choix
politique d'autant que les recettes
fiscales sont bien là en 2018 l'ensemble
de la fiscalité écologique avait
rapporté plus de 50 milliards d'euros à
l'état d'après la cour des comptes alors
ce budget il à la hauteur de l'urgence
climatique on va en débattre avec quatre
invités sur ce plateau j'ai eu le
plaisir d'accueillir jean françois
husson
bonjour vous êtes sénateur l ère de la
meurthe et moselle vice président de la
commission des finances également avec
nous rendent en tête
bonjour sénateurs au groupe ps de la
loire atlantique vice président de la
commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
match crypte bienvenus vous êtes
secrétaire général de l'union des
démocrates et des écologistes
vous êtes assez proche de la majorité
actuelle sur les questions
environnementales et enfin anne
bringault vous êtes responsable
transition énergétique du réseau action
climat tout d'abord première question
pour vour dantec est ce vraiment un
budget vert tout simplement non non
c'est pas un budget qui va permettre
d'atteindre des objectifs même tout le
monde le sait je crois je crois surtout
dans le dernier chiffre 1 qui est citée
dans le reportage que la fiscalité
écologique aujourd'hui c'est plus de 50
milliards 56 58 milliards ça c'est les
recettes pour l'état les dépenses liées
à l'environnement en ne reprenant même
que le budget du ministère de
l'environnement de la transition
écologique et solidaire
c'est dans les 30 milliards donc je
crois que meilleure mini star est à 30
milliards et même on a fait un calcul et
on remet de l'autre mais moi je crois
que les français ont compris et ça a été
tout le débat sur la contribution
carbone et ça a été un débat douloureux
puisque on a bloqué cette fiscalité qui
était une fiscalité importante
les français ont compris en filant aux
mangues la fiscalité que le gym ne
servait pas la transition mais un à
boucler le budget de l'état et qu'à
partir de là il n'y a pas de contre il
n'y a pas de contrat social politique
démocratique entre les français et le
gouvernement fasse a pas commencé que
sur ce gouvernement c'est sur le fait de
faire un effort de fiscalité
environnementale mais d'avoir derrière
les moyens qui vont avec donc je crois
que ce budget est encore une fois un peu
sur eux mêmes bases que les budgets
qu'on a pu dénoncer les années
précédentes
une révolution écologique dans ce budget
non non et y compris pour les
territoires mais c'est avec jean fin
solution m'a mené le combat tous les ans
on pourra le reprendre la rochelle on
verrait pas vous êtes vous êtes d'accord
là-dessus il n'y a pas une fiscalité qui
était à la hauteur on à nous regarder
les chiffres alors c'est vrai vous avez
dit il ya le budget du ministère il est
aux alentours de 30 milliards d'euros
elhorga aussi en baisse oui il est en
baisse et si on additionne tous les
crédits affectés à la transition
écologique
on est arrivé à 16,4 milliards d'euros
et le gouvernement fait valoir qu'il ya
800 millions euros de plus par rapport à
l'an dernier et lé bruit ou peut-être
les trouver où sont ils en ont d'abord
c'est inexact tout ça c'est un peu de la
poudre de perlimpinpin pas dire qu'on a
mis quelques missions nouvelles
et puis on fait de l'habillage et
française ont compris deux choses ils
ont exprimé dans le quinquennat
précédent notamment les bretons sur
l'écotaxe art fut alors que je le dis
quand même alors que le parlement
s'était prononcé à l'unanimité
quand il ya eu l'augmentation le
raidissement de la taxe carbone j'ai
personnellement mis en garde il ya deux
ans c'était en novembre 2010 est au
premier budget présenté par le
gouvernement et donc pas gérald darmanin
en fait vous ne pouvez aujourd'hui c'est
un contrat parce qu'on a un changement
de logiciel
aujourd'hui on doit être écologique et
on doit combiner économie et je dirais
questions sociales et sociétales
c'est ma page est celle des noms mais le
défi il y là parce qu'en fait si vous
regardez bien on a un gouvernement qui
est pas là depuis trois ans j'ai eu
trois ministres de l'écologie oui je
cherchais juste les robes et on est
passé d'un nicolas hulot à françois de
rugy à elizabeth banks et pas forcément
la même notoriété entre le premier et la
dernière mathieu cuite votre vous votre
votre avis sur ce budget est il vraiment
revers je vous ai senti plutôt acquiescé
quand on a quand on entend ce que j'ai
demandé ça non mais forcément quand vous
augmentez un budget de 800 millions
d'euros il ya une amélioration qui est
notable mais où l'augmentation
positionnement l'a pas vu et lé ou pour
dent
dans d'abord vous avez donc un budget à
32 milliards on peut regarder en détail
on est dans une bataille de chiffres
chacun amène ses chiffres ronan dantec
le disais on a fait un sujet on en est
on est nous mêmes pas exactement sur les
crédits
le gouvernement annonce une hausse une
augmentation de 800 millions d'euros du
budget du miss à la transition
écologique
il ya de nouveaux crédits notamment
affecté l agence française de la
biodiversité
il ya 5 milliard et demi d'euros sur sur
les énergies renouvelables parce que le
gouvernement veut pousser veut pousser
là dessus vous dites non moi je vous dis
oui on est dans vous parliez sur la
question sociale
évidemment le budget il se doit aussi
d'être sociale et la question de
l'augmentation plus encore de ce budget
elle est liée évidemment au fait que
nous avons dû revenir sur la taxe
carbone justement parce qu'on a entendu
la grogne de l'année dernière déjà les
jaunes et 4 milliards ou cap milliard et
demi qui était affecté normalement à
cette taxe carbone elle va sont pas
rentrés dans les caisses de l'état pour
faire plus encore mais au fond ce budget
est quand même une amélioration
vous vous dites non je dis oui c'est une
amélioration par rapport au budget de
l'an dernier une amélioration par
rapport au budget de l'an dernier anne
bringault vous votre avis on sait que
beaucoup d'associations sont plutôt
déçus parce qu'il y avait les annonces
un budget à la hauteur et puis la
réalité vous c'est clairement pas un
budget vert on n'a pas assez d'argent
pour rénover les logements notamment
pour les plus précaires on n'a pas assez
d'argent pour accompagner tous les
ménages pour les aider techniquement et
financièrement à rénover leur logement
on n'a pas assez d'argent pour les
accompagner vers des changements du
véhicule ouvert des autres mobilité les
transports en commun je parlerai pas des
lignes de train les les pistes cyclables
tout ça ça manque cruellement et on a au
contraire donné plutôt ouvert la brèche
à des financements privés avec les
certificats d'économie d'énergie qui
sortent du coup de du budget public
pierre on a en fait c'est plus de 16
milliards qui vont à des activités
néfastes pour le climat c'est à dire
qu'on donne au moins autant pour ce qui
est contraire au climat que ce qui est
pour le climat par exemple des niches
fiscales sur le transport aérien par
exemple des niches fiscales sur le
transport de fret
transport routier de marchandises tout
cet argent là va alimenter les énergies
fossiles et finalement renforce le
système qui fait qu'on va continuer à
utiliser des màj fossiles pire la france
finance les projets d'énergies fossiles
à l'étranger non seulement en france on
n'est pas exempt clamé en plus on va
garantir à l'export des projets
d'exploitation ou de centrales qui
utilisent les énergies fossiles
donc on n'est pas du tout sur un budget
verbe bien au contraire nous vous jugez
que le gouvernement ment lorsqu'il dit
que c'est un budget à la hauteur de
l'urgence il fait clairement du
greenwashing
il en est parfaitement conscient alors
vous en avez parlé tout à l'heure de la
question des gilet jaune c'est important
de cibler les bonnes priorités dé mettre
suffisamment d'argent et de faire
accepter cela aux français le sujet
c'est de ne pas crispés les français
face à une fiscalité verte qui a été
vécu là comme punitive par beaucoup et
qui a été l'étincelle donc pour
déclencher le mouvement des gilets
jaunes cet épisode a été rappelé cette
semaine par albéric de montgolfier le
rapporteur général du budget on écoute
et on en parle juste après ceddat est
particulièrement jeudi devant jean
françois buisson qui s'est exprimé en
premier par tirman légitime pour traiter
cette question parce que il a été le
premier à alerter sur l'augmentation
pluriannuel de l'énergie à travers ce
qui s'était passé notamment sur la
fiscalité de la tpe et sa non pas des la
dernière mais dès le plf d'il ya deux
ans où jean françois husson avait dit
attention
une augmentation qui ne seraient pas
compensés par ailleurs par un
accompagnement des français auraient des
conséquences risquerait de provoquer des
mouvements vous le savez à l'époque il
avait dit de bonnets rouges et
finalement nous avons eu des gilets
jaunes
j'en prends ça ils sont vous êtes un peu
la madame irma du sénat ronan dantec
vous aussi tarte
albéric de montgolfier n'a pas parlé de
vous mais vous aviez exactement donné
l'alerté au même moment vous aviez
n'avons que des madame irma
alors jean françois husson vous avez vu
arriver le mouvement des gilet jaune de
loin pour vous quel a été à ce moment là
l'erreur du gouvernement
mais l'erreur n'est pas reproduire
l'erreur du gouvernement c'est que vous
allez voir je crains qui se passe à une
chose sur les retraites il faut
aujourd'hui on est devant un changement
de modèle de société de consommation et
il faut le faire progressivement et il
faut associer nos concitoyens parce que
moi je pense que l'économie doit passer
sur un modèle plus décarbonée on voit
également que il faut associer
l'ensemble des parties prenantes donc
les collaborateurs des entreprises
les chefs d'entreprise et puis les
collectivités or aujourd'hui on est dans
l'incantation dans l'ordre et notamment
dans la punition
qu'est ce que vous voulez dire la taxe
carbone elle était déjà avec une
trajectoire qui était on demandait de
vrais efforts le gouvernement a fait le
choix de dire on le vote une fois et
pour cinq ans on a la majorité depuis
trois mois dont vous allez pas nous
faire la leçon voulait modeste
parlementaire en plus très honnêtement
quand on est pas du nouveau monde et que
vous venez au sénat on a quand même
l'impression de représenter le monde
d'avant-hier et je pense au contraire
qu'on est en contact avec les français
et les réalités et donc aujourd'hui il
faut absolument partager les réflexions
il faut donner des lignes directrices et
il faut le consolider par des pactes
avec l'ensemble des parties prenantes
parce que même je le dis le parlement
tout seul ne suffit pas les deux
assemblées ça ne suffit pas redondante
est qu il faut effectivement accompagné
les français car le problème de la
fiscalité écologique c'est que elle est
socialement injustes elles pèsent plus
sur les ménages modestes en proportion
que sur les ménages aisés on va garder
un graphique de l'inspection générale
des finances sur ce graphique on voit
qu'elle représente 80 que le 6 % du
revenu pour un ménage modeste et là on
voit que le revenu de plus en plus
élevés et 1,1 pour cent pour les plus
riches
c'est donc essentiel de soutenir et
d'accompagner à bas il y avait un
symbole alors le gouvernement un petit
peu bougé sur ce point puisqu'il a
repris est le mécanisme que nous nous
avions proposé
au sénat sur la taxation de l'aérien
mais quand on disait aux français qu'ils
modeste qui partait en voiture à nice
parce qu'ils n'avaient pas les moyens de
se payer l'avion qui paye la taxe
carbone et que ceux qui a les moyens de
se payer quatre billets d'avion ne la
paient pas ce niveau d'injustice sociale
évidemment au bout d'un moment ça finit
par nous péter à la figure
mais je crois que le problème principal
qu'on a et qui à mon ami n'est pas réglé
et là c'est de la responsabilité du
président de la république et du premier
ministre de donner des consignes très
claires c'est que pour bercy l'enjeu
c'est pas la transition énergétique et
climatique et rend donc le budget oui et
que effectivement à partir du moment où
la taxe carbone a été vue comme une
vache à lait qu'on n'a pas une histoire
derrière y compris de la redistribution
on avait proposé une double resterez de
redistribution m'avait proposé de rendre
extrêmement vers l'est les territoires
c'est quelque chose que j'avais lancé
avec le maire de dunkerque est
l'adjointe de bordeaux au moment des
assises de l'énergie c'était il ya 4 5
ans dire si vous n'aimez pas les
territoires on est de rendre
obligatoires les les plans climat
ça ne va pas passer là le gouvernement a
dit non et 100 francs solution qui étais
tu lui aussi a remis avec christine
lagarde
l'amendement compass tous les ans
l'unamité on va voir ce qui va se passer
à l'assemblée
mais là ils ne nous ont pas entendus ils
ne nous ont pas entendus sur la
redistribution un chèque énergie un
chèque transport et derrière ils ont
perdu beaucoup d'argent parce que cette
fiscalité là et quand même une fiscalité
intéressante pour modifier les
comportements à partir des effectivement
au moment où on répond aux eaux aux
injustices sociales qu'elle peut créer
mais là on a un gouvernement et bercy je
pense aujourd'hui sincèrement on en fait
encore bouger son logiciel sa priorité
c'est par la transition qu'il mâtine
mathieu crypte est ce que bercy a bougé
son logiciel ou est ce qu'ils continuent
à utiliser et bien tout ce budget pour
justement le boucler toutes séries tout
cela pour simplement pour boucler le
budget rssi et l'administration fiscale
peut porter une politique ce n'est pas
celle que porte le premier nid sous
présent de la république à bompas
commentaires signés
attendez c'est le président de la
république qui impulsent une politique a
fortiori il s'implique aujourd'hui
beaucoup sur les questions écologiques
c'est mieux qu'en début de quinquennat
c'est sûr sur la question des gilets
jaunes évidemment qu'il y avait une
urgence sociale et que cette question de
fiscalité écologique elle est venue au
fond comme une étincelle sur un
ras-le-bol fiscal qui était global qui
datent pas évidemment du début du
quinquennat mais qui avait déjà commencé
bien avant sous le quinquennat
chirac sarkozy hollande etc etc en
particulier sur les territoires ruraux
moi même je suis impliqué dans la région
centre val de loire dans un département
très rural
je vois bien où on a vu là le départ de
l'état tout ça ce sont des questions qui
sont très liées parce qu'il ya plus de
transports publics à plus de trains que
je rejoins ronan dantec et j'ai un
désaccord avec le gouvernement là dessus
c'est effectivement donné aux
territoires plus de pouvoir plus de
moyens accompagner les territoires parce
que en réalité c'est souvent les
territoires ils sont cependant l'équipe
du changement climatique est en première
ligne sur sur les solutions à apporter
anne bringault en tout cas le
gouvernement on ne sait pas exactement
ce qu'il fait mais en tout cas ce qu'il
dit c'est qu'il communique beaucoup
regardé il ya un fascicule comme cette
année tiennent là pour accompagner le
projet de finances 2010 a livré de la
transition écologique il fait valoir
tous azimuts que le gouvernement
favorise la biodiversité qui va vers une
agriculture biologique et durable
un plan transport une politique
énergétique ambitieuse
anne bringault qu'est ce que vous pensez
je ne commenterai les slogans de ce beau
dépliants par contre sur la fiscalité
c'est important d'avoir en tête que les
français ce qu'ils veulent c'est une
transition est une transition qui soit
juste et une fiscalité juste il centre à
faire des efforts mais il faut que ces
efforts soient équitablement répartis
c'était pas le cas vous l'avez montré
c'est le plus modestes et ceux qui
vivent en milieu rural qui est des
analyses en cinq ans donc ils font que
l'art jeunes qu'ils soient collectées
aille vers la transition vers des
nouveaux véhicules va des mobilités
différentes va la rénovation des
logements pour baisser la facture
d'énergie des ménages
et il faut aussi que cette fiscalité
touche d'autres secteurs l'aviation qui
ne payent pas il faut faire une taxe
c'est très insuffisant
le remplacement des radars du cnca
suffire à changer il faut augmenter le
prix de l'avion et baisser le prix du
train c'est pas logique actuellement ça
soit quatre fois moins cher de prendre
l'avion alors que prendre le train est
beaucoup plus écologique il faut
également pour les ménages qui n'ont pas
que ça un choix qui nous sont obligés de
prendre la voiture pour aller travailler
et bien qu'ils aient une redistribution
une sorte de chèque énergie pour
attendre le moment où il y aura des
véhicules moins polluants véhicules
électriques ou biogaz qui seront
accessibles en occasions par exemple
pour ces ménages
donc il ya vraiment des solutions par
contre c'est une solution globale et qui
soit juste qu'il faut travailler pour
moi moi j'ai vu le veut le slogan la
biodiversité une priorité les le nombre
de salariés des parcs nationaux va
encore baisser cette année remonte tous
les territoires
la souffrance des agents dans les parcs
nationaux qui n'arrivent plus à mener
leurs actions sur la protection de
l'environnement dans des lieux tout à
fait remarquable les moyens sur le
risque d dréal on l'a vu avec le
brizault ils sont en baisse aussi depuis
plusieurs années ça c'est un chiffre or
ce chiffre là dans le budget il est
clair le nombre de salariés diminue
l'état et ça c'est essentiel parce que
les questions environnementales s'est
beaucoup d'animations il faut beaucoup
accompagnés donc on a besoin de temps
humain et ça c'est en train de baisser
fortement
on ne passait pas anecdotique ça
décrédibilise complètement tout le
discours pareil donc il faut arrêter
avec la baisse des postes
et effectivement on a quand même un
budget qui est dans la continuité d'un
état dont la priorité je les ai déjà dit
c'est simplement le déficit la réponse à
mathieu clip effectivement est-ce que ça
fait même un peu désordre d'avoir toutes
ces suppressions de postes au ministère
de l'environnement 800 suppressions de
postes dont une partie chez les
opérateurs et une partie effectivement
de région betsiboka surveillance dont
météo-france absolument ses rêves dont
évidemment l'ensemble des ministères
doit faire un effort par rapport à la
bonne gestion budgétaire et dans un
deuxième temps une partie des postes qui
sont supprimés au sein du ministère de
la transition écologique sont en réalité
réaffecté au ministère de l'intérieur
justement pour permettre une
mutualisation des secrétariats généraux
communs notamment pour pour les
territoires et vous emportez zéro
crédits sur ce que vous dites là
des gens des parcs nationaux au
ministère de l'intérieur mais vous
caricaturez non je vous dire que sur les
1 800 postes dont vous êtes que vous
évoquez il y en a 400 effectivement au
ministère qui sont qui sont aujourd'hui
en administration centrale et pas sur
les territoires et basse et caresser son
administration en disant tout ça vous
perdez linge c'est une explication que
vous êtes bien le slogan je donne une
explication
attendez vous me dites il ya une
réduction d'effectifs vous dis oui une
réduction d'effectifs mais sur le
chiffres qui seront annoncés vous aviez
évoqué 800 postes en jeu la roue 97 je
voudrais je vous répond qu'à une partie
de ces postes là où effectivement il ya
une suppression de poste et une autre
parti ou d'une réaffectation de ces
postes un transfert au ministère de
l'intérieur pour permettre une
mutualisation entre l'intérieur et la
transition coliques notamment pour les
territoires pour conclure je
souhaiterais que nous puissions
également nous projeter un petit peu sur
l'avenir un car il ya eu un rapport du
programme des nations unies pour
l'environnement qui a été rendu public
déjà envoyé cette citation de matthieu
orphelin qui n'exclut de la majorité est
en marche il avait déclaré il a déclaré
un vrai budget vert c'est un budget qui
investit assez dans la transition
écologique est compatible avec une
limitation du réchauffement climatique à
un degré et demi on en est encore loin
et regarder justement et bien cette
courbe si nous poursuivons nos émissions
de gaz à effet de serre au rythme actuel
on arrive à une augmentation de 3,4 à
3,9 degrés ça on parle de l'ensemble du
monde on arrive à une augmentation de
3,5 degrés s'ils ont su d'accord de
paris et pour arriver à contenir
l'augmentation des températures a
réellement là où il le faudrait il
faudra stick mans changer nos habitudes
regardez comme il faut il faut une
inversion de la courbe véritablement
anne bringault c'est vrai que ça fait
des années qu'on dit qu'il faut changer
qu'il y a urgence alors si on l'avait
fait il ya dix ans la courbe elle sera
un peu plus plane
maintenant on arrive vraiment au bord de
la falaise soit on se jette dans le vide
mais effectivement ça va être un petit
peu douloureux soit on attend encore
plus mais alors là on va vers la
catastrophe alors dix ans est balancé
maintenant jour tout ordre
maintenant l'empreinte carbone des
français c'est-à-dire les émissions
liées à nos consommations elle
n'augmente pas on à ox et exporter nos
émissions qui sont qui viennent des
produits qu'on importe mais finalement
ce que l'on aimait en ou en français
avec notre consommation ne baisse pas
par ailleurs on a des tendances qui sont
très négatives
la moyenne d'émission des véhicules
neufs en france en 2018 elle était
supérieure aux émissions d'un même
véhicule neuf en 2016 le transport
routier sa part augmente alors qu'on
devrait développer on a dans nos
objectifs de développer le fret
ferroviaire et le fret fluvial
donc on est vraiment sur une trajectoire
qui ne va pas dans le bon sens il faut
être très conscient du fait qu'il va
falloir sortir des énergies fossiles
donc se déplacer autrement se chauffer
au proment et réduire les émissions de
l'agriculture ça veut dire réduire
l'élevage et la consommation de viande
et réduire les engrais azotés ce sont
vraiment les axes principaux et on ne va
pas pouvoir passer à côté ortec vous qui
avez travaillé sur les conséquences
qu'aurait le réchauffement climatique
qu'est ce que ça voudrait dire
concrètement un tel réchauffement des
températures
ah bah si on est à + 4 degrés nos
modèles sociétaux ne survivent pas c'est
à dire qu'on n'est pas juste a traité
des îlots de chaleur ou des sécheresses
on est sur des crises mondiales telles
que probablement un moment il ya
quelqu'un qui appuie sur le bouton
nucléaire pour provoquer un hiver
nucléaire donc
donc il faut absolument qu'on trouve une
solution on a un gouvernement qui dit
beaucoup
aujourd'hui le président parle beaucoup
sur ces sujets là moi je continue de
discuter avec ce gouvernement il a
encore pour quelques années et on n'a
pas le temps d'attendre un gouvernement
qui nous serait un plus favorable et
notamment c'est quand même sur la
question je crois de l'économie mondiale
et des grands accords de libre échange
que ça va se jouer
emmanuel macron la tribune de l'onu dit
il n'y aura plus d'accords de
libre-échange qui ne respectent pas la
transition énergétique et climatique
j'attends donc du président et de son
gouvernement qui réponde à ça mais c'est
extrêmement douloureux parce que ça va
contre tous les intérêts économiques de
court terme mais à l'échelle mondiale il
y à des pays qui ont des résultats on a
aussi publié le rapport climate change
sur l'action fait de lundi 2019 on voit
qu'il ya des pays qui ont de vrais
résultats mais qui mettent toute leur
politique en cohérence
il faut absolument que l'économie
mondiale soit régulée par la question
climatique
c'est dans le discours du gouvernement
sait pas encore dans les zones qui
accueille ce sont des modèles à suivre
ces pays qui ont changé radicalement de
modèle il faut évidemment transformé
notre modèle mais on est quand même dans
une discussion qui est globale ronan
dantec le disais quand vous regardez
aujourd'hui la chine ou l'inde où un
certain nombre de pays émergents leur
modèle s'est transformée extrêmement
rapidement en prenant le mauvais chemin
et aujourd'hui effectivement le modèle
français
pendant que cette alliance est
aujourd'hui l'inde est pas comparable à
la mède plus alors propre mais que les
classes moyennes européennes c'est pas
qu'une question de transfert de
production séquence est aussi une
politique mondiale qu'il faut qu'il faut
coordonner et c'est le cas notamment jan
kopp qui arrivent là en espagne et c'est
dans ces discussions internationales
qu'il faut aussi poussé et pour le coup
le président de la république le fait
sur la question des accords de libre
échange notamment sur les toits on va le
voir sur le site de plus en plus de
clause sur le géant médias sur le ceta
et mercure sourd il ya un vrai retour en
arrière puisque finalement la majorité
en marche à l'assemblée avait voté ça en
godillots
moi je crois qu'il fait ce constat non
non non il faut arrêter la prise de
conscience aujourd'hui faut agir enfin
honnêtement ça me vient à tous qui va
pas demander juste vous dire qu'on jette
non pas du tout je nous invite
collectivement depuis le début depuis
des années à regarder avec plus de
vigilance
les modèles vers lesquels on doit
évoluer je vais vous dire c'est pas ni
en marche ni personne qui va me donner à
titre personnel il nous donner aux
français des leçons moi je crois qu'il
ya un vrai sujet
le sujet c'est aujourd'hui la france
doit peser plus en europe et il faut
absolument que l'europe et je crois
qu'elle est en train de le faire soit
quelque part notre porte étendard parce
qu'il faut peser dans la compétition
mondiale
et si l'ambition de l'europe elle est
aussi de travailler sur ces enjeux
climatiques
ça nous rendra plus forts ensemble la
france sera forte si l'europe est forte
il ya aussi ce message là enfin moi je
veux tordre le cou aux populistes de
tous poils qui considère qu'il faut être
replié sur soi et en vouloir à tout le
monde ça suffit il faut être offensif il
faut se bagarrer il faut le faire pour
l'écologie parce que l'écologie c'est la
vie et la vie c'est l'avenir de la
société
eh bien merci beaucoup à tous les cadres
d'avoir par
si paix à ce débat merci jean françois
husson merci ronan dantec merci anne
bringault et merci à mathieu kuip nous
allons également passé à présent aux
faits politiques du jour le débat sur
les retraites sortis du flou après avoir
reçu les partenaires sociaux pendant
deux jours le premier ministre et d'un
philippe à tout à l'heure
dis toute sa détermination il est un
petit peu précisé le calendrier des
annonces ont l'écoutant je voudrais dire
que nous sommes plus que jamais si j'ose
dire
déterminé à construire ce système
universel de retraite parce que cette
réforme est une réforme de justice
sociale construire un système universel
de retraite
ça n'est pas réformer notre système
actuel c'est le refonder le refonder
pour qu'ils soient plus justes et plus
solide tout au long de ces discussions
nous avons rappelé le principe
fondamental qui sous tend ce projet de
société
remplacer les 42 régime existant par un
système unique et universel commun à
tous les français et dont les règles
seront les mêmes pour tous cette
déclaration du premier ministre est
intervenue à une semaine de la journée
de grève du 5 décembre le gouvernement
d'ailleurs se mobiliser hier le premier
ministre a remobilisé les parlementaires
de la majorité avec un mot d'ordre on ne
lâche rien mario vigreux après le
conseil des ministres de ce matin le
compte à rebours est bel et bien lancée
dans huit jours le 5 décembre c'est une
grève dure qui se profile contre la
réforme des retraites
conséquence le gouvernement se met en
ordre de bataille
ce mardi soir edouard philippe recevait
à huit clos les parlementaires de la
majorité
objectif faire le point sur l'avancée
des discussions avec les partenaires
sociaux mais surtout exhorté ses troupes
à faire bloc autour de la réforme la
majorité qui étaient toutes représentées
ici sénat et assemblée est extrêmement
déterminé pour que cette réforme soit
réussie le fait qu'elle soit réussie
implique qu'on ne relâchent rien de
l'attention que nous portons aux forces
syndicales et aux français
cette détermination doit répondre à
celles des syndicats qui évoquent une
montée en puissance
mobilisation depuis très très longtemps
on n'avait jamais eu autant de demandes
notamment de salariés dans les
entreprises où il n'y avait pas de
syndicats qui voulaient savoir comment
participer 5 décembre par exemple dans
les bouches du rhône il ya déjà 2 145
appel à la grève dont 80 reconductible
de son côté face aux parlementaires le
premier ministre rappelle les éléments
de langage et les invite à faire de la
pédagogie dans leur circonscription
être sur le terrain auprès des citoyens
pour partager la solidarité qui lie à au
travers de ce projet de société qui doit
permettre aux retraités les plus
modestes de voir leur pension
revalorisée c'est déjà l'essentiel de
notre engagement pour les jours qui
viennent et compris avant le 5
prochain rendez vous pour le
gouvernement un séminaire ce dimanche à
matignon pour fixer la feuille de route
et à une semaine des manifestations du 5
décembre on va parler vient de la
réforme des retraites avec rené paul
savary bonjour bonjour vous êtes
sénateur et l'air de la main de vice
président de la commission des affaires
sociales et rapporteur retraite pour
cette même commission également sur ce
plateau et chariots ou bonjour
initiateurs la république en marche
représentant les français établis hors
de france vous étiez d'ailleurs hier à
cette réunion avec les parlementaires de
la majorité alors que vous a dit le
premier ministre
est-ce qu'il a re mobiliser les troupes
est ce que les troupes elle en avait
besoin
oui surtout je pense qu'il a un discours
très très offensif
une grande partie de ce qu'il a dit
était au fond un compte rendu des
entretiens qu'ils avaient eu le lundi et
le mardi avec l'ensemble des
organisations syndicales
je vais pas rentrer dans les détails
mais enfin nous a fait un tableau au
fond assez nuancé sur les résultats de
ces de ses contacts avec bien sûr
certains certaines forces syndicales qui
sont tout à fait opposés au projet à
l'universalité etc
mais d'autres qui sont qui a qui amènent
des propositions qui sont prêts à
discuter tout à l'heure d'ailleurs le
premier ministre a dit qu'il avait eu un
échange très riche de très grande
qualité avec les partenaires sociaux il
a même dit
bien les or il a cité entre les
partenaires sociaux a dit les ententes
sur les droits familiaux l'emploi des
seniors la pénibilité c'est un
gouvernement allait qu'outre n'est pas
le savoir et à écouter dans une réforme
sociétale aussi importante
elle vaut mieux être à l'écouté la
réforme doit faire plus tôt avec la
société avec ceux qui les représentent
et partenaires sociaux que contre eux
j'ai pas si elle est cool mais
apparemment il a quand même un certain
nombre de personnes qui sont contre la
réforme alors qu'on ne connaît pas
encore les tenants et les aboutissants
oui on a des préconisations une vaste un
mode de calcul complètement différent
parce que le système pare passe quand
même pas pareil que celui que l'on
connaît sur la même trajectoire
budgétaire ce qui veut dire que si on
prend pas un certain nombre de mesures
le compte n'y est pas donc ce sont tous
ces problèmes qu'il faut encore régler
donc aujourd'hui on va voir moi je ne
suis pas madame irma non justement sur
un mot sur la méthode quand même on a
beaucoup parlé et bien du flou de la
cacophonie au sein du gouvernement par
exemple ce qui a pu avoir sur la clause
du grand-père vous qu'est ce que vous
pensez de la façon dont le gouvernement
est bien à préparer cette réforme avec
avec et effectivement ce flouquet
beaucoup et qu'elle soit écoutez moi je
trouve que c'était bien parti j'ai été
personnellement associé au déplacement
de jean paul delevoye il a fait une
concertation large de notre côté j'ai
commencé moi faire des auditions puisque
étant désignés à l'avant ce qui montre
que le sénat est prêt à avancer dans la
dimension des retraites
et puis et puis bah ça traîne ça fait
maintenant presque deux ans quoi donc y
arrive à un moment elle concerne ce
genre vous passez à un moment à l'action
pascal à force de tergiverser on a
l'impression que les semaines et les
mois perdus font qu'un doute s'installe
dans l'esprit des gens elle doute ça
peut être quoi ça peut être demain on
nous cache quelque chose pour qu'on
n'arrive pas pourquoi on n'arrive pas à
le sortir
si c'est une réforme qui est plus juste
plus équitable tout le monde devra
prouver aux dires des deux mains alors
c'est pas le cas donc il faut faire
attention à tout cela c'est que
l'incertitude est sûre ce souvent
d'inquiétude et oui c'était un vrai une
grande difficulté pour le gouvernement
on a commencé à avoir des annonces en
tout à l'heure richard you puisque et
d'un philippe a dit qu'ils auraient bien
jean paul delevoye qui interviendrait
vers le 10 décembre qu'après dans
philippe l'a lui-même rendre ses
arbitrages
on devrait connaître le texte au début
de l'année prochaine devrait mettre
sciemment je peux bien sûr j'en reçois
sur ou pas c'est pas ben ouais c'est pas
moi qui suis je ne suis pas le maître
des horloges comme on dit maintenant
mais c'est effectivement dans ces eaux
là mi mi janvier les artistes raconter
ses arbitrages oui il est longtemps mais
en même temps alors quand on amène une
réforme qui est déjà ficelé on nous crie
dessus en disant c'est jupitérien sa
tombe du ciel c'est horrible il n'y a
pas de concertation et canton concerne
effectivement ça fait presque deux ans
que ça discute 350 réunions ont fait des
choses absolument extraordinaire alors
là on dit ah bah ça traîne c'est flou et
où il ya il reste un certain nombre de
questions centrales a tranché comme la
période de transition par exemple comme
il les rend progresse-t-il à la
sur les âges âge pivot âge légal fatous
et tous et tous ces points il ya deux ou
trois grandes caisses et puis l'
équilibre financier
voilà yahia a tranché c'est le chant
question là n'est pas le savoir eh oui
c'est des problèmes qui sûrement se sont
réglés faut pas être que goûter un peu
ce qu'un système c'est un système qui
doit s'équilibrer
si c'est pas par l'âge c'est un
augmenter les cotisations en baissant
les pensions ou il faut faire est
attentif c'est qu'il faut donner
confiance aux jeunes et donner notamment
mais aussi à l'ensemble de la population
dans un nouveau système un peu
révolutionnaire quand même donc pour
donner confiance ou des garanties de la
stabilité du système et l'assurance que
les retraites sont payées donc il faut
bien pouvoir dire au moins dans cinq dix
ans au moins qui livrait parce que si on
a qui lie pas avec des mesures d'âge on
fait quoi au monde et qu'il eut avec le
point problème la réforme pas point
saint système à rendement définit donc
l'équation entre le nombre de cotisants
qui n'arrête pas de diminuer le nombre
de pensionnés qui augmente avec une
durée plus longue
fait que si on touche pas c'est la
madame est en baisse la valeur du point
est en règle le dispositif
donc ce qui peut être la variable
d'ajustement en baissant le point vous
avez des retraites m dos que ça peut
être une garantie de faibles retraites
c'est pas la volonté du gouvernement me
semble-t-il
il veut garantir au moins un niveau de
vie moyen des retraités de demain il
faut quand même déjà consolidé me
semble-t-il au système qui soit bien
équilibrée quel que soit le mode de
calcul actuel où le futur mode de calcul
bien l'équilibré pièces pour lampard des
bases de confiance ou bien voir il y
aura des gagnants des perdants réussi à
limiter et puis on examine tout ça
tranquillement on aimerait mais c'est
une affaire complexe 1 on aimerait bien
qu'ils aient pas de perdant une des
idées que j'ai entendu qui circulent il
y aura nécessairement ceux qui ont
aujourd'hui un régime spécial ne
vont-ils pas y perdre à voir ceci dit
c'est vrai que dans un certain nombre de
régimes spéciaux
la réalité des choses c'est que
les cotisations du salarié couvre la
moitié de la dépense de ce qu'ils
reçoivent et c'est nous qui payons là ça
oui non mais oui fm enfin ils sont
déséquilibrés sur le plan démographique
donc il faut regarder du marché
historique un petit peu à vous parle a
opposé une bonne question parce que dans
un mode de calcul différent et pour que
la réforme soit et c'est à vous qu'il ya
deux mois le perdant possible ce qui
veut dire que si on veut le mois le
perdant possible pour mettre des sous
sur la table parce que automatiquement
il y aura aussi on ne nous dit plus de
solidarité les pensions plus base qui
seront rehaussés etc
on prend pas leur apogée là pour donner
la pause les autres ça c est donc faudra
mettre de l'argent sur la table donc
faut mettre de l'argent sur la table
bouclé l'incarnant possible faut mettre
de l'argent sur la table c'est estimer
quand même par le corps pour l'
équilibre donc ça fait des sommes qui
commence à devenir importante donc il
faut quand même nous expliquait un petit
peu où on va sur le plan de la
trajectoire financière
un équilibre qui émeut le corps dit
entre 7 et les autres 9 et 10 c'est
pourquoi c'est si large
moi je dois comprendre ces deux cours
d'analysé ça veut dire qu'à un moment
donné
voilà il faudra que ces sommes là
j'allais le dire tout à l'heure là je me
suis arrêté
c'est une possibilité c'est de comparer
le système actuel avec ce que donnera le
nouveau système est de voir
effectivement là où il y en a qui
gagnent et là où il y en a qui perdent
et sociale de mettre une clause de non
perte si j'ose dire un mot pour conclure
justement ça serait peut-être sur
quelque chose qui pourrait permettre
d'aller à l'encontre civilisations et
des manifestations un mot tout de même
sur cette manifestation du 5 décembre
on a beaucoup entendu le gouvernement
monte au créneau qui dénonçaient des
réflexes corporatistes là le premier
ministre d'un philippe tout à l'heure a
plutôt dit respecter un les grévistes et
la mobilisation
quel est votre sentiment par rapport à
cette mobilisation qui se prépare à qui
se prépare d'ampleur coûter dans une
démocratie c'est tout c'est normal on
peut ne pas être d'accord on peut dire
voilà et défendent
où ils pensent qu'ils défendent leur pré
carré leur position mais c'est normal il
faut pas non plus que ça met le pays
résultat voilà ce n'est pas le savoir et
vous votre avis sur cette contestation
nous sommes à une semaine du 5 décembre
c'est à dire que moi je pense qu'il faut
rassembler les gens et pas les divisent
et quand on dit qu'il y en a qu'on ait
un avantage par rapport à d'autres on
les divise quand on dit que la réforme
elle sera plus juste mais quand la
reporte à eau aux générations futures ça
veut dire qu'on maintient les inégalités
donc dans la proche du gouvernement faut
peut-être qu'ils améliorent leur
communication visiblement c'est pas
compris pourquoi d'accord pour viser les
bains voilà quand vous êtes dans la rue
vous discuté avec des gens dont j'en ai
encore pas trouvé à qui sautait sur sa
chaise on applaudit d'enseignement dire
que je souhaite bien quoi tout le monde
dit oui il y aura sûrement besoin
d'améliorer les choses de quitter
d'équilibrer le système de retraite de
garantir cela nos enfants mais les
efforts on sait bien qu'ils vont être à
partager donc derrière faut
impérativement être attentif à tout ça
est plutôt rassembler les gens que les
diviser parce que j'ai le sentiment moi
comme d'autres que le mans va être dur
et long elles ont alors plus en
tergiversant - koné les choses vous
savez l'anxiété est source
un peu de fantasmes parfois donc il vaut
mieux dire la vérité aux gens même si
c'est demain je ne sais pas moi j'ai
invente un demain on dit aux gens il
faut travailler plus longtemps
ils sont peut-être capable de comprendre
faut pas les prendre pour des billes
quand même bien disons la vérité puis on
annonce quoi sinon
ouais enfin met au clair
moi je pense que le la proposition qui
sur la baie effectivement sans doute i
am un petit manque de pédagogie
parce que telle que je la comprends elle
a une valeur universelle
elle est la même pour exactement tout le
monde tous les travailleurs quels qu'ils
soient pas simplement les salariés pas
seulement le public le privé mais aussi
les professions libérales et ce sera
exactement le même système c'est quand
même quelque chose qui est plus juste et
plus équitable les gens devraient ça
devrait unifier le pays
savary va pas vous dire annonce sa
retraite parfois tout à fait et puis le
système par points est sûrement plus
égalitaire sauf que c'est la transition
qui fait parce que il ya une histoire
banale peillon ces mecs faut être
sensible
il ya parfois vaut mieux avancer par
petites touches pour arriver à ses fins
que de faire une grosse révolution où
finalement on arrive à ce que les mâles
constitué soyons prudents dieu merci
beaucoup monsieur d'avoir participé à ce
face à face sur la question des
retraites un sujet dont on va avoir
l'occasion de reparler bien sûr autre
mobilisation celle des agriculteurs
plus d'un millier de tracteurs ont
convergé vers paris aujourd'hui certains
sont même arrivés sur les champs-elysées
l'objectif des manifestants interpellés
l'exécutif et la grande distribution
alors que commencent les négociations
commerciales qui fixe les prix pour un
an tout de suite et bien nous allons
rejoindre quentin calmer salle des
conférences à votre micro michel raison
michel raison qui a travaillé à faire un
bilan de la loi agriculture et
alimentation c'est un texte qui devait
permettre aux agriculteurs de sortir de
la crise d'évidence à n'a pas tout à
fait marcher oui tout à fait puisqu'il
manifeste effectivement aujourd'hui tu
as mal à michel raison bonjour vous
étiez rapporteur de cette loi et gally
mais aussi donc en charge ce suivi de la
loi et galim qu'est-ce qui n'a pas
fonctionné avec cette loi qui descend
c'est comme ça rééquilibrer les pouvoirs
entre les forces entre entre les
agriculteurs et la grande distribution
or déjà la première remarque c'est que
de toute façon ne pouvait pas régler le
dossier du revenu agricole uniquement au
travers de 1/5 des produits vendus par
l'agriculture ça c'est la première
remarque donc il ya eu une sorte de
de mensonges aux agriculteurs en leur
disant on va traiter le problème de
votre c'est la brigade il ne concernait
que vraiment une part infime et via la
sélection elle puisque tout ce qui est
exporté et tout ce qui est vendu en hors
domicile les céréales d'abord tous les
produits sont pas vendus à la grande
distribution donc on a fait le calcul
précis on est à un cinquième des
produits vendus sachant que les recettes
des agriculteurs ne sont pas que les
produits vendus il ya la pac et c'est
les produits vendus x un tonnage ou un
litrage est-ce que vous leviez
aujourd'hui la loi galland est un flop
oui on peut le dire mais nous on avait
quand même dit sans faire de jeu surtout
pas faire de politique politicienne sur
ce dossier qu'à trop grave et dans nos
intervention liminaire m'avait dit qu'on
ne voyait pas comment on pouvait régler
le problème du revenu des agriculteurs
alors si on en vient
au thème précis de la loi et galim
maintenant sur ce qui aurait fonctionné
au dysfonctionné c'est à dire entre les
relations entre les fournisseurs qui
sont des intermédiaires des agriculteurs
et les distributeurs
moi j'ai été dix ans député j'étais à
l'assemblée un des deux spécialistes sur
le sujet des relations fournisseurs
distributeurs
moi je proposais ne change plus la loi
parce que chaque fois qu'on change la
loi les distributeurs grande
distribution trouve une solution pour
les contourner et de toute façon il ya
toujours des effets pervers
mais alors comment est ce que on peut
comme cela améliorer l c'est cette
question du revenu des agriculteurs est
ce qu'il faut pas que le consommateur
paye davantage c'est dans la toute façon
ce qui est sûr c'est que le consommateur
ne paye pas son juste prix de produits
mais une fois qu'on a dit ça on n'a pas
réglé le problème
on a quatre cinq grands distributeurs
qui se font la guerre des prix le
politique n'a pas beaucoup de pouvoir
sur le prix ni sur le marché on a
d'autres pouvoirs en matière de charges
en matière de mai sur ce dossier là on
n'a pas beaucoup de pouvoir
donc il faut au moins qu'on essaie que
les lois qu'on vote ne fasse pas l'effet
inverse de ce qu on imaginer au moment
où vivote
un dernier mot sur cette agri bashing
dénoncée par ces manifestants
aujourd'hui à l'appel de la fnsea et des
jeunes agriculteurs
comment est-ce qu'on pourrait constituer
français avec les agriculteurs
alors je veux pas dire qu'ils sont en
brouille d'ailleurs est que les français
parce que les français entre eux une
partie d'entre eux le sont et
c'est un problème de communication mais
c'est votre métier et vous savez que
c'est très difficile vous savez aussi
que la communication négative est
toujours facile à faire passer et que la
négociation la communication positive
est difficile et moi je je souhaiterais
qu'il ya un accord entre tous les
organismes agricoles et l'administration
aussi en valeur le ministre ou ceux qui
s'occupent de notre pays une
communication réelle sur la réalité de
ce qu'est l'agriculture sur des réalités
scientifiques qu'est ce que vivent
réellement les agriculteurs merci
beaucoup mais c'est une raison on a
entendu a effectivement toute
explication à notre public sénat merci
merci beaucoup
quentin alors que nous sommes à une
dizaine de minutes maintenant du début
des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement on voit d'ailleurs bien que
cela se remplit dans la salle des
conférences du sénat avant 7 heures des
échanges directs entre les sénateurs et
l'exécutif et j'ai plaisir d'accueillir
en plateau emilie zapolsky bonjour vous
êtes communicante et fondatrice de
l'agencé milly conseil nous allons
parler ensemble est bien de ce que l'on
peut attendre comme temps fort a pour
cette séance
il va d'ailleurs avoir des questions et
bien sûr l'agriculture sur la
mobilisation aujourd'hui des
agriculteurs cela s'explique aussi parce
que eh bien les agriculteurs ils ont été
assez déçu par l'exécutif qui pourtant
avait fait une grande loi sur le sujet
alors oui vous parlez de la loi et galim
le flop dont parlait michel raison juste
à l'instant
alors oui c'était une loi qui était
censé rééquilibrer les prix de la grande
distribution pour que les agriculteurs y
trouvent leur compte
finalement on voit que le bilan est en
demi-teinte il ya un peu de résultats
mise à part je crois sur la filière du
lait
donc il ya de la déception mais ça
s'explique quand même pas que là dessus
que les agriculteurs prennent la parole
dont ils vont aux champs elysées ça nous
rappelle quand même des événements qui
ont eu lieu l'année dernière en novembre
2018 les gilet jaune avait choisi aussi
donc il ya cette idée de révolte qui est
possible en quelque sorte qui a été un
petit peu lancé par les gilet jaune
pourquoi pas eux pourquoi en irait-il
pas manifestés eu également à paris pour
faire valoir leurs droits pour demander
pour faire mention de leurs
revendications il ya un peu cet élan qui
a été donné et puis il ya tout ce qui se
passe aussi sur
les incendies des exploitations récent
une espèce d'agri bashing qui se passe
en ce moment avec les vegans les
antispécistes il ya toute cette
atmosphère et récemment le ministre de
l'agriculture les a défendues en quelque
sorte sur ce que j'ai aujourd'hui didier
guillaume qu'il soutenait cette
manifestation et qu'il comprenait les
raisons de la colère des agriculteurs
faut dire aussi que lui n'était pas aux
manettes au moment où il ya eu la loi et
galim ce n'était encore que stéphane
travert c'est peut-être plus facile pour
le ministre actuel de l'agriculture donc
de défendre les agriculteurs mais eux
ils ont du coup et une fenêtre de tir en
quelque sorte pour leurs revendications
dans la rue aussi pour ce soutien
affiché donc du gouvernement et en même
temps avec des difficultés puisque on
voit bien que la société une partie de
la société se dirige vers un mode de
production ou aimeraient en tout cas un
mode de production et un modèle
d'alimentation complètement différent
donc il va y avoir une sorte de rupture
qui dépasse même le cadre de la
politique du gouvernement sur des
attentes très fortes d'une société qui
veut autre chose qui veut de la qualité
qui veut des produits avec des animaux
qui sont très bien il ya quelque chose
qui est de l'ordre plutôt de sociologie
quoi de la société et qui va dépasser le
cadre des politiques et des relations
avec la grande distribution est un
signal aussi c'est que la grande
distribution les chiffres ils sont pas
très bons or ils sont bons pour les
petits hypermarchés qui sont en ville
les espèces de de marché qui attend
leclerc etc
mais sinon la grande distribution va mal
donc on voit bien que la société est en
train de bouger là dessus comment la
filière agricole peut s'y retrouver
là-dedans on voit qu'ils vivent quand
même avec peu de revenus que les modèles
économiques sont très compliqués à
exploiter donc il va y avoir il va y
avoir vraiment une filière en danger
d'ici peu une personne n'aime plus leurs
agriculteurs pourront vous aujourd'hui
en tout cas il n'est même plus un
certain modèle d'agriculture alors
certains modèles s'assied sur
d'agriculture mais parmi les
agriculteurs qui viennent aujourd'hui je
pense qu'il y en a qui ont déjà fait un
modèle opté pour un modèle différent
c'est simplement les modes de
distribution est ce qu'on est est ce
qu'on arrive à développer les circuits
courts des modèles ou les où les
consommateurs sont plus proches des
producteurs pour que la grande
distribution prennent moins sa
commission il ya tout ce système a pensé
et je
l'impression qu'on en est qu'au début du
début sur ces circuits courts et cette
agriculture un petit peu plus de qualité
et de proximité auprès des consommateurs
autre sujet de mobilisation en a parlé
plus tôt dans cette émission et bien
c'est la grève bien sûr du 5 décembre on
est à huit jours de cette journée de
mobilisation de manifestations déjà un
mot sur la méthode qui a eu le
gouvernement sur cette réforme des
retraites on a beaucoup parlé de
cafouillages de cacophonie de flou bon
aujourd'hui il ya eu la parole du
premier ministre edouard philippe
on commence à avoir un peu de lumière au
bout du flou du tunnel alors moi je
dirais que c'est un petit peu la méthode
du gouvernement c'est à dire qu'on a un
petit peu de la visibilité sur le
calendrier puisqu'il a donné précisément
quand est ce que monsieur de le voir
aller parler parce que les mesures
défendues 9 ou 10 décembre début enfin
au début des années 2020
on aurait le texte on voit qu'on fait un
petit peu dur et quand même et qui a
quand même derrière des municipales 2020
qui s'annonce donc le gouvernement a
tout intérêt à etel et ça dans la durée
mais il ya aussi cette volonté de pas en
dire trop
et moi je dirais que c'est ce qu'a dit
edouard philippe c'est pas si clair que
ça oui il enterre la clause grand père
mais il dit les retraités actuels ne
seront pas ne seront pas concernés
quelque part la tradition alors entre la
clause grand père c'est à dire qu'il y
ait que des jeunes qui rentraient dans
le dans le marché du travail qui
seraient concernés et d'autres c'est
quand même pas très clair on a
l'impression que la et d'ailleurs c'est
ce que joue le gouvernement depuis un
moment déjà
ils attendent le curseur et le curseur
le signal ça sera la mobilisation du 5
décembre et ça sera est ce que l'opinion
publique soit suit ou pas ce mouvement
de grève et à partir de là on a
l'impression qu'ils auront le courage
d'aller plus dans le sens le fond de la
réforme parce que jusqu'à maintenant et
depuis juillet depuis le rapport
delevoye ce qui manque c'est vraiment le
sens c'est le fond c'est les mesures est
ce que c'est une réforme budgétaire et
là pour le coup on comprendrait que il
faut repousser l'âge là on avait un
déficit de 2025 le corps l'a signalé on
a un déficit est ce que c'est pour créer
ce régime universel dont parle edouard
philippe qu'il a mentionné là en disant
on y croit on veut plus de régimes
spéciaux mais un régime universel
est ce que c'est pour de la solidarité
pour les mères de famille
pour qu'elle ait une meilleure retraite
ou les petites retraites on a encore
encore beaucoup beaucoup d'incertitudes
sur cette réforme
eh bien merci beaucoup et me rappelle ce
qui pour cet éclairage et va donc en
être question des retraites lors de
cette séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
et d'ailleurs quand un vous êtes avec et
la porte-parole du gouvernement si bête
ndiaye justement pour revenir pour
parler de ce sujet si sensible
oui et tout à fait à mes d'abord si vous
êtes ndiaye bonjour un mot sur ces
treize militaires de l'opération barkan
qui sont morts lundi soir le présent à
public en a parlé on s'en doute au
conseil des ministres
qu'est ce qu'il a pu dire aujourd'hui
est bien le conseil le conseil des
ministres a débuté par une intervention
du président de la république qui a tenu
à rendre hommage à nos soldats morts au
combat
il a rappelé qu'elle était l'importance
de l'opération militaire barkan qui se
déroule actuellement dans la bande
sahélo sahélienne double importance
d'abord parce que il s'agit d'aider à
stabiliser une région celle des trois
frontières qui aujourd'hui est en butte
à l'action de djihadistes évidemment
mais aussi importance pour la protection
de nos concitoyens ici en france nous
confirmer un hommage lundi après midi
aux invalides avec une cérémonie
particulière alors je peux effectivement
vous confirmer cet hommage qui sera
rendu par le président la république et
le gouvernement
à partir donc lundi probablement dans la
matinée l'elysée aura vocation à donner
des informations complémentaires sur le
déroulé de ce moment qui je crois sera à
la fois un moment d'émotion mais
également un moment très solennel dans
lequel seront évidemment impliquer les
familles des militaires qui ont disparu
sylvette ndiaye deuxième sujet que nous
allons évoquer ensemble du dossier des
retraites samedi 9 jours de la grande
mobilisation du 5 décembre à cette
tentative de l'exécutif de clarifier là
où nous en sommes aujourd'hui
alors comment ça va se passer qu'est ce
que dit le premier ministre exactement
le premier ministre a donné un certain
nombre d'indications à la fois de
calendrier à l'issue de ces rencontres
bilatérales qu'il a eu avec les
organisations syndicales donc il a
indiqué que la fin des concertations
interviendrait vers le 9 ou le 10
décembre jean paul delevoye aura
l'occasion
après une multilatéral d'indiquer ce
qu'il retient de ces rencontres diverses
et variées y aura eu je crois à l'issue
de cette période
près de 350 réunions avec les
organisations syndicales patronales et
professionnelles
le premier ministe pardon lui-même aura
l'occasion d'ici la fin de l'année de
s'exprimer pour donner dans le détail ce
que seront les arbitrages du
gouvernement pour cette réforme
edouard philippe a dit on doit trouver
le bon curseur sur la date d'application
de cette réforme ça veut dire qu'il y
aura un secteur par secteur branche par
branche des négociations pour l'entrée
en vigueur de la réforme des retraites
alors l'objectif n'est pas d'avoir des
choses qui sont décalées dans tous les
sens il est bien de pouvoir dire à la
fois que aux français qui sont proches
de la retraite il faut déterminer à
combien le temps de la retraite on leur
permet en quelque sorte d'avoir le temps
de s'organiser parce que vous pouvez
avoir fait des choix de carrière qui
influe sur votre retraite parce que vous
connaissez les modalités actuelles de
calcul un dernier mot sur cette phrase
qui fait beaucoup réagir sur les réseaux
sociaux depuis ce matin vous avez dit
que la réforme des retraites était une
réponse à la crise dès gilet jaune
pourtant ce n'est pas la revendication
cette réforme non mais la crise des
gilet jaune elle est basée aussi sur le
sentiment profond qu'il existe des
injustices et des inégalités et moi je
crois que quand on est une femme qu'on
est à la tête d'une famille
monoparentale et qu'on a du mal à
boucler ses fins de mois on fait partie
de ces femmes qui seront victimes de
faibles pensions à la fin d'une carrière
est justement le système que nous
proposons va lutter contre cette
inégalité
merci beaucoup et on va retrouver alice
bardot qui est dans l'hémicycle du sénat
bonjour alice alors dites-nous tout du
programme de ces questions d'actualité
qui commence dans quelques instants
alors viens d'entendre avec vous quentin
à l'ordre du jour de ces questions
d'actualité il y aura notamment la
réforme des retraites et est le climat
social de plus en plus tendues à
l'approché de la date fatidique du 5
décembre jour de grève nationale le
premier ministre a réaffirmé il ya un
instant donc sa détermination à faire
aboutir cette réforme une détermination
donc qui devrait être répété tout à
l'heure dans l'hémicycle en réponse aux
questions de la sénatrice est l air
catherine de roche et à celle donc de la
sénatrice monique lubin autres sujets
bien sûr c'est la situation au mali avec
trois questions au gouvernement à ce
sujet on est au lendemain
l'annnonce de la mort de treize
militaires français dont le fils du
sénateur jean marie bockel l'émotion
devrait toujours être vivent ici au
sénat hier un hommage leur a été rendu
donc la classe vient de sonner tout de
suite à des questions au gouvernement
[Musique]
sur d'actualité au gouvernement
notre séance et retransmise en direct
sur public sénat et notre site internet
chacun observera à la fois le respect
des uns et des autres et le temps je me
permets d'insister sur le temps la
parole est à notre collègue alain
richard pour le groupe de la république
en marche
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le premier ministre
nos forces armées viennent de subir la
perte tragique des 13 militaires d'élite
en action de combat au mali nous nous
inclinons devant leur sacrifice
une rando hommage à leur courage qu est
celui de tous les hommes et femmes sous
nos âmes
l'opération dans laquelle nos soldats
sont engagés a été autorisé par le
parlement
conformément à la constitution et nos
commissions en sont tenus informés les
légitimes décidé en plein accord avec
les autorités du pays et elle apporte un
appui décisif
la force des nations unies télécharger
d'oeuvrer à la stabilisation du mali
nous déplorons intensément la paire
trame dramatique de ces hommes de valeur
mais nous devons aujourd'hui voir aussi
le sens authentique de ce2 de cette
action de leurs actions celui de
l'action internationale de la france il
est important que vous résidiez
aujourd'hui devant le sénat monsieur le
premier ministre les actions déjà menées
par nos forces contre nos ennemis dans
le sahel
le concours que nous apporte les nations
partenaires et la coopération développée
avec le mali et ses voisins pour
construire la paix dans cette région qui
est important à notre sécurité
c'est un monsieur le premier ministre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur avant de répondre à
la question que vous posez je voudrais
vous en doutez bien m'associer au
message de respect et de tristesse que
vous venez de formuler à l'attention de
nos compatriotes qui servent sous les
drapeaux à l'attention de leurs familles
de leurs compagnons d'armes à
l'intention de tous ceux qui mesurent
parce qu'il les connaît c'est parce
qu'ils en sont proches
le sacrifice qu'ils sont susceptibles de
faire et l'engagement quel engagement de
toute une vie qu'il réalise en servant
les armées françaises je le dis monsieur
le sénateur à quelqu'un qui le sait
mieux que d'autres
compte tenu des fonctions que vous avez
exercé
nous pouvons être fiers de nos forces
armées et je le dis avec un profond
respect une immense admiration au sénat
alors que nous savons tous que les
treize morts que nous devons déplorer
dans cette opération de combat au mali
touche particulièrement
cette maison cet hémicycle en la
personne de votre collègue de notre ami
jean marie bockel
la france se bat au mali plus exactement
comme j'ai souvent l'occasion de le dire
dire la france se bat au mali c'est dire
en vérité
des hommes et des femmes se battent au
ben ali pour la france pour y défendre
sa sécurité pour garantir la stabilité
d'état amis alliés et partenaires
elle se bat au mali depuis que le
précédent président de la république a
considéré qu'il était de l'intérêt de la
france d'aller stopper cette avancée
vers bamako qui menaçait de déstabiliser
une région est de permettre la
constitution
une zone de non-droit dans laquelle nous
le savons des groupes armés et
terroristes se seraient organisées afin
de pouvoir ensuite déstabiliser pas
seulement la région mais notre pays y
compris par des actions terroristes
des hommes et des femmes se battent donc
au mali d'abord dans le cadre de
l'opération serval puis dans le cadre de
l'opération barkan le sens de cet
engagement il est rappelé régulièrement
et je voudrais indiquer deux choses très
brièvement
d'abord le fait que la france n'est pas
seule elle est la première puissance par
la force la capacité numérique de son
engagement par la compétence des forces
armées qu'elles déploient sur ce
territoire
mais on n'est pas seuls et bien d'autres
nations participent soit dans le cadre
de la minus ma soit dans le cadre des
opérations organisées avec les états de
la région qui sont actifs dans ce
processus soit encore dans le cadre de
l'opération dite et utm ou des états de
l'union européenne participent à ces
opérations participe-t-il à c'est une
question délicate et nous avons à
l'évidence un travail de conviction à
mener avec nos partenaires européens et
au delà avec nos alliés sur l'intérêt
commun que nous avons à faire prévaloir
des zones de paix de développement dans
la bande du sahel sous peine d'avoir à
subir
chez nous en europe et partout dans le
monde
la déstabilisation que j'évoquais
précédemment
nous devons c'est l'objectif qui est
fixé aux forces armées françaises qui
participent aux opérations
nous devons déstabiliser les groupes
armés terroristes
nous devons déstabiliser leurs caches
d'armes
leurs routes d'approvisionnement nous
devons réduire leurs points forts nous
devons accompagner les armées des états
concernés notamment ceux du g5 sahel
dans la montée en puissance
indispensable
pour garantir la paix et nous devons
aussi nous le savons parfaitement ce
n'est pas facile faire en sorte que le
combat ne soit pas simplement militaire
car le combat militaire est nécessaire
mais il n'est pas suffisant pour régler
des questions qui se posent parfois
depuis très longtemps dans cette région
il ya donc tout un travail de
stabilisation politique qui revient
souvent aux états concernés et de
développement économiques de perspective
pour l'ensemble des populations
ce que je veux dire monsieur le sénateur
en répandant ainsi c'est que le combat
que nous livrons est un combat militaire
dure et risqué tous ceux qui servent
dans les armées françaises savent le
risque auquel il expose parfois dans la
vie civile et jusqu'où je ne parle pas
de cette assemblée bien entendu parfois
dans la vie civile on oublie les risques
auxquels s'exposent nos soldats on ne
les voit pas très bien on les mesure pas
complètement tous ceux qui s'engagent
sous les drapeaux les connaissent ça ne
rend pas le risque moins intense et ça
ne rend pas le chagrin moins fort mais
c'est un risque qui est connu et que
prennent consciemment des jeunes gens au
service de la france
nous devons en être fiers et les
célébrer nous devons accompagner ceux
qui restent et conjoints les enfants les
parents les accompagner de la chaleur de
notre fraternité et nous devons savoir
que ce qui se joue là bas est important
pour nous ici et que ce combat sera long
et difficile
l'honneur d'une démocratie c'est de
faire en sorte que le pouvoir politique
choisisse d'engager des troupes sur un
théâtre d'opérations étrangers
lorsqu'ils considèrent que c'est
nécessaire c'est une lourde
responsabilité
et elle a été lourde pour tous ceux qui
ont exercé ces choix l'honneur d'une
démocratie c'est aussi de dire la fierté
que représente pour nous tous ces hommes
et ces femmes mais j'ai bien conscience
monsieur le président quand dix ans ces
mots je suis un peu maladroit mais je
peux vous dire mesdames et messieurs que
je suis infiniment admiratif et que nous
sommes tous infiniment admiratif de ce
qu'ils font sur place
merci monsieur le premier ministre la
parole monsieur monsieur richard de la
parole est maintenant notre collègue
olivier léonard pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
mes chers collègues monsieur le premier
ministre
notre émotion l'émotion nos concitoyens
est à son comble depuis l'annnonce de la
mort de nos treize soldats dans cette
collision de deux hélicoptères au cours
d'une opération de combat au mali ce
lundi 25 9 ans aux dons de tous les
collègues de mon groupe je souhaite
rendre hommage au courage de ces héros
qui ont péri l'an ensemble dans cette
tragédie
je tiens à honorer leur mémoire et je
veux adresser notre soutien le plus
profond aux familles endeuillées
j'ai naturellement une pensée
particulière pour notre collègue jean
marie bockel et sa famille à cet instant
est alors qu'un hommage national sera
rendu lundi aux invalides
il m'apparaît très crucial de réaffirmer
notre soutien aux 4500 soldats engagés
sur le terrain pour combattre le
terrorisme islamiste qui nous frappe
aussi ici en france et en europe
par delà les débats que certains
voudraient engager sur la stratégie de
la france dans la région du sahel
je rappeler deux choses deux choses à la
fois simple et pourtant fondamental sans
l'opération barkan le mali a mis pays-là
ami de la france serait aujourd'hui sous
la domination de nos ennemis
car au mali la france fait face trop
seul à l'organisation des états
islamiques au grand sahara
c'est d'ailleurs sur ce dernier point
que je souhaite vous interroger monsieur
le premier ministre
dans un contexte de dégradation de la
situation sécuritaire dans la région du
sahel
et alors que la france protège toute
l'europe dans cette opération
quelles initiatives comptez vous prendre
pour obtenir un soutien militaire
renforcé de la part de nos alliés
européens qui sont de fait directement
concernés quelles initiatives
diplomatiques et politiques
la france prend tel auprès de l'union
européenne et de l'organisation des
nations unies pour avancer vers une
stabilisation économique et
institutionnelle dans cette région pour
vous répondre la parole qu'à madame la
secrétaire d'état auprès de la ministre
des armées
geneviève darrieussecq que vous avez la
parole madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur léonard
je tiens d'abord à excuser l'absence de
florence parly qui a tenu à se rendre au
mali aux côtés de nos forces armées
suite au drame et aux déchets de nos
treize militaires français qui ont
trouvé la mort lundi au cours d'une
opération de combat contre les groupes
armés jihadistes dans le liptako malien
je voudrais vous remercier je voudrais
remercier la représentation nationale
ici pour votre soutien indéfectible pour
nos forces armées et je dois vous dire
que notre ministère et la communauté de
défense est très sensible au soutien de
la nation dans les moments difficiles
mais aussi tout au long de l'année
monsieur le sénateur la france reste
plus que jamais engagée aux côtés du
mali
nos axes d'effort à court terme c'est
d'abord soutenir les armées locales et
la force du g5 sahel et outre notre
soutien équipements cela passe par des
opérations conjointes comme l'opération
bourgou 4 menée justement ces dernières
semaines est appuyé par barkan qui a
permis et bien de neutraliser nombre de
terroristes et qui a permis de saisir de
très nombreux équipements la france veut
mobiliser les européens pour lancer la
taskforce takouba déploiement de forces
spéciales européennes à l'accompagnant
un accompagnement des maliens et
monsieur le premier ministre vient de le
dire la solution n'est pas que militaire
l'accord de paix doit être mis en oeuvre
et nous devons progresser en matière de
gouvernance et de développement
c'est au gouvernement malien qu'il
appartient de jouer un rôle moteur
son engagement à désarmer toutes les
milices et aller au bout du processus de
désarmement démobilisation et
réinsertion doit être suivi d'effets
nous sommes la france est prête à aider
les maliens à faire face à la crise du
centre est le premier ministre malien
s'est rendue dans le centre et a permis
la signature d'accords locaux ce qui est
sommes pas supplémentaire le retour de
la sécurité de la justice est impératif
mais il faut également traiter les
causes profondes
un appui y ont leur déploiement accéléré
de l'état et des services
c'est la priorité de notre appui
notamment avec l'alliance au sahel
merci à la même liste la parole elle
notre collègue qui arrive collombat pour
le groupe communiste républicain citoyen
et écologistes la parole
la ministre le var vient de subir de
nouvelles inondations dramatiques cinq
morts des dégâts dont le montant devrait
se situer entre 5 ans entre 180 millions
et 300 millions d'euros
à l'origine comme classiquement dans le
var et tout le sud de la france
de violents orages de type cévenol avec
le ruissellement torrentiel qui en
résulte or par un de ses mystères
bureaucratique dans notre pays fait ses
délices
malgré toutes les tentatives en
particulier celle du sénat je pense
notamment à celle de mathieu darnaud
rapporteur pour la commission des lois
de françois patriat de votre serviteur
en décembre 2017
le gouvernement se refuse obstinément à
considérer que la lutte contre le russe
le russe helmand relève pleinement de la
prévention de l'innovation ce qui
pourtant en rendant les travaux capelle
la situation fille dans sa part la taxe
dite gym api d'eau pourrait on n'en pas
douter les politiques de prévention à la
charge des collectivités
madame la ministre combien de
catastrophes ou faudra-t-il encore pour
admettre l'urgence de lever les
obstacles au déploiement d'une politique
pérenne de prévention de l'innovation
dans le sud du pays
pour vous répondre la parole et à madame
la ministre de la transition écologique
et solidaire monde à manisa
or nous avait parole ainsi monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur je
voudrais tout d'abord exprimer ma
solidarité à l'égard des victimes des
graves inondations le week-end dernier
cinq décès le bilan est lourd et j'ai
bien évidemment une pensée pour les
proches des victimes
je voudrais aussi salué l'exceptionnelle
mobilisation des forces de secours des
services de l'état des opérateurs des
élus locaux qui ont fait face ce qui a
permis que le bilan ne soit plus lourd
bien sûr le gouvernement assure un suivi
attentif de l'ensemble des conséquences
de ces intempéries
le cumul des précipitations a été très
important ce qui a justifié que météo
france place de département le var et
les alpes-maritimes en vigilance rouge
les deux fait notre pays doit se
préparer à vivre ce type de phénomène de
plus en plus souvent et de plus en plus
intensément
c'est pourquoi il faut effectivement
agir pour la prévention des inondations
et c'est ce que nous faisons
notamment avec les programmes d'action
pour la prévention des inondations
financée notamment avec le fonds barnier
j'attends dans les prochains jours un
rapport d'inspection de mon ministère
qui doit dégager des pistes pour mettre
en oeuvre plus rapidement ses programmes
d'action pour la prévention des
inondations et donc toutes les
propositions seront bien sûr examiné
l'objectif étant de simplifier
d'optimiser nos procédures tout en
conservant le même niveau d'exigence en
matière d'environnement
par ailleurs une démarche d'ensemble à
l'échelle des bassins de risque est
indispensable et nous sommes aujourd'hui
pleinement engagés pour accélérer avec
pragmatisme la mise en oeuvre de la
politique publique de prévention des
risques d'inondation jour merci merci
monsieur coloma madame la ministre
merci pour votre l'expression notre
solidarité mais la meilleure ma façon de
montrer votre solidarité
ce serait de régler le problème que je
vous pose c'est à dire comment ce fait
elle qu'on ne peut pas financer ou dans
les packs les plus grandes difficultés
le financer les opérations contre le
ruissellement qui est le problème
central dans le var et les
alpes-maritimes
répondez moi qu'est ce que vous voudrez
voulait faire qu'est ce que vous pensez
faire
elle ne cessez de nous dire ce que je
sais déjà
quant au fonds barnier on pourra en
reparler une autre fois c'est l'argent
c'est l'argent des assurés qui le
finance c'est pas le gouvernement mais
c'est la parole est à notre collègue
monique lubin pour le groupe socialiste
et républicain
vous avez la parole je suis le président
si le premier ministre en préambule au
nom de mes collègues du groupe
socialiste et républicain
je m'associe allumage à l'hommage
unanime rendu à nos militaires morts
pour la france
monsieur le premier ministre neuf
français sur dix disent vivre
actuellement une crise sociale hôpital
étudiants chômeurs enseignants pompiers
agriculteurs aujourd'hui sont autant de
lanceurs d'alert sur l'état de notre
société
pourtant la france est un pays riche
c'est donc il ya un problème monsieur le
premier ministre que monsieur le
président de la république évacué d'un
revers de formule
les français seraient pessimiste mais
comment pourrait-il en être autrement
quand ils considèrent que leurs
difficultés sont mal comprises de leurs
gouvernants quand les solutions avancées
repose quasiment toujours sur la
stigmatisation de telle ou telle
catégorie la réforme forcée de
l'assurance chômage sur les chômeurs
soit disant profiteurs la réforme de
l'accès à l'aide médicale d'état pour
les étrangers soit disant consommateurs
de notre système de santé
et maintenant la réforme des retraites
avec son lot d'annoncés désordonnée et
anxiogène qui commencera par pénaliser
la génération 59 63 qui ne devait pas
être concerné pourtant nous aviez vous
dit mais qui prendra finalement de plein
fouet les effets de la réforme
paramétrique que vous nous préparez tout
comme les mères de famille semble-t-il
d'ailleurs le tout bien sûr sur fond de
stigmatisation de ces nantis qui serait
la source des maux de tous les autres
divisez toujours divisés monsieur le
premier ministre
où est l'état où l état protecteur celui
qui garantit la cohésion sociale celui
qui maintient le vivre ensemble malgré
les différences celui qui apaise celui
qui rassemble son peuple en bref celui
qui redonnera l'optimisme voir l'espoir
à nos concitoyens
pour vous répondre la parole est aux
commissaires ont retraite il des liens
auprès de la mise des solidarités de la
santé je veux le voir vous avez la
parole
chez le président madame c'est d'être à
madame lubin perte est loin d'être
sensible au discours que vous avez sur
les fractures de la société française je
m'en étais beaucoup ému lorsque j'étais
médiateur et si je me suis engagée sous
l'autorité du premier ministre est la
mise en place d'un projet universel
c'est peut-être par le souffle de
l'histoire d'essayer de faire en sorte
que le soutien à l'universalité ne se
conjugue pas paru d'édition de
différence mais qu'au contraire on
puisse retrouver ce sens du bien commun
et non pas que chacun cherche à
considérer l'état comme une fiction qui
permet à chacun de vivre au détriment
des autres et c'est la raison pour
laquelle et c'est la raison pour
laquelle
et c'est la raison pour laquelle
souhaitant apporter aux futures
générations
cette formidable exigences qu'avait
exprimé 800 chercher de dire que la
différence entre un politicien est un
politique
l'un s'occupe des prochaines générations
quand l'autre s'occupe des prochaines
élections
nous avons souhaité nous avons souhaité
mettre en place
nous avons souhaité mettre en place un
système qui répond à l'exigence d'équité
les mêmes règles pour tous qu'ils soient
que la retraite soit le reflet du
travail que nous embarquions plus de
solidarité et plus de redistribution
notamment vis-à-vis des femmes
les simulations que nous formulons c'est
que les pensions des générations 80 et
90 des femmes augmenteront de 5 à 10% et
je crois que sur ce sujet nous pourrions
nous retrouver
voilà le débat
je vois monsieur le premier ministre que
monsieur le haut commissaire pardon je
vois que le gouvernement est toujours
sur un système manichéen d'un côté ceux
qui auraient tout compris est de notre
côté ce qui nous rend rien compris moi
ya une chose que j'ai retenu c'est que
le souffle de l'histoire doit nous
rappeler que les peuples est en titane
ont assez ils finissent toujours par se
rebeller
la parole est à notre collègue franck
prénom ville - le groupe les
indépendants vous avez la parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je souhaite
à mon tour dans un premier temps avec
mes collègues du groupe les indépendants
assurer les familles des 13 militaires
de notre sincère compassion et de notre
profond respect
ma question s'adresse au ministre de
l'agriculture elle porte sur la crise
sanitaire que traverse la forêt j'y
associe ma collègue notre collègue anne
catherine loisier présidente du groupe
d'études forêt bois monsieur le ministre
la forêt traverse une crise sans
précédent
les conditions climatiques ont mis à mal
les peuplements forestiers
on compte désormais près de 2,7 millions
de mètres cubes toucher toutes essences
confondues dans la région dans les
régions grand test et bourgogne franche
comté sont les plus impactées
depuis la sécheresse de 2018 la
propagation du scolyte a explosé
entraînant un dépérissement massif
les volumes des spis et asco visiter
pour les forêts publiques du grand test
approche 1,5 million de mètres cubes
c'est presque 5000 hectares de forêt
concernés dans notre département de la
meuse le 8 octobre dernier vous avez
annoncé la mise en place d'un plan de
soutien de 16 millions d'euros pour
valoriser le bois scolytés et replanter
c'est un début mais qui s'avère à face à
l'ampleur du désastre vita suffisant
alors comment se déclinera t-il cette
tempête silencieuse qu'il que qui frappe
nos forêts françaises est aussi un
véritable enjeu européen puisque
l'allemagne et les pays d'europe
centrale sont eux aussi fortement
impactés
à titre d'exemple l'allemagne vient de
bâtir un plan de 800 millions d'euros
sur trois ans c'est donc une catastrophe
économique écologique et sanitaire
que comptez-vous faire à court terme et
à moyen terme
la forêt a besoin d'une politique très
ambitieuse
il est urgent d veulent d'évacuer
rapidement le bois contaminée afin de
contenir la propagation
il est également nécessaire de
réinvestir massivement dans nos forêts
il en va de l'héritage que nous
laisserons aux générations futures pour
vous répondre
la parole et communiquent de
l'agriculture de l'alimentation tuent
guillot le président mesdames et
messieurs dessinateur sénatrice monsieur
le sénateur frank mais non ville vous
avez eu raison de poser cette question
d'associer anne catherine loisier de
fait l'ensemble des sénateurs parce que
la situation que traverse la forêt
française est aujourd'hui dramatique et
dramatique à deux niveaux est dramatique
au niveau conjoncturel avec cette
maladie des scolytes
des dizaines de milliers d'hectares de
bois scolytés qui est un vrai problème
pour la forêt actuelle
et puis elle est dramatique pour
l'avenir sur la durée avec le
dérèglement climatique
avec le réchauffement climatique et avec
le fait que la forêt tel quel et plantes
aujourd'hui avec ces essences ne répond
pas assez à l'enjeu du captage du
carbone
sur le premier point conjoncturelle vous
l'avez dit monsieur le sénateur il est
urgent de bouger il est urgent d'avancer
je crois que le gouvernement avec le csf
forêt bois a pris la mesure de cela nous
avons mis un plan d'extrême urgence la
sur place de 16 16 millions d'euros 8
millions 6 millions d'euros
immédiatement pour arriver à lutter
contre les scolytes à sortir dé des bois
scolytés arriver à les mettre dans
l'économie et puis 10 millions d'euros
de suite pour faire en sorte de
travailler à sa régénérescence il faut
gagner cette bataille et sur la durée
il est absolument indispensable de tenir
compte de ce que vous voyez vous les
forestiers qui est habitué à vivre dans
la forêt j'aurais pu citer le sénateur
djemilli avec lequel nous travaillons
beaucoup
aussi et le fait que le fait qu'il faut
absolument travailler sur faut
absolument travailler sur d'autres
essences avec une replantation de la
forêt il faut arriver à avoir un plan
d'ensemble fin mars
j'ai demandé à ce que l'ensemble de la
filière bois d'amont en aval d'ici fin
mars travaille sur la mise en place d'un
plan structurel qui nous permettra
d'arriver à régler cette situation qui
est dramatique je crois que les
parlementaires comme le gouvernement ont
pris la mesure et nous allons réussir je
vous remercie
merci aux parents les matins au
président christian cambon pour le
groupe l'est républicain
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre au nom de mon groupe
auquel je souhaite associer la commune
notre commission de la défense
je souhaite avant tout rendre hommage à
la mémoire de nos soldats disparus
tragiquement dans l'accident
d'hélicoptère qui est intervenu au sahel
alors qu'ils étaient engagés en plein
combat contre des groupes djihadistes
armés chers collègues une fois de plus
nos forces paie un lourd tribut à cette
guerre qu avec un courage et une
abnégation sans limite elle livre pour
notre sécurité celle des français mais
aussi celle de toute l'europe
nos pensées douloureuse vont évidemment
aux familles de ces héros à leurs
camarades
alors camarades de peau de gap de vars
de saint christol mais aussi à toutes
les forces engagées au sein des opex qui
chaque jour partent en mission sans
savoir si elles rentreront le soir avec
une émotion toute particulière nous
penser notre affection vont ici à notre
collègue à jean marie qui nous parlait
si souvent de ce fils tant aimé dont la
vocation était le service de la france
écoutons le message de son père hier
soir nous sommes dévastés mais nous
sommes fiers de lui car en vérité ces
treize soldats n'étaient pas là par
hasard
il avait choisi cet engagement au nom
des valeurs auxquelles il croit
auxquelles il croyait en cet instant
nous ne leur devons pas de polémique
nous leur devons respect recueillement
et reconnaissance ici au sénat reviendra
sûrement le temps des interrogations
elles sont légitimes peut-être aussi
faudra-t-il un débat mais aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui nous savons que face à une
extension de la menace djihadiste vers
les pays voisins
notre présence militaire est
indispensable je dirais même qu'elle est
incontournable car sans sécurité
inutile de croire au développement ou à
plus de présence sur le terrain d'un
état malien déjà si défaillant mais nous
savons aussi que cette mission
sur un territoire grand comme l'europe
nous ne pouvons l'assuré seul vous
l'avez dit monsieur le premier ministre
dpi nombreux nous est déjà mais ils nous
aident insuffisamment alors à la veille
de plusieurs sommets des nations
occidentales européen autant pensez vous
monsieur le premier ministre pouvoir
mobiliser plus encore nos alliés
européens et occidentaux afin qu'il nous
aide encore plus efficacement et qu'un
tel drame ne se reproduise plus jamais
en d'autres termes pour que pierre
emmanuel bockel et ses compagnons
d'infortuné ne soient pas morts pour
rien
[Applaudissements]
pour nous répondre
[Musique]
la parole à monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le président comment je n'ai
rien à ajouter à l'essentiel de la
question et de l'intervention vous devez
prononcer je mesure les motions de l'ami
est la parfaite compréhension que vous
avez de l'ensemble de ces sujets compte
tenu des responsabilités que vous
exercez au sein de cette assemblée
vous connaissez les militaires français
vous les voyez régulièrement ou les
auditionner ici voulait saluer sur les
théâtres d'opérations extérieures avec
beaucoup de sénateurs
j'allais dire vous partagez non pas du
tout en terme de combat et vous partager
avec eux la réalité de ce que sont les
opérations extérieures le sens de
l'engagement profond et en même temps la
très grande simplicité dans les rapports
humains qui prévaut généralement
lorsqu'on rencontre
celles et ceux qui servent sous les
drapeaux français bref monsieur le
président comme beaucoup d'entre nous
ici vous les aimez et donc la perte de
13 hommes est évidemment quelque chose
qui entraîne la tristesse et à certains
égards une forme de désarroi une forme
seulement car vous l'avez dit nous
sommes au mali pour d'excellentes
raisons sommes au mali pour garantir la
sécurité de la france pour accompagner
des états qui sont des états partenaires
et amis
nous sommes au mali parce qu'une
décision politique a voulu que nous
soyons aux manies et comme toute
décision politique il est bien naturel
que le parlement l'assemblée nationale
et le sénat
la discute l'interrogent ce que vous
faites ce que vous faites depuis
longtemps et ce que vous continuerez à
faire et il est légitime normal sain
dans une démocratie qu'il en soit ainsi
vous l'avez dit également monsieur le
président nous devons faire en sorte que
la france qui n'est pas seul au mali
puisse être plus accompagner encore
faire en sorte que les mandats de
l'ensemble des structures qui
interviennent soit probablement mieux
coordonner faire en sorte que les
objectifs politiques et opérationnelles
soit adaptée au fur et à mesure que la
menace mute et se transforme
il appartiendra au président de la
république de s'exprimer après le temps
du deuil sur ce que nous pouvons faire
pour convaincre nos alliés nos amis
européens que l'intérêt de l'europe se
joue aussi dans cette région et il
appartiendra à l'ensemble de la
communauté nationale à l'ensemble des
acteurs du débat public de convaincre
nos partenaires sur place les états du
sahel qu'une partie décisive de la
solution est dans leurs mains que la
réconciliation nationale au mali la
reconstitution de l'armée nouvelle comme
on dit parfois au mali sont des
conditions indispensables du retour à la
stabilité de la préservation de la
stabilité et du développement que
l'engagement de l'ensemble des états et
le fait qu'ils assument avoir besoin de
nous d'autres pour garantir cette
stabilité soit toujours prier toujours
formuler c'est un combat difficile je le
disais tout à l'heure au sénateur alain
richard et c'est un combat qui est long
et nous le savons il faut donc formulé
politiquement les objectifs
après débat convaincre nos alliés et
être
au secours au soutien toujours des
femmes et des hommes qui s'engagent sous
les drapeaux je vous remercie monsieur
prix merci monsieur le problème n'est la
parole et à notre collègue pierre
louault pour le groupe de l'union
centriste pouvait la parole monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre de
l'agriculture il ne vous aura pas
échappé qu'aujourd'hui
à paris comme dans un certain nombre de
villes françaises nos agriculteurs sont
dans la rue après l'espoir portèrent
travers la loi dit et galim et les états
généraux de l'alimentation les
agriculteurs de notre pays sont amenés à
constater que les résultats ne sont pas
à la hauteur des espérances qui l'ont
nourri et que collectivement nous
voulons leur donner depuis tant d'années
une réalité nous rattrape encore est
toujours celui des prix agricoles
monsieur le ministre monsieur le premier
ministre fait de la responsabilité de
votre gouvernement
aujourd'hui il y a quatre cent cinquante
mille français qui se lèvent tous les
matins feeder qui travaillent sept jours
sur sept et qui pour moitié ne gagnent
même pas le smic et pour un quart
d'entre eux ont des revenus inférieurs
au rsa et pourtant ce sont ces milliers
de paysans qui nourrissent les 68
millions de français de nos concitoyens
et ont pour seul retour les batak des
doctrinaires environnementaux et
animalistes les agriculteurs font des
efforts considérables
ils ont acquis une grande capacité de
remise en cause comme peu dans notre
société les pratiques agricoles évoluent
pour améliorer la qualité des produits
la disparition du glyphosate détruira
les espoirs des agriculteurs et
notamment ceux qui sont les plus
performants sur la conservation des sols
malgré tous ces constats le phénomène
d'agri bashing s'acharne mitraille
harcèle l'agriculture de ce pays
monsieur le ministre comment redonner
une raison de vivre aux agriculteurs
comment leur permettent de gagner leur
vie
comment redonner une raison d'être face
à ses bourreaux des agriculteurs qui les
emmène tout droit au suicide
pour vous répondre la parole et
communistes de l'agriculture que
l'alimentation didier guillaume sur le
ministre avait la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur lourd aujourd'hui selon le
comptage du ministère de l'intérieur
1086 tracteurs sont sur paris c'est un
trait aux chiffres et c'est une très
grosse mobilisation de même que dans
beaucoup de capitales régionales il y a
beaucoup de manifestations et de blocage
pourquoi et vous l'avez dit dans la
deuxième partie de votre question tout
simplement parce que les agriculteurs en
ont marre du dénigrement permanent
les agriculteurs je vais je vais venir
les agriculteurs les agriculteurs en ont
marre de se faire insulter
lorsqu ils dépendent dans un champ les
agriculteurs en ont marre d'avoir eu
soixante dix agressions attaques dans
des élevages y compris par des
parlementaires de la république madame
la présidente et les agriculteurs et
encore ce week-end trois bâtiments
d'élevage ont été brûlés c'est
inacceptable et il faut le condamner
fermement et toutes celles et tous ceux
qui trouveront des explications à cela
seront complices de la détresse et de la
grille bashing donc ça c'est la première
chose
deuxièmement ce que je veux vous dire
c'est que nous essayons de travailler
pour qu'ils aient un revenu décent
mais aujourd'hui la grande difficulté
qui diable pour l'agriculture c'est que
les agriculteurs sont la seule
profession en france qui ne fixe pas
leurs prix la seule profession qui vend
en dessus et en dessous de ce que ça
leur coûte et c'est inacceptable et
c'est et c'est pour ça c'est pour ça que
mais j'aurais pu mais je répondrai à
madame la présidente prime à tout à
l'heure
c'est la raison pour laquelle c'est la
raison pour laquelle les est ce qui a
été fait dans 4 de la loi et galim
n'avait jamais été tenté jusqu alors
c'est l'inversion de la construction des
prix pour y arriver ça a été décidé par
toute la profession agricole confondues
décidée par les parlementaires pour les
états généraux et de sion de le mettre
en oeuvre je vous remercie
merci la parole est maintenant madame la
présidente sophie primas pour le groupe
l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de l'agriculture nous avons
dans ce pays une chance insolente c'est
celle de notre pays qui dispose d'une
situation exceptionnelle pour que notre
agriculture puisse répondre à bien des
enjeux souveraineté alimentaire
transition écologique sécurité sanitaire
nouvelles énergies
mais nos agriculteurs sont aujourd'hui
perdu totalement perdu et la colère qui
monte aujourd'hui à paris autour de
paris est un cri monsieur le ministre
notre agriculture est en grande
difficulté alors ma question est simple
comment comptez vous répondre
aujourd'hui à la détresse des
agriculteurs dans la rue on vous
répondra parole est d'or ministre de
l'agriculture et de l'alimentation
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
présidente
dans cet hémicycle j'ai travaillé à
trois lots agricole à la lm ap de bruno
le maire le titre de la loi c'était
dreux données du revenu aux agriculteurs
à la loi d'avenir de stéphane le foll
dans le titre était il faut que les
agriculteurs vivent de leur travail et
la loi et galim de stéphane travert en
disant on va inverser la convention des
prix eh bien je suis au regret de dire
que depuis 15 ans tous gouvernements
confondus
la france n'a pas réussi à donner un
revenu décent à ses agriculteurs
et c'est là le drame de c'est là le
drame alors je pense que nous
participons tous à cela et c'est la
raison pour laquelle dans le cadre de la
loi et galim dans le cadre de la loi et
galim un pari a été tenté c'est le pari
de l'inversion de la construction des
prix c'est le pari de faire en sorte que
soient les filières qui fixent leurs
prix et j'ai remarqué d'ailleurs dans
l'excellent texte que vous êtes qui est
en préparation que vous ne revenez pas
là dessus dans votre ppl madame la
présidente
c'est dire si le choix qui a été fait
aux états généraux et dans la loi et
galim d'inversion de l'action de la
construction des prix co construit avec
les syndicats agricoles vous va vous n'y
revenez pas vous avez raison
pourquoi vous avez raison d'une paille
revenir parce qu'il ya deux ans
d'expérimentation et vous savez très
bien que l'année dernière la loi n'était
pas en application les ordonnances
n'était pas prise et donc ça ne pouvait
pas fonctionner la deuxième année
d'expérimentation c'est cette année la
présidente de la fnsea dans grandit la
semaine dernière c'est cette année qu'on
verra ça fonctionne et si ça ne
fonctionne pas alors il faudra y revenir
mais moi je crois à l'intelligence
collective
je pense que nos entreprises de
l'agroalimentaire qui font du bon
travail vont pouvoir avancer je pense
que la grande distribution va pouvoir
payer différemment les choses mais je
crois surtout mais je crois surtout mais
je crois surtout que la mobilisation
d'aujourd'hui des agriculteurs je vais
devoir partir parce que je les reçois de
chaleur va contribuer avec le travail
des parlementaires et du gouvernement à
faire évoluer cette situation
ponam la présidente
le ministre de l'agriculture votre
réponse me déçoit car il ne s'agit pas
de la loi et galim il s'agit du destin
de l'agriculture est ce que je pointe
aujourd'hui c'est les contradictions
entre le discours et les actes qui sont
à mon avis au coeur du malaise agricole
vous dit soutenir la transition
écologique mais rien dans votre budget
pour accompagner significativement une
modification profonde des modes de
production
vous mettez en place une interdiction
des produits phyto mais rien pour
certaines filières dans l'impasse comme
le souligne votre propre majorité
vous avez fait adopter la loi et galim
censé sauver le revenu à l'école mais
elle ne porte que sur 20% de ce revenu
et la théorie du ruissellement ne
fonctionne pas vous teniez vous dit
soutenir la compétitivité des
exploitations mais la même loi augmente
les charges et le différentiel est
devenue insoutenable et nous n'avons
jamais autant apporter vous pariez sur
la montée en gamme et vous soutenez les
accords commerciaux qui ouvre nos
marchés à des produits qui ne répondent
pas aux exigences de production c'est le
cas du ceta et c'est le cas la ddt de
l'accord sur les viandes bovine
américaine que le parlement européen
s'apprête à voter demain vous dit
préparer l'avenir mais vous laissez le
se préparer une pac avec une
renationalisation des budgets qui
favorisera une concurrence
intra-européenne mortifère monsieur le
ministre je crois sincèrement qu'il nous
faut une grande loi
un grand projet de loi de programmation
pluriannuelle agricole dans lequel nous
parlerons de l'innovation de la
formation des investissements durables
et qui offrira un cap à nos agriculteurs
une ambition à notre pays un cap qui
donnera confiance à nous français qui
oublie trop souvent quel est notre
chance
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
joël bigot pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues alors
qu'on nous annonce que ce budget sera
vert ou ne sera pas l'examen du projet
de loi de finances nous permet de mieux
appréhender la réalité des fêtes
que constatons-nous madame la ministre
malgré tous vos efforts de communication
environnementale
le vernis se craquelle devant la
suppression sans précédent du nombre
d'emplois de fonctionnaires au sein de
votre ministère
rien que pour cette année 2500 postes
disparaissent pour l'année 2020
ce sont 1000 73 postes que vous
supprimez ce sont les fondements même du
service public de l'écologie qui sont
mises en danger
jusque dans nos ddt pire sur les trois
années à venir
vous prévoyez de poursuivre cette
destruction à la hache des effectifs est
supprimée ainsi près de 5000 postes soit
5% des agents de votre ministère or pour
mettre en oeuvre la transition
écologique il nous faut des moyens
humains ne serait-ce qu'en moyens de
contrôler tous les opérateurs de l'état
sont durement impactée 40 emplois pour
les agences de l'eau sans pour météo
france 40 pour l'hygiène sens pour le
serrer ma 17
l'ineris 20 pour l'ademe alors que ces
messieurs augmente vous embarquer le
pays dans une politique publique
paradoxale où l'écologie est dans tous
les discours tout en sapant les moyens
de l'état s'il y a bien un secteur qui
devrait être sanctuarisé c'est bien
celui de l'écologie les collectivités
territoriales qui sont le fer de lance
de la transition écologique ont besoin
du soutien de l'état en ingénierie de
projets en logistique en proximité
combien de petits projets annulés car il
engagerait trop de frais de gestion
prenez garde de ne pas saborder les
dynamique vertueuse les syndicats toutes
tendances confondues vous ont pourtant
alerté et le groupe socialistes et
républicains souhaitent faire de même et
vous demande à l'occasion du débat
budgétaire qui s'ouvre cet après midi au
sénat de revoir votre copie pour être à
la hauteur d'une politique publique que
les français attendent de pied ferme
pour vous répondre la parole et
sallaumines is la transition écologique
et solidaire
si la mairie jab est mort devait la
parole monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur joël bigot le président de la
république et le premier ministre l'ont
clairement exprimés l'écologie est une
des priorités de l'acte 2 du quinquennat
et cette priorité suppose évidemment des
moyens et c'est bien ce que traduit le
projet de loi de finances pour 2020 avec
une nette augmentation des crédits de
mon ministère
plus de 800 millions d'euros
supplémentaires pour agir alors le
ministère de la transition écologique et
solidaire participe néanmoins à l'effort
de réduction des effectifs de la
fonction publique dans la continuité des
années passées donc pas sur les chiffres
que vous avez mentionné mais on aura
l'occasion de reprendre cette discussion
dans quelques instants
je suis évidemment vigilant parce que
cet effort soit compatible avec la bonne
mise en oeuvre de nos priorités c'est
pourquoi certaines missions je pense à
la biodiversité ou à l'inspection des
installations classées sont préservés
donc nous aurons l'occasion de reprendre
ce débat tout à l'heure mais je voudrais
rappeler trois priorités porté par le
budget de mon ministère
la première c'est de mieux accompagner
les français dans la transition
énergétique avec la poursuite de la
montée en puissance du chèque énergie
avec le succès de la prime à la
conversion et du bonus écologique avec
des moyens sans précédent pour la
rénovation énergétique des logements à
3,5 milliards d'euros
l'autre groupe si vous fait un bond
l'autre grande priorité pour 2020 c'est
un effort sans précédent là aussi dans
d'investissement pour les transports du
quotidien des transports plus propres
avec 3 milliards d'euros pour la fuite
ce qui est la traduction de la loi
d'orientation des mobilités récemment
adoptée et enfin nous allons accompagner
notre politique en faveur de l'eau et de
la biodiversité avec notamment la
création de l'office français de la
biodiversité
donc vous le voyez la priorité est là et
les moyens sont au rendez vous
monsieur bigot quelques secondes oui
merci madame mini-salle heures de
l'urgence écologique qui à force de
réduire nos effectifs nous perdons nos
savoir-faire nous experts public jeudi
biens publics de l'environnement
nous arrivons à loos madame la ministre
il faut stopper l'hémorragie la parole
est maintenant notre collègue catherine
de roche pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le haut
commissaire jean paul delevoye
voilà maintenant deux ans que vous êtes
chargé du dossier des retraites et et
nous je dois dire que ne s'en vouloir
être désagréable nous ne voyons pas très
clair alors il ya eu l'âge pivot il ya
l'âge d'équilibré y'a pas d'âge mais une
durée une dorée travail plus longues on
a entendu la clause grand-père pas de
clause grand père mais le président la
république qui nous dit en même temps il
faudra adapter les choses
donc tout ça devient très compliqué très
anxiogène monsieur le premier ministre
annoncée ce midi qu'il y aurait des
réformes à partir du vin des annonces à
partir du 15 décembre
mais en attendant merci monsieur le haut
commissaire d'être lumineux et nous
éclairer ou en est où exactement
pour vous répondre et faire toute la
lumière la parole et au commissaire
délégué des solidarités de la santé
monsieur delevoye vous devez la parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
président madame catherine de roche
merci de ce moment d'ensoleillement
partager merci de votre appréciation
pour saluer la méthode
en réalité
en réalité je pense que ce qui est
important c'est ce que nous rencontrons
dans l'ensemble des rencontres
citoyennes
il y à une acceptation des principes à
chaque fois que le phare nous sommes en
contact avec les citoyens ils
soutiennent le principe de
l'universalité
ceci est très clairement ancré dans
l'esprit de tout ce que nous voulons
bâtir un système où les mêmes règles
s'appliquent à tous la seconde c'est
qu'ils ont parfaitement compris que sous
l'autorité du premier ministre et du
président de la république nous voulions
mettre en place un système équitable un
métier identique retraite identique
troisième élément ils ont parfaitement
compris que nous souhaitions quelque
chose de plus redistributif et de plus
solidaire et aussi au titre de la
cohésion de la nation
quelque chose qui renforce la cohésion
générationnel qui ré embarque la
confiance des jeunes et qui permette
quelque chose de beaucoup plus solide
par rapport aux aléas du futur et quand
je mesure votre impatience mais dans le
respect que nous avons des discussions
étaient partenaires sociaux je
terminerai mes consultations faire le 9
et le 10 je rendrai 10 décembre
je rendrai alors des conclusions et il
appartiendra au premier ministre comme
il a indiqué ce midi avant la fin de
l'année de préciser très clairement les
contours du projet probablement la façon
dont nous allons pouvoir engager les
processus de décision et donc je vous
invite à vivre de façon très ensoleillée
les quelques jours qui le séparent de
bill et sans merci
hollande de roche oui merci monsieur le
haut commissaire mais il ya quand même
deux ans de travaux on a eu deux
colloques ici ici au sénat et c'est vrai
que vous avez un slogan qui peut séduire
en effet c'est notre réforme sera simple
et juste
sauf que quand on déroule la pelote et
quand on regarde certaines mesures est
le dernier exemple en date c'est quand
même celui des retraites des femmes qui
ont eu notamment trois enfants ou plus
et l'institut de la protection sociale
est très clair dessus ça ne tient pas
c'est à dire que vous allez non non je
persiste et signe
les chiffres sont têtus vous allez en
fait sacrifier les familles qui
renouvelle les générations alors qu'on a
un système qui est basée justement sur
ces mêmes générations donc nos objectifs
à nous était très clair c'était en effet
revalorisation n'est pas ceux des
pensions pas de baisse des retraites
réforme des régimes spéciaux mais sans
creuser le déficit et sans laisser filer
le déficit et c'est là où il ya une
différence
alors pour l'instant vous essayez de
gagner du temps parce que vous êtes
tenus par votre promesse de pas faire de
réformes paramétriques mais pour
l'instant vous gagnez du temps et désolé
de vous décevoir mais c'est toujours
aussi floue pour moi la parole est à
neutre
collègue claude kern pour le groupe de
l'union centriste avez la parole merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
le président de la république s'est
exprimé sur le dispositif de consignes
pour recyclage des bouteilles plastiques
lors du congrès des maires
vous en faites une interprétation tout à
fait subjective alors que le débat
débute à l'assemblée nationale nous ne
souscrivons pas à votre proposition
d'expérimentation sur les territoires
volontaire avec une mesure d'étape en
2023 que de temps perdu
nous sommes en urgence environnementale
ne nous en lisons pas dans de faux
débats
le seul mot d'ordre qui tiennent et de
sortir du tout plastique
or le système de recyclage nécessite de
toujours réinjecter de la matières
premières plastiques dans la production
je le dis sans ambages vous mais vous ne
prenez pas la bonne direction
vous allez déséquilibrer un service
public dont le modèle économique est en
train de faire ses preuves entre avant
par voie de conséquence l'action
volontariste des territoires en matière
environnementale vous participerez à
toujours plus de plastique vous mettre à
contribution les consommateurs qui vont
payer plus et dégrader un peu plus
l'environnement se déplaçant au point de
collecte
nous attendons des décisions de bon sens
il faut mettre l'accent sur la consigne
de réemploi ainsi qu'une collecte
efficiente duo en foyer allez vous
écoutez les territoires les élus locaux
qui sont sur le terrain et qui ont pu
exprimer leurs positions sur le sujet
dans leur résolution générale du 102e
congrès des maires de même que la parole
du président de la république
allez-vous porter un regard pragmatique
sur le dossier et sortir d'un certain
dogmatisme qui ne mène nulle part sauf à
la catastrophe vont répondre la parole
et ministre de la transition écologique
et solidaire
vous avez la parole monsieur président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur claude kern le
projet de loi anti gaspillage porté par
brune poisson qui est actuellement en
discussion à l'assemblée nationale est
l'un des textes fondamentaux pour la
transition écologique et solidaire que
nous portons il concilie écologie du
quotidien et transformation profonde de
nos modèles de consommation
s'agissant du service public de gestion
des déchets qui est l'un des enjeux de
ce texte je voudrais réaffirmer très
clairement et sans ambiguïté le rôle
central des collectivités locales rien
ne peut se faire sans elle sur ce sujet
comme nous nous y étions engagés nous
avons de nouveau réuni lundi les
associations d'élus en présence des
organisations professionnelles et des
ong pour évoquer ce sujet de la consigne
nous nous sommes accordés ensemble sur
une méthode pour atteindre l'objectif de
90 % de bouteilles plastiques collectés
et recyclés dans dix ans cette méthode
elle repose sur six engagements la mise
en place d'un good groupe de contact
entre l'état et les représentants des
collectivités locales
la définition d'une mesure objective des
performances de collecte tri et
recyclage
la garantie de mener à leur terme
l'extension des consignes de tri la
réalisation d'un bilan en 2023 pouvant
conduire à la mise en place d'une
consigne mixte pour recyclage et
réemploi dans des conditions qui devront
être précisées dans la loi dans
l'intervalle le lancement
d'expérimentations avec les territoires
volontaire et certains territoires
souhaite le faire de consignes et puis
bien évidemment la nécessité de soutenir
les initiatives de réemploi donc nous
allons poursuivre le travail avec les
associations de collectivités pour
traduire ces engagements dans le projet
de loi l'occasion de l'examen en séance
publique dans deux semaines à
l'assemblée nationale donc l'objectif
est là nous avons une méthode partagée
pour l'atteindre dans laquelle la
consigne jouera tout son rôle
ce choeur
merci madame la ministre pour votre
réponse mais pour atteindre l'objectif
des solutions existent déjà dans les
territoires qu'ils ont mise en oeuvre la
loi grenelle
il suffit que le gouvernement fasse
enfin respecter cette loi et d'autre
part lors de l'examen du projet de loi
économie circulaire ici dans cette
assemblée un excellent travail a été
fait sous la houlette de martin de
sidrac alors reconnaissait le et
soutenez le merci la parole à notre
collègue alain chatillon pour le groupe
l'est républicain
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
madame la ministre de la santé je vais
vous interroger sur trois points le
premier set comment se fait-il que dans
ce pays on ne s'occupe pas un petit peu
plus quand on voit le budget de la
sécurité sociale dans l'état où il est
depuis des années un peu plus et
problème de prévention des produits de
prévention des produits de sécurité
alimentaire des produits de diététique
et des produits de régime comme cela se
fait dans la plupart des pays d'europe
particulièrement des périples les pays
d'europe du nord et l'allemagne
c'est ma première question la deuxième
question c'est ce que disait le
professeur cref voici une trentaine
d'années comment se fait-il que dans les
études pour les médecins il y ait cinq
fois moins d'études sur la nutrition que
pour les vétérinaires qui connaissent
beaucoup mieux la nutrition et c'est eux
qui la contrôle du reste enfin la
troisième question
la troisième question c'est tout
simplement comment se fait-il que la
dgccrf et la nes elle ne se préoccupe
pas des produits qui rentrent sur le
marché en provenance de suisse du
luxembourg de belgique notamment
absolument pas conforme à la
réglementation avec des informations
médicales
alors qu'ils n'ont aucune qualité pour
l'être donc sur ces trois questions
j'aimerais votre réponse merci
pour vous répondre la parole et à madame
la ministre des solidarités de la santé
madame agnès buzyn merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur alain
chatillon merci d'abord de poser cette
question je sais que le sujet de la
nutrition et de la santé vous tient à
coeur et merci de m'interroger sur cette
thématique donc les liens effectivement
entre santé nutrition sont de mieux en
mieux connus comme en témoigne
aujourd'hui les recommandations
nationales et internationales sur
l'alimentation
nous développons le nutrisse corps vous
le savez de façon à mieux alerter nos
concitoyens et ajustements à les aider à
être acteurs de la prévention en
s'alimentant de façon la meilleure
possible nous savons que le risque de
développer un nombre un grand nombre de
maladies chroniques est aujourd'hui lié
à la façon dont nous nous alimentons et
je vous rejoins dans l'idée qu'il est
important de promouvoir cette prévention
primaire c'est la raison pour laquelle
le service sanitaire où les étudiants en
santé vont faire d'eux des
interpellations dans les collèges des
lycées autour de thématiques de santé à
laax nutrition santé dans ses objectifs
par ailleurs s'agissant des produits
alimentaires ou de diététique non vous
parlez donc certains sont recommandés
par les agences nationales de santé
lorsqu'il s'agit de produits qui visent
à lutter contre la dénutrition ou dans
certaines maladies génétiques et elles
font l'objet évidemment d'information et
d'une règlementation géré par l' agence
nationale de sécurité du médicament
ensuite concernant les médicaments je
pense alternatif dont vous parlez des
produits diététiques qui vendent sur le
marché
beaucoup sont soumis à réglementation la
réglementation est différente de celle
qui concerne les médicaments
ils n'ont pas d'indications
thérapeutique ne font pas l'objet
exactement des mêmes contrôles par
contre aujourd'hui nous sommes en
difficulté pour contrôler des aliments
qui sont achetés sur internet plutôt les
compléments alimentaires
acheté sur internet par un grand nombre
de nos concitoyens nous veillons à ce
que l'information soit la meilleure
possible je vous prie de m'excuser nous
veillons à ce que la formation sur la
meilleure possible car nous avons des
alertes sanitaires sur la qualité de ses
produits qui échappent évidemment à la
réglementation il s'agit donc
aujourd'hui de savoir si ces produits
sont de utile ou pas ce n'est pas tant
de savoir s'ils sont naturels ou pas et
donc nous allons poursuivre aujourd'hui
toutes les mesures qui visent à mieux
réglementer ces achats sur internet
je vous remercie merci madame la
ministre monsieur châtillon oui je
rappelle que ces produits là s'il était
vendu comme en allemagne
ils ne sont pas remboursés par la
sécurité sociale et ça c'est un avantage
important ça pourrait faire j'ai fait un
premier calcul andreu milliard et deux
milliards d'euros d'économies
le deuxième point c'est les produits qui
effectivement pourrait apporter de la
valeur ajoutée à nos agriculteurs du
ginkgo biloba par exemple du ginseng et
bien d'autres produits aromatiques qui
pourrait être apportée vraiment de la
valeur ajoutée un certain nombre de
terres agricoles
voilà les éléments qui me paraissent
important c'est de se mobiliser pour que
l'on fasse plus de prévention et moins
d'actes après est ce que pour
franchement est ce que pour un rhume de
cerveau
on a besoin de prendre des anti
inflammatoires comme et ça coûte alors
qu'un rhume ça dure huit jours de toute
façon je pense qu'avec les plantes on
peut se soigner aussi bien pour un rhume
de cerveau
merci
la parole est à notre collègue agnès
constant pour le groupe de la république
en marche
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre chers collègues jeudi dernier
vous avez lancé l'application numérique
mobile mon compte formation
ce nouvel outil doit permettre à quelque
28 millions d'actifs de choisir depuis
leur smartphone une formation pour
obtenir des compétences supplémentaires
voire se reconvertir c'est aussi 25
millions d'euros mis à la disposition
des français
j'ai tester cette application
effectivement à moins de cinq minutes
muni du numéro de sécurité sociale nous
sommes informés du crédit en euro dont
on dispose pour financer une formation
des choix de formation ainsi que des
organismes agréés les plus proches et
cela sans demander d'autorisation
spécifique ou remplir de long formulaire
si les français s'en saisissent une
telle application pourrait permettre à
la france d'investir dans ce qui fait le
succès des pays aujourd'hui les
compétences et donner la possibilité à
nos concitoyens de s'épanouir en
enrichissant leur parcours professionnel
ou réaliser enfin la formation rêver
cette démarche correspond à notre époque
les citoyens veulent prendre leur avenir
en main et ne plus laisser dicter par
d'autres l'information qui leur
conviendrait le mieux avec cet outil
la formation devient comme la santé un
droit fondamental
le projet le progrès technologique et
plus que jamais il faut vous en
féliciter un progrès social et
économique
l'outil est là les français doivent s'en
servir
c'est sur cela que porte ma question
qu'a prévu le gouvernement pour que les
français se saisissent de cette
opportunité et notamment pour les moins
qualifiés d'entre eux de même qu'en est
il pour les travailleurs indépendants
je pense notamment au monde agricole
pourront-ils également utiliser cette
application
je vous remercie pour me répondre la
parole est à blâmer
muriel pénicaud monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice agnès constant
oui il ya un peu plus d'un an vous
votiez la loi pour la liberté de choisir
son avenir professionnel qui a permis
cette transformation j'ose dire cette
révolution
la formation professionnelle depuis j'ai
dû dernier nous avons lancé avec le
premier ministre
mon compte formation c'est un droit qui
arrive directement à 25 millions de nos
concitoyens
aujourd'hui les salariés les demandeurs
d'emploi et en avril ce seront aussi les
3 millions d' indépendants alors oui
c'est une révolution car aujourd'hui il
n'y a que 1 salarié sur trois dans les
petites entreprises
ouvriers employés qui accèdent à la
formation au moment où un métier sur
deux va se transformer dans les dix ans
qui viennent
cet accès à la compétence c'est la
protection contre le chômage c'est la
possibilité d'avoir une évolution de
carrière de changer de métier de changer
d'entreprise de mener sa vie
professionnelle
et oui cette application elle répond à
ses besoins en étant très simples comme
vous l'avez dit en quelques clics on
peut découvrir ses droits plus de 1000
euros en moyenne la moitié des français
ont déjà 1400 euros ils auront 500 euros
de plus chaque année 800 euros s'ils
sont un handicap
s'ils n'ont pas de diplôme on peut
découvrir l'offre de formation alors il
y en a déjà plus de 140 milles dans
l'hérault département s'est déjà 3600
offre de formation qui sont en ligne
et puis ça permet aussi comme vous
l'avez dit de décider sans intermédiaire
et je crois que c'est très essentiel
pour le futur alors comment le faire
connaître
d'abord je voudrais dire que les
français voudraient pour dû
immédiatement très fortement
il ya déjà 280 mille téléchargements à
la caisse des dépôts qui est l'opérateur
du ministère du travail dans les
lancements des applications de nouveaux
services publics c'est quelque chose de
extrêmement élevé et ça augmente d'heure
en heure mais aussi nous avons prévu
pour l'emploi et cap emploi pour les
demandeurs d'emploi les conseils en
évolution professionnelle gratuit qui
arrivent partout sur le territoire
nous avons une campagne de médias tv et
et presse qui démarre dimanche prochain
et puis les réseaux hier par exemple les
chambres de métiers au plan national un
million trois cent mille employeurs ont
déclaré que c'était un élément clé pour
que partout sur le territoire
les salariés des artisans puissent se
former donc les réseaux vont se
mobiliser aussi nous sommes le premier
pays au monde à créer ce droit universel
ensemble faisons le connaître sur le
terrain
bien la parole et à notre collègue henri
leroy pour le groupe l'est républicain
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre collègues ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de
l'environnement
rappelez vous le 3 octobre 2015
département des alpes maritimes a été
frappé par de dramatiques intempéries
faisant 20 morts plus de 30 mille
sinistrés plusieurs centaines de
millions de dégâts
suite à ce drame le conseil
départemental les intercommunalités et
les communes est atteint et teams ont
créé le syndicat mixte inondation
aménagement et gestion de l'eau marc
alpin 10 nuages chargés de gérer le
facteur inondations et déterminer
l'ensemble des travaux indispensables en
collaboration avec les services de
l'état les agences publiques
les aménagements urgent était donc
parfaitement identifiés pour assurer la
protection maximum des personnes et des
biens entre le 22 et le 25 novembre 2010
les pluies diluviennes inondée à nouveau
le var et les alpes maritimes
plus de vingt mille foyers sinistrés
d'innombrables effondrement éboulements
nécessitant des centaines de relogement
pour beaucoup les mêmes victimes qu'en
2015 une personne auront trouvé à ce
jour et cinq morts au cours de ce drame
l'ensemble des forces de sécurité et
services municipaux avec leur mère ont
été remarquables par leur engagement
terrain depuis 2015 la dréal freine
retardent et va jusqu'à bloquer la
réalisation des travaux urgents et
indispensables identifié au prétexte de
la protection des espèces dites
protégées batraciens ou plantes en tout
genre et lorsqu'une étude se termine
elle en ordonne une nouvelle si les
travaux parfaitement identifiées par le
sz nuages avaient été réalisés des vies
des dégâts humains et matériels aurait
sans doute pu être évité
madame la ministre ne pensez vous pas
aujourd'hui qu'il est indispensable de
créer une procédure d'urgence pour
anticiper et faire face à ce genre de
situation qui se multiplient par
ailleurs allez vous donner des
instructions à la dréal pour faciliter
les dossiers en cours et faire passer
les vies humaines
avant les espèces protégées ce qui n'est
pas le cas aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
pour vous répondre la parole et à la
ministre de la transition écologique et
solidaire avait la parole monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur alors
vous l'avez rappelé notre pays a été à
nouveau durement touché par des
intempéries le week end dernier avec
onze départements en vigilance orange
pour des risques divers de vents
violents d'inondations de submersion
marine est effectivement de département
dans les alpes maritimes ont été placés
en vigilance rouge par météo france
je voudrais à nouveau exprimer toute ma
solidarité aux familles et aux proches
des victimes et salué la mobilisation
exceptionnelle des forces de secours des
services de l'état des collectivités et
des opérateurs est monsieur ministre de
l'intérieur s'est rendu sur place et il
a pu constater cette mobilisation
exceptionnelle
alors effectivement face à ces
événements dont on le sait qu'ils seront
de plus en plus fréquent est de plus en
plus violents il nous faut agir pour
prévenir les conséquences de ces
inondations
c'est ce que nous faisons avec les plans
de prévention du risque inondation
l'épée périt c'est ce que nous faisons
au travers des programmes d'action pour
la prévention des inondations
les papilles avec des financements
importants sur le fonds barnier c'est ce
que font les communes avec leurs plans
communaux de sauvegarde et je pense
qu'on a pu en mesurer toute l'efficacité
ce week end
mais effectivement il faut qu'on arrive
à mettre en place toutes les mesures
prévues dans les papilles les programmes
d'action pour la prévention des
inondations sans doute de façon plus
rapide et c'est bien le sens d'une
inspection que j'ai demandé à mon
ministère pour regarder ce qui peut
aujourd'hui freiné la réalisation de ces
programmes d'action je disposerai très
prochainement des propositions et je
pense que nous aurons l'occasion d'en
débattre il nous faut effectivement agir
plus efficacement pour prévenir ces
risques inondation et c'est ce que nous
allons faire
merci madame les mini-jeux la parole et
notre collègue martine filleul
pour le groupe socialiste et républicain
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
après deux ans de réticences et de
tergiversations la convention de
financement entre l'état et les
collectivités locales pour la
construction du canal seine nord a été
signé par le président de la république
vendredi dernier sa réalisation devient
ferme et définitive et l'état prend
enfin sa part en s'engageant à apporter
un milliard d'euros sur les 5 milliards
du coût total
si nous saluons cette formalisation nous
ne demeurerons pas moins circonspect sur
la forme
certains parlementaires des hauts de
france n'ont pas été conviés et ont
appris la nouvelle dans la presse
bien qu'habituée au mépris du
gouvernement envers le parlement nous le
déplorons fortement la plupart d'entre
nous ayant soutenu ce projet souvent
contre vents et marées à ce propos le
gouvernement est frappé d'amnésie
lorsqu'il indique que ses prédécesseurs
avaient confondu les annonces et les
actes
laissez moi vous rafraîchir la mémoire
le canal n'existerait pas sans
l'engagement du gouvernement précédent
qui a obtenu le financement parfaitement
qui a obtenu le financement à 40 % par
l'europe
il n'existerait pas non plus sans
l'acharnement pendant plus de vingt ans
des élus et des collectivités
territoriales au premier rang desquels
les socialistes c'est votre gouvernement
c'est votre gouvernement qui l'a
suspendu en juillet 2017
sur le fond le gouvernement a en
dernière minute et sans explication
claire chez adopté à l'assemblée
nationale un amendement au projet de loi
de finances sans c'est prévoir la part
de financement de l'état
or le mécanisme prévu est loin d'être
sécurisant en effet rien ne garantit que
l'abandon supplémentaires à lafitte
obtenue grâce
l'indexation de la taxe d'aménagement du
territoire sur l'inflation ont conclu
les chais pour le financement du canal
pouvez-vous aujourd'hui monsieur le
premier ministre nous préciser les
choses et nous certifier que cette
augmentation sera exclusivement destiné
à la construction du canal merci pour
vous répondre la parole et co secrétaire
d'état en charge des transports au refus
de la réunion merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice
vous avez rappelé que ce projet a
beaucoup d'atouts c'est vrai que c'est
un projet qui est bon pour
l'environnement avec le transfert prévu
de plusieurs milliers de poids lourds
qui circulent actuellement sur l'a1
c'est un projet qui est bon pour
l'économie portuaire et fluvial non
seulement pour la zone région de
dunkerque mais aussi pour les ports de
l'axé seine que l'emploi l'emploi l'état
pardon s'emploie à renforcer depuis
maintenant deux ans puis c'est un projet
qui est bon pour le territoire pour le
territoire des hauts de france avec
quatre plateformes multimodales qui vont
être créés les connecter à cette
nouvelle infrastructure avec autant
d'emplois et de croissance locale pour
dire oui au canal il fallait créer les
conditions de crédibilité de ce projet
vous l'avez dit son coût a été réévalué
à 5 milliards d'euros il ya deux ans
dans un exercice inédit de transparence
et de sincérité budgétaire
je peux vous affirmer ici que la
sécurisation de la part état du
financement est prévu et que la
trajectoire de la fuite ne se retrouvera
pas modifié et que tout ce qui a été
prévu dans l'âme sera réalisé évidemment
comme cela a été comme cela comme nous
sommes engagés pour cela nous faisons
confiance aux collectivités locales au
travers de la société de projet qui sera
régionalisée dès le 1er avril 2020
madame la sénatrice et enfin vous l'avez
rappelé l'europe a été mobilisé à
hauteur de 2 milliards d'euros sur sur
ce projet l'état veut par ailleurs que
ce projet soit exemplaire en terme
environnemental et économique évidemment
j'en ai parlé mais aussi en termes
d'insertion locale dans l'emploi et
c'est tout l'objet de la démarche grand
chantier qui est aujourd'hui menée sous
l'égide du préfet de la région hôte
france enfin elle vous avez raison
madame la sénatrice pour ce projet il
fallait une coalition
d'acteur et d'action et je veux saluer
les élus de tous bords dont vous êtes
qui ont défendu avec opiniâtreté et
détermination un projet que les autres
france attendait depuis plus de 40 ans
mais c'est une autre gouvernement qui
l'a rendu possible et donc irréversible
en signant la convention de financement
la semaine dernière en présence du
président de la république à nesles cela
permettra à madame la sénatrice de
donner les premiers coups de pioche vers
compiègne en octobre 2020 et de viser
une mise en service à l'horizon 2028
vous remercie merci monsieur le premier
ministre les dames de messieurs du
ministre merci nos prochaines questions
d'actualité auront lieu notez le bien le
11 décembre 2010 9 à 15 heures il n'y a
pas de questions d'actualité la semaine
prochaine des raisons budgétaires
évidentes je vais suspendre la séance
elle sera reprise à 16h30 pour l'examen
de la mission écologie développement et
mobilité durables
la séance est suspendue
[Musique]
voilà c'est la fin des questions au
gouvernement une séance particulière
marquée par de multiples hommages aux
treize militaires ayant perdu la vie
avant-hier au mali alors l'émotion était
assez intense tout à l'heure puisque le
fils du sénateur jean marie bockel fait
partie des victimes alors sans le citer
edouard philippe a eu quelques mots à
son égard
bien conscient de la résonance toute
particulière de ce tragique événement
ici au sénat christian cambon président
de la commission des affaires étrangères
et ami de jean marie bockel a prononcé
un discours particulièrement touchant on
les écoute
devons respect recueillement et
reconnaissance ici au sénat viendra
sûrement le temps des interrogations
elles sont légitimes peut-être aussi
faudra-t-il un débat mais aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui nous savons que face à une
extension de la menace djihadiste vers
les pays voisins
notre présence militaire est
indispensable je dirais même qu'elle est
incontournable car sans sécurité
inutile de croire au développement ou à
plus de présence sur le terrain d'un
état malien déjà si défaillant pensez
vous monsieur le premier ministre
pouvoir mobiliser plus encore nos alliés
européens et occidentaux afin qu'il nous
aide encore plus efficacement et qu'un
tel drame ne se reproduise plus jamais
en d'autres termes pour que pierre
emmanuel bockel et ses compagnons
d'infortuné ne soient pas morts pour
rien alors qu'on vient d'entendre cet
événement a ouvert le débat sur la
présence des forces françaises au mali
mais le premier ministre est claire à ce
sujet le combat militaire contre les
jihadistes est indispensable tant pour
la sécurité en ici en france que pour la
stabilité des pays du sahel
un combat militaire qui n'empêche pas
toutefois je cite une stabilisation
politique de ces pays mais également de
développement économique alors edouard
philippe a pris la parole à deux
reprises tout à l'heure à ce sujet et
lors de sa première réponse peu après
l'ouverture de la séance juste après
donc cette la fin de sa réponse il a été
très chaleureusement applaudi sur tous
les bancs de l'hémicycle
alors donc si le débat autour de la
présence des troupes françaises au sahel
est ouvert le respect pour l'engagement
de nos militaires lui ne pose pas
question et dépasse les clivages
politiques
merci beaucoup à l'iss pour toutes ces
explications autour de cette séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement je
suis toujours avec emilie zapolsky merci
d'être resté avec nous je rappelle que
vous êtes communicante et fondatrice de
lagence emilie
conseil alors c'est effectivement l'un
des temps forts de cette séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
plusieurs interventions autour et bien
de la mort de ses treize militaires
morts au mali dans le cadre de
l'opération barkan sont des moments
d'une à limiter aussi dans l'hémicycle
qui font pas assez rare d'unanimité
politique alors d'unanimité oui et puis
de communion on voit bien qu'on rend
hommage c'est le moment de rendre
hommage à ces soldats qui sacrifie
parfois leur vie pour nous et pour ces
pays qui sont en guerre on voit bien les
mots de christian cambon était est et
clarins est vraiment le moment de
communier ensemble de faire cet hommage
edouard philippe l'a fait également
et puis de bien dire qu' il n'y a pas de
remise en question de la présence
militaire de la france puisqu'il ya eu
quelques échos là dessus très rapidement
après l'annnonce de cet événement du
côté de jean luc mélenchon notamment là
c'est vraiment le mot d'ordre c'est de
dire on ne peut pas remettre en question
la présence militaire
après viendra le moment plus de
réflexion de l'initiative européenne de
savoir comment on peut aider ces pays à
se développer on parle de coopération
décentralisée
il ya un projet de loi qui est dans les
cartons mais qui a du mal à émerger
ça sera un deuxième temps de réflexion
plus aboutie mais effectivement à
l'heure est au consensus pour l'instant
en revanche il ya un sujet sur lequel il
n'y a pas du tout consensus ce sujet et
bien c'est celui des retraites
et justement et d'un quentin calmer
salle des conférences vous trouvé avec
le haut-commissaire en retraite jean
paul ii le voir c'était là aussi l'un
des temps forts de cette séance de
questions d'actualité tout à fait à mme
bonjour jean paul delevoye
bonjour est loin d'être cette prise de
parole d'edouard philippe le premier
ministre qui en sortie du conseil des
ministres a dit qu'il fallait trouver le
bon curseur sur la date d'application de
la réforme alors expliquez nous est ce
que ça signifie qu'il va y avoir une
clause de grand-père en fonction des
profils des professions et ça ce sera
négociée d'abord le premier ministre
souhaitait s'exprimer après deux jours
de rencontres avec la totalité des
acteurs syndicaux
chacun ayant souligné avec beaucoup de
gravité la pertinence d'un système
universel et chacun exprimant ses
positions opposées ou favorable à ce
système avec un certain nombre de
particularités la cfdt a insisté sur son
combat pour le minimum et la pénibilité
et d'autres ayant exprimé leur volonté
d'être contre ce système
alors qu'est laquelle mise en action le
premier ministre a très clairement
indiqué que je poursuivrai mes
rencontres et que le 9 ou le 10 décembre
j'en tirerai les conclusions et qu'il
appartiendra au premier ministre avant
la fin d'année de pouvoir offrir à nos
concitoyens l' architecture du système
les principes du système est de faire en
sorte que donc des choses soient très
clairement clarifier ce sont les
rencontres branches professionnelles par
branche professionnelle
actuellement nous avons 350 réunions
pour faire en sorte que pour chaque
profession nous puissions offrir un
chemin de convergence entre leur
situation actuelle et le système
universel auquel nous aspirons
alors parlons de ces rencontres un avec
les éditions patronales et syndicales
qui avaient dû à matignon est lundi et
mardi par exemple et bien geoffroy roux
de bézieux il a dit qu'il y avait une
confusion autour de la réforme
quand laurent berger de la cfdt a parlé
de tergiversations vous reconnaissez il
ya un flou quand même autour de cette
réforme des retraites
je pense que les principes sont clairs
ils sont dans mon rapport remis le 10
juillet un système universel un système
à points
un système qui garantit l'évolution
positive des pensions un système de
redistribution envers les plus précaires
et envers les femmes
et donc ces principes sont ancrées et
quand je rencontre les citoyens ils sont
perçus positivement
il reste ensuite toute une série de
discussions sur la gouvernance sur la
transition sur les moyens à mettre en
oeuvre pour accompagner cette transition
et il est difficile d'imaginer que nous
puissions affichait les solutions avant
même qu'elle que les discussions ont
abouti et donc certains cherchent à
cultiver la notion du flou nous nous
sommes constants dans notre démarche
respect pour les partenaires sociaux ait
clarification d'ici la fin de l'année
un dernier mot rapide 1 sur ces
simulations de l'institut
de protection sociale ça vous fait pas
très plaisir inverse simulation on parle
notamment d'une maman avec trois enfants
qui perdrait avec le nouveau système on
entendu parler ou même les sénateurs de
16 de ces simulations qu'est ce que vous
répondez à cet institut d'abord vous
échappe à personne que cet institut a
engagé un plaidoyer anti système
universel il l'a fait dans une étude
précédente
la seconde c'est que cette étude est
fondée sur des raisonnements faux ils
prennent l'hypothèse d'une maman qui
partira génération 63 à 62 ans au 1er
janvier de ville 25 c'est à dire qu'elle
n'aura même pas cotisé dans le futur
système
deuxième élément je vous donne un
élément déterminant l'étude n'intègre
pas l'indexation
c'est à dire qu'il ya une perte à peu
près de 35% des droits et donc qu'ils
affichent une baisse de 11%
quand en réalité de 19 % quand en
réalité les calculs que nous nous
formons c'est une augmentation de 11% et
donc vous voyez bien qu'il faut faire
attention à toutes celles et ceux qui au
lieu d'éclairer le débat cherche à le
manipuler
merci beaucoup jean paul delevoye et on
le voit le débat ne fait que commencer
sur l'écran des retraites
merci à vous merci beaucoup canton pour
cette interview j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir en plateau nous ont rejoint
christian cambon bonjour je vous êtes
président de la commission de la défense
et des affaires étrangères sénateurs et
l'air du val de marne merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous on vous a entendu
d'ailleurs lors de cette séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
sur le mali est un sujet que nous allons
évoquer dans un instant également sur ce
plateau à gilbert luc devinaz ce bonjour
sénateur socialiste du rhône membre de
la commission des affaires étrangères et
de la défense
et enfin également avec nous joël
guerriau sénateurs les indépendants de
la loire atlantique vice président de la
commission des affaires étrangères et de
la défense mais d'abord nous allons
parler de la question des retraites
on vient d'entendre l'intervention de
jean paul delevoye à l'instant je le
disais c'est un sujet qui n'est pas
vraiment consensuelle la preuve en est
eh bien elle attaque qu'il y a
tout à l'heure dans l'hémicycle par
monique lubin sénatrice socialiste de ce
projet de réforme
on l'écouté on en parle jusqu'après les
français seraient pessimiste mais
comment pourrait-il en être autrement
quand ils considèrent que leurs
difficultés sont mal comprises de leurs
gouvernants quand les solutions avancées
repose quasiment toujours sur la
stigmatisation de telle ou telle
catégorie la réforme forcée de
l'assurance chômage sur les chômeurs
soit disant profiteurs la réforme de
l'accès à l'aide médicale d'état pour
les étrangers soit disant consommateurs
de notre système de santé
et maintenant la réforme des retraites
avec son lot d'annoncés désordonnée et
anxiogène
le tout bien sûr sur fond de
stigmatisation de ces nantis qui serait
la source des maux de tous les autres
divisez toujours divisés monsieur le
premier ministre
où est l'état où l état protecteur
christian cambon votre réaction à cette
intervention c'est aussi une référence
au fait que emmanuel macron a largement
parlé ni de réflexe corporatiste dans
les grévistes qui seront est bien dans
la rue le 5 décembre prochain
cette affaire des retraites je crois que
on sait depuis bien longtemps qu'elle
est explosive qui nous on se souvient du
mot 2 de michel rocard
je pense que dans la proche du
gouvernement il ya des points positifs
car le système montre depuis longtemps
un certain nombre de failles d'inégalité
d'injustice sûr lorsqu'on vous êtes
d'accord avec l'idée d'un système
universel par points
sur le fond moi personnellement c'est
une notion qui ne à laquelle je ne suis
pas hostile
je pense en revanche que la manière dont
s'y prend le gouvernement d'annoncer
j'allais dire selon la technique des
tranches de salami différents aspects de
la réforme de maintenir cette
concertation mais qui semble changer de
jouer sur un calendrier on dit c'est
pour tout de suite c'est pour maintenant
c'est pour plus tard c'est pour dans 40
ans sacré effectivement un climat
d'anxiété qui ne cesse de s'accroître si
de surcroît on laisse on laisse penser
que on va piocher dans certains régimes
pour en alimenter d'autres car
finalement nous tous qui sommes là on a
tous quelque part cotiser on a tous
constitués aussi
en tous les cas des droits à notre
retraite même si le système fonctionne
par répartition donc je pense qu'il ya
des bons principes qui sont mis en avant
et tous les pays européens ont modifié
et ont changé leurs régimes de retraite
ne serait ce que pour tenir compte de
l'allongement de la durée de la vie
c'est un fait que personne ne peut ou ne
peut contester et aussi souligné que le
pourcentage depuis la libération c'est
un voeu c'est juste l'inversé et avait
deux personnes qui travaillaient pour
une persona retraite maintenant on roule
vers de retraités pour une personne qui
travaille donc un enfant du 8e est
capable de comprendre ça m'est donc je
pense que dans la méthode il faudrait
remettre un petit peu les facteurs en
ligne gilbert luc devinaz ne peut pas
faire autrement que changer le système
c'est ce que nous dit avec christian
cambon jean paul delevoye a dit le
soutien à l'universalité va permettre de
retrouver le bien commun c'est là la
philosophie de sa réforme mais on voit
bien que dans la rue ce qui qui qui
craignent cette réforme craignent bien
sûr bien pour avoir moins de droits et
et moi à la fin du mois à la retraite
écoutez je viens d'écouter ce que vient
de dire un ami christian président de
notre commission
je suis pas convaincu comme lui que la
proposition d'aller vers une retraite
universel soit en tous les cas
aujourd'hui je suis dans le doute et
monsieur de lenoir vient de s'exprimer
en disant qu'il fallait contre carrer
ceux qui disent n'importe quoi mais le
gouvernement aujourd'hui dans son
expression laisse planer le doute sur
tout
c'était le droit d'aller saluer tout à
l'heure catherine de roche qui est à
dire oui on a on n'y comprend plus rien
on n'y comprend plus rien je partage ce
qui est dit catherine de roche et
monsieur delaunois dans cette interview
vient de dire en même temps puisque
c'est le mot à la mode que
il le premier ministre venait de
rencontrer faire des débats avec des
organisations syndicales au regard
rencontrer les organisations syndicales
et quand on lui demande des précisions
il renvoie son rappeur qui date d'avant
la rencontre et qu'ils organisaient les
salaires donc moi qui étaient syndiqués
à une époque mais j'ai connu ce que
c'était que la négociation avec un chef
d'entreprise
jamais un chef d'entreprise s'est
comporté de la sorte après une
négociation on va sur des propositions
qui tiennent compte de la négociation et
qui ne renvoient pas un rapport qui
était feuilles à quelques quelques mois
par un éminent haut fonctionnaire donc
j'ai des doutes et après ça rejoint
quand même la méthode du président macro
présent macron part du principe qu'il a
été élu par les français et qu'il a été
lui pour son programme
c'est une erreur moi je n'ai pas voté
macro premier tour et macron le
président mac ont été votés par 24 % de
ceux qui ont été votées ah oui mais on
peut pas lui reprocher d'appliquer son
nom
ça veut dire que 24% des français au
premier tour au soutenu son poème mois
deuxième tour j'ai voté emmanuel mâcon
mais j'ai pas voté son programme
j'ai barré la route à une autre
candidature et ça pose si on continue
comme ça ça posera des problèmes à la
vème république joëlle garriaud vous
votre votre avis justement d'abord
effectivement aussi sur sur la forme la
façon qu'a eue le gouvernement de s'y
prendre sur cette réforme il ya eu tout
de même tout à l'heure quelques
éclaircissements par le premier ministre
qui a bien dit jean paul delevoye va
s'exprimer le 10 décembre
après il y aura un arbitrage par le
premier ministre et on attend le texte
pour le début de l'année prochaine
donc on commence à avoir au moins
quelques éléments de calendrier mais
vous ne devrez d'apporter la réponse la
question que je me posais dire qu on y
voit clair sur un calendrier
maintenant à caractère sur le fond la
réforme maintenant ce calendrier
s'inscrit dans une histoire
je rappelle que le premier livre blanc
sur les retraites date de 1991 que
depuis il ya eu un certain nombre de
l'indicateur qui montre combien le
vieillissement de la population pose
problème qu'il faut traiter ce sujet là
qu'on peut pas dépasser 13 8% du pib qui
est consacrée au financement des
retraites qu'il ya bien là un sujet qui
n'est pas évitable et je comprends la
difficulté
et puisqu'il s'agit de travailler sur le
fond et en profondeur ce qui n'est pas
simple et qui conduit évidemment à des
frictions en particulier quand on parle
de l'universalité
contrairement à ceux qui disent que le
gouvernement veut diviser la france pas
du tout
elle est déjà à diviser aller / des
systèmes totalement inégalitaire 40 de
l'agriculture
tout à l'heure nous en parler
agriculture vous savez ce que c'est que
le revenu moyen d'un agriculteur à la
retraite c'est de l'or de 880 euros
c'est à dire en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté ou savez qu'il ya des écarts
énormes dans la fonction publique un
autre un fonctionnaire d'état qui part
en moyenne à l'âge de 62 ans pour une
retraite de 2100 euros
vous avez un retraité de la sncf qui va
partir à 56 ans avec 1 avec en moyenne
une retraite de 2600 donc on voit bien
que les inégalités que les régimes
spéciaux coûte cher puisque la moitié du
financement des régimes peu spéciaux
provient de qui de l'état c'est à dire
finalement du fait que les cotisants à
l'écran facilité par leurs cotisations
de payer leur propre retraite donc faut
bien à quel contribuable à la rescousse
est ce qu'on peut continuer comme ça est
ce que ceux qui sont dans un système
finalement qui les défavorisés peuvent
continuer à travailler
peut être plus pour arriver à financer
non pas leur retraite mille retraite qui
crée des inégalités qui sont un fait
dont je conçois tout à fait la
difficulté du gouvernement
je pense que le premier ministre
aujourd'hui dans ses déclarations a été
très clair et je pense qu'il faut suivre
et qu'on rentrer dans ce débat comme
nous le ferons lors de l'ouverture en
janvier des questions de cette question
parlement et mise à emilie zapolsky joël
guerriau nous dit voilà c'est la france
qui est divisé ce n'est pas le
gouvernement qui divise
lorsqu'il parle d'ailleurs d'un
corporatisme vous votre alors moi j'ai
l'impression que le gouvernement s'est
donné beaucoup beaucoup d'objectifs pour
une seule réforme qui on l'a vu par le
passé pose toujours des soucis réformer
les retraites c'est très compliqué juppé
c'est toujours du monde dans la rue
c'est là dans la rue
là on a voulu faire beaucoup beaucoup et
à la retraite à points il ya
l'universalité dont vous avez parlé il
ya de nouveaux droits et on a
l'impression que du coup le gouvernement
n'arrive pas à communiquer en versa avec
en plus le traumatisme de l'année
dernière du mouvement d'aidé gilet jaune
avec cette espèce de de yo yo le rapport
delevoye sort tout de suite après
emmanuel macron dix ans maintenant l'âge
pivot finalement on n'est pas sûr là on
revient comme vous le disiez tout à
l'heure sur le rapport delevoye alors
qu'on a dit on se concerte ça fait quand
même 2 ans que les syndicats sont dessus
et on a du mal à comprendre pourquoi il
n'y a pas de mesure où deux pistes
qu'ils soient concrètes et qui soit
visiblement exprimer peut-être qu'il ya
trop d'objectifs dans cette réforme
et alors il ya un glissement aussi qui
est assez particulier mais là c'est
c'est d'ailleurs monique lubin qui parle
de où est l'état protecteur
oui la fin d'un question voilà parce
qu'on a l'impression que c'est un
gouvernement qui transforme l'état en
sorte de commercial qui on donne des
impôts on doit avoir un service
correspondance et à ses impôts pareil
pour la retraite je cotise je dois avoir
à la hauteur de ma cotisation mais c'est
oublier le principe même de la
philosophie des retraites de la
solidarité même du chômage de
l'assurance chômage c'est qu'on cotise
tous pour qu en effet on s'y retrouve
tous à peu près donc forcément il y aura
des perdants et forcément il ya des gens
qui gagnent alors il ya des nouveaux
droits bon a priori on remet en question
des droits pour les mères de famille de
trois enfants mais logiquement cette
réforme elle était aussi fait pour faire
un minimum de droits à 1000 euros pour
les retraites ce qui est ce qui n'existe
pas vous l'avait dit pour les
agriculteurs c'est en dessous de 1000
euros c'est quand même une une maman
s'appelle objectif pour les mères de
famille pareil donc on a perdu cette
notion de redistribution et c'est pas
pour un euro cotisé je vais avoir un
euro de retraite n'ont cessé plus ça on
n'est plus là dedans
sauf que le gouvernement a du mal à
s'exprimer parce qu'il prend les
citoyens pour des consommateurs de
services de l'état eh bien écoutez on
aura en tout cas l'occasion d'en
reparler puisque
ce texte est bien le connaître au début
de l'année prochaine au dessus de 100
alors le 10 décembre n'aura les
premières annonces de jean paul delevoye
et l'année prochaine on aura le texte
normalement nous at on promis
deuxième sujet qui a largement marqué
cette séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
le mali bien sûr après la mort de treize
militaires engagés dans l'opération
barkan c'était lundi un véritable moment
d'unanimité et dans l'hémicycle on va
tout de suite
écoutez edouard philippe le premier
ministre qui est intervenu tout à
l'heure dans l'ouverture de cette séance
de questions d'actualité et nous devons
savoir que ce qui se joue là bas est
important pour nous ici et que ce combat
sera long et difficile
l'honneur d'une démocratie c'est de
faire en sorte que le pouvoir politique
choisisse d'engager des troupes sur un
théâtre d'opérations étrangers
lorsqu'ils considèrent que c'est
nécessaire c'est une lourde
responsabilité
et elle a été lourde pour tous ceux qui
ont exercé ces choix l'honneur d'une
démocratie c'est aussi de dire la fierté
que représente pour nous tous ces hommes
et ces femmes et j'ai bien conscience
monsieur le président quand dix ans ces
mots je suis un peu maladroit mais je
peux vous dire mesdames et messieurs que
je suis infiniment admiratif et que nous
sommes tous infiniment admiratif de ce
qu'ils font sur place
les figures grave les applaudissements
sur tous les bancs de l'hémicycle
christian cambon vous également lorsque
vous êtes intervenu il ya eu ce moment
d'unanimité
c'est quand même un moment d'union
d'union politique au moins dans ce
moment dommage écoutez je crois que nous
sommes encore sous le choc
nous le sommes deux fois j'allais dire
trois fois puisque ici on a trois
membres de la commission des affaires
étrangères et de la défense dont la
mission ici dans cette maison est
justement de suivre notamment nos
opérations extérieures est de faire en
sorte que nos soldats puissent se battre
dans les meilleures conditions de
sécurité
donc une telle nouvelle est un choc
parce que je n'oublie pas que le
parlement se prononce lui aussi lorsque
l'opération l'opération extérieur est
prolongée donc à partir du moment où
nous votons c'est que quelque part nous
avons aussi la responsabilité des vies
de ses hommes et donc le choc état est
immense il est d'autant plus que mais je
ne reviens pas dessus
l'un des nôtres a perdu son fils et
comme tout le monde connaît jean marie
bockel et et le respectent les
responsabilités qui lui précédemment je
crois que ça ne fait qu'amplifier
l'émotion au delà de ça moi ce que j'ai
souhaité dire c'est que le temps n'était
pas à la polémique
je pense qu'il n'est pas nécessaire pour
l'instant d'ouvrir la discussion
discussion il y aura bien sûr qu'il ya
des interrogations bien sûr qu' on ne
peut pas imaginer pendant 5 ans 10 ans
15 ans ou 20 ans allonger cette liste
interminable
ils sont déjà 549 sur le monument que
nous venons d'inaugurer le 11 9 ans
c'est déjà tellement il est tellement
important
et puis je pense que nous avons aussi le
souci de garder ce souvenir qui se
souvient des 89 soldats qui sont morts à
uzbin en afghanistan l'afghanistan qui
est de nouveau à vau l'eau et dont on
peut se demander pourquoi sont ils morts
le temps de la réflexion via mais pour
l'instant au moment même où nous parlons
leurs dépouilles revient sur le
territoire national donc je crois qu'il
faut laisser le temps de
le temps du respect je pense que les
familles si vous perdez un enfant si
vous perdez votre conjoint vous n'avez
pas envie de vous poser tout de suite la
question de savoir pourquoi vous avez
envie un peu de solidarité un peu de
concorde nationale et un peu de de
silence j'allais presque dire pour faire
en sorte que ces douleurs vous puissiez
la faire vôtre et c'est ce que nous
essayons de faire en dix ans il ya un
temps pour chaque chose
ça ne veut pas dire qu'il n'y aura pas
de débat et je pense que par exemple il
faut que le parlement soit plus associé
dans l'avenir c'est quand même 4502 nous
sommes beaucoup plus si on y ajoute les
autres terrains de sur lequel ils
interviennent et c'est plus d'un
milliard d'euros donc je dire ce n'est
pas rien mais pour l'instant faisons
attention à ne pas blesser les familles
qui souffrent effectivement l'heure
n'est pas à la polémique gilbert luc
devinaz néanmoins pour revenir sur les
raisons pour lesquelles la france est
intervenue au mali c'est là s'est passé
c'était la décision de françois hollande
le précédent président de la république
pour quelles raisons faut-il que les
forces françaises soient sur place
mais écoutez il faudrait projeter une
carte
regardez où se trouve le mali qui est
juste en dessous du maroc de l'algérie
et aujourd'hui je suis d'ailleurs
maintenant au dessus vous avez l'algérie
et le maroc les pays du maghreb et les
pays du maghreb c'est le sud de l'europe
est aujourd'hui la méditerranée c'est
plus comme le siècle dernier
c'est devenu quelque chose qui se
trancher très facilement ça c'est le
premier point maintenant je m'associe
aussi à ce que vient de dire le
président dans l'hémicycle ya deux
discours qui ont été applaudi par
l'ensemble des sénateurs
celui du premier si nice est celui du
prise en commission à christian cambon
ça signifie quelque chose
et bien sûr que nous sommes très
affectés plus particulier fait qd et à
la commission défense puisque jean marie
bockel a perdu son fils l'histoire est
acide moi j'ai qu'il ya quelques années
j'ai milité dans le même parti politique
que jean marie bockel et cette année je
suis parti en mission avec lui en
colombie ça rapproche
bien évidemment les hommes et comme
vient de le dire président bon il ya un
temps pour tout
là on est dans le temps du recueillement
je dirais même dans le temps du deuil
et puis il y aura un temps du débat du
reste au moment de la loi de
programmation militaire
j'avais proposé à mon groupe un
amendement qui a été repris par le
groupe qui n'a pas été voté et qui
proposait que une fois par an les
opérations extérieures et les missions à
l'intérieur fasse l'objet avant juin
d'un débat quand elle était prolongée et
qu'enfin d'opérations extérieures quand
le gouvernement ne décide il y ait un
débat ce qu'à l'heure actuelle on prend
la décision
vous parlez 2013 c'était une bonne
décision
il ya eu une décision politique et une
action rapide militaire mais cette
rapidité fait que en fait on y est
depuis six ans et que depuis six ans les
choses sur place ont changé et que quand
on lit un certain nombre de données
qu'on écoute le général facon qu'on
écoute les propos du président la
république il y à des interprétations
sur le terrain qui semble différente ça
nécessite au moins par une préparant de
refaire le point et de refaire un point
sur les objectifs qu'on a donné à
l'armée française et l'armée française
c'est pas la solution
la solution il sera politique on peut
débattre sans polémiquer sur cette
situation sur la présence française au
mali dans l'hémicycle beaucoup ont
demandé on demandait aussi un
renforcement européen joël guerriau sur
place 1 oui d'abord moi je voudrais
avoir une pensée pour les treize
familles de ces soldats qui sont morts
au mali et rappelé effectivement le sens
de l'intervention française au mali
et je pense aussi à ces trente six mille
familles maliennes qui en 14-18 entendu
le nom d'un des leurs qui est mort pour
la france je crois que c'est pas
seulement à devoir national par rapport
à la question du terrorisme qui nous
importe ceux ci un pays francophone avec
cinq cent mille malien qui vivent en
france et qui représente aussi 20
millions un peu plus de 20 millions de
maliens au mali ce n'est pas le cas pour
assurer notre énorme je crois que nous
avons subies au nord de solidarité par
rapport à l'histoire qui nous unit et
par rapport à cette situation qui font
que nous ne pouvons pas rester dans
l'indifférence
et conduire finalement ce pays là dans
une situation qui serait inéluctable
vous parlez de l'europe bien sûr qu'on
peut compter aussi sur les européens et
de se retourner vers les européens lui
demande et leur demander de nous
soutenir sur notre action mais je crois
que c'est avant tout le devoir de la
france c'est de voir de la france
attaché à l'histoire de france et
leicester du mali nous sommes deux pays
lille y est liée par des événements qui
ont été des événements dramatiques et ce
n'est pas aujourd'hui le moment de se
remettre en question sur l'importance du
rôle de nos soldats sur le terrain
malien bien au contraire je crois que
nous pouvons nous enorgueillir
et d'abord nous avons pour eux beaucoup
d'admiration c'est interdit par notre
président le président cambon dans
l'hémicycle et aussi par le premier
ministre ce sont là des missions d'une
très haute importance et qui aussi
répondent finalement à ce que nous
devons à l'égard du peuple que nous ne
pouvons pas laisser pour compte dans une
situation catastrophique à des moyens
eux mêmes des moyens militaires très
faible vous savez à chaque fois qu'on
met des moyens militaires pour protéger
sécuriser la population malienne c'est
quelque part favoriser le développement
du mali parce qu'il n'ya pas de
développement dans un pays qui soit pas
un pays en paix et qu'ils soient
sécurisés et 7 et cet argent et ses
fonds que nous donnons ce sont aussi des
fonds qui servent
sur le plan humanitaire pour permettre à
ce pays de vivre mieux et de se
développer
c'est très très important nous ne devons
pas quitter le territoire malien j'en
suis profondément convaincu et c'est en
l'occurrence une question je dirais de
dignité française emilie appel ce qui en
sort ici sur ce plateau l'unanimité le
refus de la polémique
et pourtant on a vu la polémique arrivé
tellement vite sur l'intervention
française au mali notamment avec la
france insoumise qui tout de suite a
remis en cause
cette intervention s'interroge sur le
tempo qu'on peut avoir aussi lorsqu'on
est dans ce moment ce moment de deuil ce
moment dommage vous l'avez dit tellement
vite moi je dirais même trop vite parce
qu'en effet je pense que le moment
actuel c'est le moment de recueillement
de communion de remerciement pour aux
saisons moi j'ai entendu en effet votre
collaborateur jean marie bockel l'iard
parler d'une manière très digne alors
qu'il a perdu son fils un jeune fils il
a dit des choses très très belle très
simple très digne j'ai trouvé que
c'était très digne par rapport à ces
soldats qui prennent ce rôle là et qui
vont jusqu'à la mort parfois pour les
fêtes en plus ministre
et qui donc il connaît très bien le
sujet alors c'est l'hommage il va y
avoir aussi l'hommage officiel avec les
mots d' emmanuel macron qui est toujours
très habile pour ça pour pour témoigner
de toute la france et de remercier après
il ya les interrogations et en effet je
pense que la france est soumise à
dégainer un peu rapidement pour
commencer à polémiquer ce n'était pas le
moment ça va venir le moment alors mois
sur des questions et de déférence envers
la science la présence militaire sans
manger aucun la sujet à dire si si si
elle n'est pas à remettre en question
après il ya des interrogations vous
l'avais dit je pense que sur l'europe en
tout comme pour le sahel est ce qu'on
peut y aller à plusieurs
même si on a une partie d'histoire très
forte avec ces pays là est ce que
l'europe et comment on peut construire
enfin cette défense où cette position
européenne alors que souvent on est
seuls les états membres on a du mal
quand même à agir ensemble et puis je
reviendrai sur ce que je disais c'est
aussi vous l'avez dit le développement
économique social humain est très
compliqué dans ces pays en guerre il
n'est pas impossible il ya des
collectivités même au sahel qui
s'organise et qui reviennent vis-à-vis
des collectivités françaises pour agir
ensemble en pas en dehors mais en tout
cas en parallèle de ce que le
gouvernement fait en matière de défense
il ya une loi qui est dans les cartons
un projet de loi sur la solidarité
internationale et la coopération
décentralisée alors cdc petit par
rapport à la défense et par rapport à
l'aspect militaire mais c'est aussi des
espoirs donnés aux populations sur place
de continuer à se développer
économiquement socialement de retrouver
des services de retrouver des emplois de
retrouver une activité
et j'ai l'impression que là on a
tendance à minimiser toujours cette
partie là ou alors c'est pas la priorité
parce que ce projet de loi il est
annoncé depuis un moment et on n'en voit
pas la couleur
tellement donc voilà j'ai l'impression
qu'il ya des choses à faire mais la
polémique s'est passé pas le moment
c'est pas le moment de la polémique a
encore christian cambon sur sur les
soutiens que nous avons en europe
c'est un problème qui est compliqué
c'est pas aussi simple que ça d'abord
parce que nous avons des régimes
constitutionnels qui sont très
différents c'est par exemple que les
forces militaires allemands dépendants
du bundestag
il n'y a pas une cartouche d'un fusil
allemand qui peut être tiré sans que le
parlement se réunisse vous imaginez bien
que nous on fonctionne pas du tout comme
ça parce que si on avait fonctionné
comme ça il ya belle lurette que le mag
que le mali serait devenu un califat
mais et je pense que la ministre de la
défense des armées a suggéré une bonne
idée il y à des pays qui ont des forces
spéciales pour intervenir sur ce genre
de terrain moi j étais comme mes
collègues un certain nombre de fois
c'est pas c'est pas un défilé avec des
galons et des kenji c'est un travail qui
est très difficile qui est très
particulier il faut est équipée de
manière spécifique
il faut connaître aussi le terrain
j'allais dire il ya il ya la mesure des
difficultés locales
ce ne sont pas des armes et nous ne
sommes pas opposés à des armées qui sont
face à nous nous sommes confrontés à des
gens qui parfois sont en tenue civile et
qui promène un chameau et puis qui
peuvent dégainer une kalachnikov et vous
descendre comme ça je vous laisse et
d'un vrai train mais je en revanche je
pense vraiment que trop d'états
européens n'ont pas vu que le danger
terroriste situé au sud moi je siège en
tant que parlementaire de l'otan et
j'entendais discours sur le danger que
représente la russie je veux pas le nier
mais il ya quand même un véritable
danger beaucoup plus grave on a payé
cher qui est celui du terrorisme en
afrique et le poids de l'afrique face à
l'europe mérite effectivement comme
vient de le dire très justement mes
collègues que on intervienne et que l'on
les aident à récupérer leur souveraineté
voilà pour cet avertissement de
christian cambon va passer un dernier
sujet qui a marqué cette séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement ce
sujet c'est le malaise des agriculteurs
et d'ailleurs on va rejoindre comme
wasquehal mais qui se trouve salle des
conférences avec didier guillaume le
ministre de l'agriculture
bonjour didier guillaume jours vous
allez recevoir les syndicats agricoles
dans quelques instants à votre ministère
on voit leur colère
dans les rues notamment sur le boulevard
périphérique qu'est ce que vous allez
leur dire pour les rassurer sur leurs
revenus à l'école comment est-ce que ça
peut s'améliorer pour il ya deux choses
là moi d'abord je soutiens leurs
revendications je chantais alors leur
manifestation je suis à leurs côtés je
suis leur ministre et je veux leur dire
que nous devons continuer à nous
bagarrer ensemble dans deux directions
pour lutter contre le dénigrement
permanent et pour faire en sorte que le
niveau économique remonte leur première
revendication c'est quand même ça ce
qu'on appelle la grille bashing il faut
arrêter 71 actes délictueux dans des
élevages depuis le début de l'année
trois élevages qui ont été mises à mal
et brûlé ce week-end des agriculteurs
qui sont sortir de leur tracteur se
faisant traiter de pollueur grimpent aux
honneurs tout cela ça suffit il faut
arrêter les agriculteurs ne sont pas des
empoisonneurs ou des pollueurs sont des
gens qui nous font manger et bien manger
il ya aussi la question des revenus
vivre de ce qu'ils produisent
qu est ce que vous le dirai la loi et
gally mail a fait flop deux ans après
mais pas du tout là le galli n'a pas
fait flop parce que la loi galim est en
train de se mettre se mettre en place
vous savez moi au sénat j'ai fait trois
lois agricoles la première loi agricole
elle aime à peine bono le maire s'était
il faut donner du revenu aux
agriculteurs la deuxième loi c'est la
loi le foll la loi d'avenir j'étais
rapporteur
il faut que les agriculteurs vivent de
leur travail la troisième loi la loi
travers et galim il faut inverser la
conscience du prix ça fait 15 ans qu'on
n'arrive pas à trouver la solution
là nous avons pris des mesures
exceptionnelles avec une expérimentation
de deux ans pour inverser l'action
sociale du prix ce sont désormais des
filières agricoles qui fixe le prix eux
mêmes jusqu alors les agriculteurs était
la seule profession qui ne fixait pas
leurs prix bon ben ya une
expérimentation qui est en cours nous
ferons un bilan à la fin de cette
expérimentation au 1er mars 2020 un
dernier mot sur est un gâchis dont vous
parliez vous doutiez vous disiez il faut
que ça cesse qu'est-ce que là aussi
votre ministère peut faire pour changer
les choses
nous travaillons beaucoup sur la
réconciliation vous savez il ya en fait
de france la france dévient de la france
des campagnes la france des métropoles
la france rurale et il faut qu'il ait la
réconciliation entre la société
d'agriculture la réconciliation entre
les citoyens et les agriculteurs
aujourd'hui l'agriculture française est
engagée dans la transition agro
écologiques
il n'y a jamais eu autant de conversion
au bio 10% et j'ai mis autant de haute
valeur environnementale
aujourd'hui l'agriculture mute mais
simplement ce que je veux dire très
sérieusement et très sincèrement la
vitesse de la transition agricole n'est
pas la vitesse des tweets et de là
société voilà et donc il faut laisser le
temps aux agriculteurs qui bougent
beaucoup nous avons décidé de réduire de
50% les l'utilisation des produits
phytosanitaires en 2025
nous y arrivons vous allez donc
rencontré les syndicats voulaient vous
allez demander de lever les blocages
ah non mais moi je vais pas leur
demander on va discuter on va on va
essayer d'avancer moi j'espère qu'ils
comprendront que le gouvernement est à
leurs côtés j'espère qu'ils comprendront
que nous sommes là pour les aider et
qu'au bout du compte après la
manifestation
et c'est une manifestion déclaré je veux
d'ailleurs dire très clairement pas une
exaction aucun problème aucune violence
c'est ça aussi la france rurale
merci beaucoup dit merci à vous gilbert
luc devinaz de votre ancien collègue
didier guillaume il est du côté des
manifestants des agriculteurs preuve
aussi que certainement la loi et galim
n'a pas porté ses fruits
écoutez son propos est surréaliste voilà
je dirais ça c'est vrai que c'est
beaucoup fréquenté dans des salles de
basket
le temps où il était président du
conseil général de la drôme et il manque
basket non sur sur ce point là puisqu'il
faut si j'ai bien compris faire vite
trois mois j'ai participé aux assises de
l'alimentation j'ai trouvé ça
intéressant j'ai trouvé qu'ils avaient
des propos de la part de représentants
de la grande distribution un peu
surréaliste par rapport à ce qu'il
pouvait faire la loi et gally moi je
veux bien mais il faut discuter avec le
monde agricole a priori alors je veux
bien admettre que c'est prématuré mais
n'a pas porté ses fruits en tous les cas
ceux pour qui elle doit porter les
fruits ne le perçoit comme ça deuxième
point sur le département du rhône langer
président est un grand parc qui était à
cheval sur l'urbain périurbain et rural
et là j'ai donnée noté l'incompréhension
qui avait entre les élus très urbain
parfois très écologique et les élus très
ruraux et périurbains et là il ya tout
un travail à faire pour faire comprendre
évoluent les choses notamment par
rapport à un certain nombre de produits
dont il faut arriver à ces paris le
dernier point c'est par rapport à ce qui
se passe à l'europe
on va vers un accord qui va rentrer en
europe 35 mille tonnes on va plus que
doubler le tonnes de boeuf qui deviendra
libre échange et ça à mon avis c'est
bien plus catastrophique pour le monde
agricole pour l'agriculture européenne
que tout ce qu'on vient de dire chrétien
cambon les traités de libre échange
c'est ça peut-être le plus grand danger
c'est ce que nous dit gilbert luc
devinaz parce que c'est votre avis là
aussi les choses sont ni blancs ni noirs
car on sait très bien dans des
départements où l'élevage est très
implanté et où il ya de véritables
difficultés pour ces éleveurs à voir
arriver des tonnages de viande en
provenance du canada est encore bien
pire si on avait le mercosur en
provenance d'amérique latine
néanmoins on entend rarement parler des
filières qui elle yayi énormément à la
mise en oeuvre du ceta dont je rappelle
qu'il fonctionne depuis deux ans on sait
très bien que la la la filière avicole
la filière des produits laitiers
la viticulture bénéficie au maximum de
ces de ces échanges
donc là je crois qu'il y a comme l'a dit
gilbert luc devinaz je crois qu'on est
dans un temps de changement de logiciel
est à la fois la volonté du consommateur
de manger mieux et de payer pas trop
cher non plus parce qu'il ya aussi dans
l'esprit de chaque consommateur que nous
sommes
il ya ces différences on n'est pas non
plus fatalement prêt à payer n'importe
quel prix et donc je pense qu'il ya une
vraie crise du monde agricole moi je ne
suis pas élu d'un département agricole
mais je vois l'excellence agricole dans
mon département puisque j'ai le mine de
rage mais c'est un potentiel formidable
d'exportation c'est un potentiel y
compris vers les pays d'afrique
on devrait expliquer à ces gens comment
utiliser leurs propres ressources
on ne le fait pas suffisamment donc je
pense que on est dans une situation qui
est compliqué il faut assurer le revenu
des agriculteurs
il faut effectivement changer de
logiciel de consommation car on est plus
prêt d'accepter toutes ces ces produits
qui ont été proches qui ont été et qui
font l'objet de traitements qui sont
très très bon pour la santé
donc c'est un problème compliqué mais
j'ai des experts beaucoup plus amusant
de voir que moi je m'améliore moi je
pense que le malaise agricole est très
profond et je pense que le ministre n'a
pas répondu à la question il dit les
comprendre moi j'ai perdu mon neveu
l'année dernière quel agriculteur que
nous avons retrouvé mort sur son
tracteur et qui vivait une situation
catastrophique
c'est quoi l'agriculteur d'aujourd'hui
c'est sont des agriculteurs qui doivent
investir toujours davantage pour faire
en sorte d'avoir plus d'hectares plus de
cheptel et pour un revenu qui n'est pas
à la hauteur et qui ne contribue peu
partour d'investissement sur
l'investissement qu'ils font il y à des
agriculteurs qui perdent leur maison il
ya des agriculteurs qui perdent
l'ensemble de leur patrimoine tout en
ayant travaillé sans compter leur temps
qu'ils n'ont pas pris de vacances qui
sont dans une situation extrêmement
complexe et ces gens là il faut les
aider il faut les soutenir et on nous
sommes très très loin du compte
moi j'ai pas attendu une seule fois l'
le ministre dans l'hémicycle prononcer
le mot grande distribution il a parlé du
dénigrement des agriculteurs et des
phénomènes de l'agressivité c'est vrai
qu'ils ont ce phénomène a mais c'est pas
la raison pour laquelle ils sont dans la
rue la raison est beaucoup plus profonde
allait lié à notre histoire de
l'agriculture vers l'agriculture c'est
nos racines
on doit faire en sorte que l'on puisse
yeux être fiers qu'ils puissent
continuer à aller dans le sens de nous
alimenter et qu'on ne se fasse qu'on ne
soit pas alimentés par des pays
étrangers qui n'ont pas la même les
mêmes valeurs
le même souci de la qualité donc je
crois qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes
vraiment un contour des chemins il faut
agir et je pense encore une fois que
nous sommes très loin du résultat est
que n'ont pas vu dans son panorama
n'oublions pas le nombre de suicides
n'oublions pas tout ces gens qui sont
dans la détresse et encore une fois il
faut agir il faut faire des choses en
allant au plus profond du problème et on
parle en grande distribution et du
dumping des prix des grandes
distributions parce que ils vivent très
bien et vivent très richement les mois
suivants absolument scandalisée par le
niveau de revenus de ses gérants de
grandes surfaces ou de sept personnes
qui ont aujourd'hui qui profite bien de
la situation il faut tenir effectivement
pour conclure un tout autre sujet on va
tout de suite rejoindre
quant à calmer un peu au jour dans la
salle des conférences du sénat et autres
avec nathalie delattre qui vient d'être
nommée présidente de la commission d'
enquête sur la lutte contre la
radicalisation
bonjour nati de l'être vous avez été élu
cette semaine président d'une nouvelle
commission denquête elle vise et bien à
lutter contre le rat lac la
radicalisation islamiste et notamment à
interroger le poids et le rôle des
autorités publiques
quels sont exactement la portée de ces
travaux quelle est la portée de ces
travaux alors c'est une commission
denquête donc elle durera pendant six
mois nous devrons
avoir remis notre rapport pour la mi mai
c'est d'étudier la façon dont s'est
propagée l'islamisme dans notre société
française et les moyens de combattre
cette probable propagation ce
développement c'est devenu un enjeu de
société
on le voit dès lors que on a une
problématique avec le port d'un voile en
sortie scolaire ça prend des proportions
qui sont aujourd'hui difficiles à
endiguer qu'est ce que vous pourriez
auditionné vous nous parliez des
hôpitaux des mères c'est vraiment ce que
tous les poulets oui en fait c'est cette
propagation dans le quotidien de notre
société bien sûr que nous aurons
une partie sur l'islamisme militant qui
conduit jusqu'à des actes de terroristes
puisque malheureusement nous avons été
touchés dans notre territoire et hier le
jour de la nomination nous apprenions
que nous avions été touchés à travers
les soldats français
mais nous souhaitons elle est plus loin
que ces actes terroristes et cette
interrogation sur ses actes de
terrorisme et bien au quotidien comment
effectivement cet islamisme a pu
s'infiltrer dans nos associations dans
nos communes au plus près de nos
territoires
mais est ce qu'on a vraiment besoin de
cette nouvelle commission denquête on a
eu beaucoup des rapports ici au sénat
même des les propositions de loi qu'est
ce que vos travaux peuvent apporter à la
réflexion je crois que l'un nous avons
eu surtout des rapports sur des éléments
plus macro
nous ce que l'on souhaite c'est vraiment
aller au plus près du terrain recueillir
les
éléments d'analysé mais aussi faire des
propositions ambitieuses et ne rien nous
interdit aujourd'hui comme propositions
en la matière merci beaucoup à la télé
on suivra bien sûr les travaux devant
deux commissions qui doivent commencer à
la ddt dès la semaine prochaine dès la
semaine prochaine
merci beaucoup quentin pour cette
nouvelle interview c'est la fin de ce
débrief des questions d'actualité du au
gouvernement au sénat
l'actualité parlementaire elle continue
sur public sénat tout de suite retour à
une audition qui s'est tenue hier à la
chambre haute dans le cadre des travaux
de la commission d' enquête sur lubrizol
et hier les sénateurs ont été
auditionnés lan cesse l'agencé nationale
de sécurité sanitaire autour tout de
suite à cette audition
mes chers collègues nous poursuivons nos
auditions de l'après midi on accueillant
monsieur jeunes et directeur général de
land c'est ce monsieur salva kiir jarre
adjoint et monsieur schuller qui est
directeur de l'évaluation des risques de
lanxess également je rappellerai comme
ça ça évitera monsieur jeunes et de le
faire et de manger le temps de parole
qui lui est imparti que l'on ne cesse a
été créée ne vous un droit de corriger
ou le compléter a été créée le 1er
juillet 2010 que c'est un établissement
public à caractère administratif qui est
placé sous la tutelle des ministères
chargés de la santé de l'agriculture de
l'environnement du travail et de la
consommation que l'on ne cesse à des
missions de veille d' expertise de
recherche et de référence à la fois dans
le domaine de la santé humaine que dans
le domaine du bien être animal et de la
santé végétale danse s évaluent les
risques et les bénéfices sanitaires et
l'ensemble des risques chimiques
biologiques et physiques auxquels chacun
peut être exposées notamment à travers
son alimentation et son activité
professionnelle
dès le 2 octobre landes 16 conjointement
avec eux l'ineris que nous avons
auditionné en début d'après midi a fait
l'objet d'une première saisine de la
part des trois ministères de tutelle
santé environnement et agriculture pour
caractériser les risques liés
un incendie d'origine du brise hall
cette saisine visait également à
produire des recommandations à
destination des pouvoirs publics sur le
sur les plans de surveillance à moyen et
long terme dont on a vu qu'il s'agissait
d'une caractéristique nouvelle par
rapport aux grands accidents industriels
du passé auquel un certain nombre
d'observateurs font référence on est
dans un dans un accident qui est
différent par rapport à ce qu'on a connu
précédemment puisque on se situe plutôt
dans une perspective de risque à moyen
et long terme
la vie que vous avez rendu relatif aux
évaluations de risques post accidentelle
liée à l'incendié était publié le 18
octobre
vous avez validé les expertises
réalisées par le groupe d'expertisé
collective d'urgence j'ai qu dont les
conclusions sont intéressantes et vous
dites notamment je vous cite le g q donc
le groupe d'expertisé collective
d'urgence recommande que des substances
additionnelles soient mesurés dans les
prélèvements sur la base d'une
connaissance fine des produits ayant
brûlé
fin de citation mais comme cela a été
indiqué à plusieurs reprises dans les
auditions si on connaît la nature des
produits entreposés chez lubrizol et et
normandie logistique
ce sont les substances issues des
mélanges de ces produits qui demeurent
inconnues et donc le fameux effet
cocktail dont nous entendons parler
depuis maintenant plusieurs semaines
donc nous aimerions savoir quand et
comment on peut imaginer avoir une
information précise et claire sur sur
ses effets cocktails nous aimerions
également mieux comprendre le sens de
votre recommandation qui consiste à
mettre en place
je cite à nouveau un plan adapté de ce
rayon se renforcer quand on déjoue par
là et en particulier qu'en est il des
produits alimentaires compte tenu de la
fin des restrictions qui concerne les
produits
agricoles ce qui n'a pas forcément suffi
à rassurer les consommateurs et au delà
la question que l'on se pose c'est de
savoir justement comment si ce n'est
assuré en tout cas informé de manière
optimale les citoyens comment faire en
sorte qu'il n'y ait pas de doute sur ce
que vous pouvez produire en termes d'
analyse des expertises de rapports
n'entendions ce matin des responsables
associatifs qui semblait si ce n'est
opposé en tout cas mettre en parallèle
les études citoyenne et puis les vôtres
ce qui nous a conduits à leur poser un
certain nombre de questions sur ce sujet
mais nous avons perçu le besoin à minima
qu'il soit plus associé à ses études à
la fois dans leur définition en amont
mais aussi dans leurs réalisations et
puis dans l'eure dans leurs
interprétations
et c'est vrai que vous produisez
toujours des études de grande qualité
parce que
vous êtes des scientifiques elles sont
souvent très très mesurée et donc
parfois on l'a dit d'ailleurs tous les
os et l'ineris parfois il y a un côté un
petit peu je peux dire opaque mais en
tout cas une difficulté à bien
appréhender la portée réelle de ces de
ses conclusions et je vois qu'il faut
que l'on soit en mesure collectivement
de faire un effort pour que ce que vous
produisez soit soit plus compréhensible
par tous et surtout ne soient pas sujets
à des des remises en question ou à des
oies des doutes
voilà ce que je voulais dire avant de
vous laisser la parole
je rappelle que vous êtes devant une
commission d' enquête parlementaire que
tout témoignage mensonger devant une
commission d'enquêté parlementaire est
puni de cinq ans d'emprisonnement et de
75000 euros d'amande et j'ai donc vous
demander ce directeur général monsieur
directeur général adjoint et monsieur le
directeur de l'évaluation de dire la
vérité toute la vérité de lever la main
droite et de dire je le jure merci donc
je vous laisse la parole pour 10 minutes
maximum
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames les rapporteurs mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs et sénatrices
vous connaissez bien l' agence on a eu
de nombreuses occasions de l'occasion
d'exposer en fait l'émission de lagence
donc je vais pas y revenir très
longuement sinon pour bien expliquer que
notre rôle très complémentaire 1 par
ailleurs de ce que fait santé publique
france en matière d'évaluation de
protection des populations c'est
d'évaluer les risques c'est d'évaluer
les risques dans des situations
d'incertitude et bien entendu dans des
cas de crises de nous mobiliser pour
apporter des recommandations pouvoirs
publics dans un délai court qui permet
d'appuyer et d'éclairer la décision
publique et puis d'appuyer la lah cette
prise de décision
alors comme vous l'avez dit monsieur le
président l'agencement déjà je dois dire
qu'après
l' incendie notre-dame systématiquement
on a une guide de gestion de crise qui
fait que dès qu'un événement majeur
survient on se mobilise et ont déclenché
en fait un plan de crise en interne qui
permet de regarder quel peut-être
d'autres contributions notre
contribution c'est pas une contribution
de terrain il ya des services de l'état
les dréal les directs des ars qui font
les contrôles de terrain et puis
coordonnées en fait par le préfet bien
entendu en cas de crise notre objectif
et nos missions c'est d'appuyer les
pouvoirs publics en évaluation du risque
on évaluera la situation risque aigu
risques chroniques risque aigu c'est
vraiment dans la première phase initiale
et puis de mobiliser nos réseaux et
notamment l' agence coordonne l'ensemble
des centres antipoison et de
toxicovigilance donc très vite dans les
jours qui ont suivi l incendie on a pu
faire remonter par le comité de
coordination des centres antipoison
l'ensemble des demandes qui avait été
adressée auprès des centres antipoison
pour mesurer finalement l'impact sur les
populations de ce qui avait été déclaré
d'ailleurs ça nous a permis de recenser
une cinquantaine de cas bénins qui
pouvait être associé en fait à 7
cet incendie est donc ça c'est pour eux
ce qui concerne les risques des risques
aiguë pour les risques chroniques qui
est vraiment le sujet qui nous intéresse
de près on va appuyer par une évaluation
les pouvoirs publics
et puis on va regarder si on a bien les
valeurs de référence sanitaire qui
permettent de s'assurer que les mesures
qui sont conduites qui sont fait
diligenter et coordonnée par les préfets
permettent de nous assurer qu'eux on est
en deçà en fait des risques sanitaires
sur le moyen et sur le long terme
donc on est dans cette temporalité comme
vous l'avez rappelé donc deux jours
après l incendie 1er octobre
enfin que quatre jours nous avons reçu
de saisine une saisine sur les produits
alimentaires et une saisine donc de la
dgr elle est une saisine des trois
ministres santé environnement et
l'agriculture sur à la fois les plantes
contrôle saisine conjointe en fait avec
dean & rice dans un premier temps
il s'agissait de définir si les produits
émis par le lincendie il y avait des
produits qu'ils n'avaient pas été prises
en compte dans les mesures qui avaient
été lancées en urgence par le préfet
donc nous avons rendu cet avis dès le 4
octobre nous a bien entendu sur la base
des données qui étaient fournies par
lubrizol par par l'ineris en fait et
puis donc ça nous a permis de relever
qu'un certain nombre de produits de
liées à la combustion nécessitait
néanmoins d'être suivie sur le moyen
long terme mais nous avons souligné
également que toutes les mesures qui
avaient été prises en urgence sur les
substances qui avait justifié des
contrôles étaient corrects enfin
correspondait à effectivement aux
substances qu'il était nécessaire de
suivre au regard de la connaissance que
nous avions des produits qui avait brûlé
bien entendu alors ensuite nous avions
des saisines sur les produits
alimentaires qui
[Musique]
mathieu lere en fait notre directeur de
l'évaluation des risques reviendra sur
ces évaluations puisque nous sommes en
train de préparer la sixième le sixième
rapport de saisine depuis le 1er
novembre donc notre groupe d'experts
collectif en urgence à travailler
quasiment depuis cette date sur
l'ensemble des saisines et c'est pas
fini puisque nous avons des saisines sur
le moyen et long terme donc d'une part
sur les plans de surveillance pour
proposer en fait aux pouvoirs publics
les plantes surveillance il est plus
adapté en fait à la situation et puis
également sur les produits la
contamination des produits alimentaires
alors évaluations de risque égal
disponibilité des données
nous ne pouvons pas rendre des avis sur
l'évaluation de la situation si nous
n'avons pas des données analytiques qui
nous sont fournies et donc pendant toute
cette période nous avons été
effectivement extrêmement dépendant des
analyses qui a été réalisé non seulement
parce que au niveau de temporel ces
analyses nécessitait des prélèvements
sur sur une séquence de temps qui à
partir de l' incendie jusque dans les
jours qui ont suivi
et puis également spatio-temporelle par
rapport au panache de diffusion il
fallait avoir des données qui permettait
d'avoir une représentativité
statistiques et tout ceci étant lié
aussi au modèle de dispersion et de
retomber en fait des suis pour les
différents milieux et pour les
différents produits alimentaires les
fourrages les herbages aussi bien que
les les produits de les produits
alimentaires qui étaient produits auchan
les végétaux les légumes etc
donc les données ont été commanditées
par la dréal sous l'égide du préfet donc
les données nous ont été transférés on
pourra revenir sur ce point particulier
d'ailleurs qui est à la fois à
l'harmonisation et la disponibilité des
données pour l'ensemble des services de
l'état et probablement les mesures
d'amélioration qui de notre point de vue
serait nécessaire pour harmoniser ces
données les rendre diront accessible
plus rapidement possible en terme
sachant qu'il ya beaucoup d'intervenants
qui ont produit des données aujourd'hui
dans ce dans le cadre de ces de ces
analyses
alors vous me posiez la question de
l'associé de fatigue des questions qui
que se pose en fait nos concitoyens dans
un cas comme celui-là de la façon de les
associer au mieux lagence a comme vous
le savez une longue expérience en fait
au travers de comités de dialogue sur
les saisines sur les évaluations sur les
avis qu'elle rend sur des sujets
sensibles qui concernent qui avait qui
concerne au premier rang en fait la
société civile
donc nous avons nous avons organisé des
comités dialogue sur ces sujets à la
fois les pesticides les radiofréquences
et nanomatériaux ou qui nous permet de
réunir très régulièrement l'ensemble des
parties prenantes à la fois
professionnelles associatives c'est sur
une protection de l'environnement et de
créer un dialogue permanent en aucun cas
un monde cherche à obtenir un consensus
sur les questions clés qui sont les
questions d expertise
l'objectif principal c'est de créer les
conditions d'un dialogue et de la crds
et des conditions de la confiance au
travers d'une transparence transparence
totale sur les méthodes d utiliser par
l' agence transparence sur les questions
posées et du père mais aussi de
recueillir les questions que se pose en
fait ses partenaires c'est ses parties
prenantes et de les prendre en compte
dans l' expertise donc c'est ce que nous
faisons habituellement bien entendu en
cas de crise la situation est un peu
différente
il faut qu'on trouve un moyen d'associer
en fait est de créer ce climat de
confiance avec les partenaires on l'a vu
dans le cas de cette crise en
particulier
je pense que on a des expériences sur
lesquels nous pourrons peut-être
débattre de science participative qui
doivent peut-être nous permettre de
mieux
tenir compte à la fois des attentes de
ses parties prenantes et des données qui
sont susceptibles de détenir et qui
peuvent mettre à disposition de l'
expertise
on a un certain nombre d'exemples par
exemple dans la lutte contre les tiques
on a mis en place en fait une une
une application qui permet en fait à
tous les citoyens de transférer des
données en fait à nos laboratoires de
l'inra et de l'homme cesse sur ses
deniers de contamination donc c'est des
exemples qui pourrait être transposé
dans d'autres domaines et qui pourrait
faciliter aussi l'obtention des données
dans des temps de gestion de crise en
tout cas c'est clair que l' agence
intervient dans sur des questions qui
dans des situations de forte incertitude
aujourd'hui on sait que les risques
aiguë les risques chroniques ont été
extrêmement faible
enfin l'impact en termes de risque aigu
a été faible ne serait-ce qu part je
dirais les le recueil en fait des cas
qu'on a pu recenser au niveau des prises
en charge hospitalière et dans les
centres antipoison les questions qui
restent posées
c'est une éventuel impact sur le moyen
et le long termes sur des risques
chroniques liées à l'exposition à ces
substances
bien entendu une agence comme la nôtre
ne dira jamais qu'il n'y a aucun risque
la question c'est la graduation du
niveau d'incertitude par rapport à ces
risques et par rapport aux substances
auxquelles on a été exposée donc on a
aujourd'hui des données qui continuent à
arriver à lagence des prélèvements de
sols qui sont arrivés encore récemment
on a un avis qui va être rendu
puisqu'on a déjà rendu un avis sur l'eau
destinée à la consommation humaine pour
la rs en fait normandie et on a eu
ensuite une saisine ultérieurement sur
les os en othe france destinée à la
consommation humaine donc les données
sont arrivés le 14 novembre donc c'est
une une saisine qu'on va rendre cette
semaine je pense on a également émis des
recommandations sur les plans de
contrôle sur le moyen et long terme le
renforcement des plans de contrôle
tout ceci dans l'unique perspective
d'avoir des jeux de données suffisamment
et avaient étayé pour que derrière nous
puissions estimer évaluer le risque
potentiel lié à l'exposition à ces
substances
et puis la saisine des trois ministres
nous conduira sur le début de l'année
2020 a finalement préparer une contre
expertise sur l'évaluation quantitative
des risques sanitaires qui est à la
charge de l'industriel de lubrizol qui
devra produire cette évaluation
quantitative des risques pour le début
de l'année 2020 et l'âge ans sera amenée
comme elle l'a fait dans d'autres
circonstances sur d'autres sites
industriels à contre expertise et cette
évaluation quantitative du risque donc
c'est tout un ensemble de travaux que
nous avons conduits que nous continuons
à conduire sur qui sont en appui en fait
aux pouvoirs publics sur la gestion de
cette crise vous nous avez indiquée
quand votre exposé que vous auriez un
certain nombre de propositions à
formuler
oui alors c'est plutôt la conclusion de
l'audition mais je pense que 1 des
besoins un des points qui ne partaient
pour la concevoir
c'est un des points je crois qu'ils qui
ne simplifie pas le travail des agences
d expertise c'est la disponibilité des
données et le format des données
on a forcément dans une cave un cas de
crise comme celui ci où on voit que les
services analytiques ont été saturés par
les demandes des pouvoirs publics des
différents acteurs qui vont fournir des
résultats des analyses aussi bien les
services de contrôle de la cl qui en
fait des pans de service commun des
laboratoires le fcl qui dépend de la
dgccrf et des douanes qui a été
sollicité par la dgccrf honda des
laboratoires départementaux qui ont été
sollicités par la dréal on a le
ministère de l'agriculture a sollicité
le lab errecart qui est en train
laboratoire de qui a fourni vraiment des
résultats de très haut niveau qui s'est
complètement mobilisé dès le début de la
crise et donc on a des sources de
données qui transitent soit par le
ministère de l'agriculture soit par les
dréal et au final qui arrivent à l'âge
ans avec des séquences temporelles en
fait qu'ils peuvent
ac est allé il est clair que si nous
disposions en fait au niveau de l'état
d'un système qui permet de centraliser
ces données d harmoniser et de les
mettre à disposition en fait de
l'ensemble des agences sanitaires on
gagnerait à temps précieux très bien je
la mets à part une bonne foi à porter
etc si moi je voulais vous interroger
sur le principe fondamental de reach le
reach qui donc est un règlement européen
et qui doit qui s'appliquent également
donc il s'applique à toutes les
substances chimiques et à savoir que la
charge de la preuve de l'innocuité des
produits et aux entreprises et donc j'ai
l'impression que ce principe ne
s'applique pas là le quasi néant puisque
j'ai l'impression que la preuve de
l'innocuité des produits est plutôt à la
charge des agences la vôtre et quelques
autres et pas des fabricants eux-mêmes
alors que c'est le principe de reach
donc je voudrais sur ce sujet en
particulier que vous me disiez est ce
que ce principe qu'encore une fois qui
est un principe de droit et qui est
entrée en vigueur depuis 2007 s'applique
où ne s'appliquent pas ou est ce que
l'état français lui est appliquée ou pas
alors bien mais c'est la triste être
fait
mon collègue m mais je suis à pourra
compléter mes reach me permet d'avoir un
classement harmonisée au niveau européen
d'une lot de dangers des substances qui
qui sont des produits chimiques qui sont
notamment mis sur le marché et ça permet
d'avoir une harmonisation sur je dirais
l'évaluation de la dangerosité
intrinsèque de ces substances ce que
l'on fait en matière d'évaluation c'est
qu'effectivement on va faire une
évaluation va on va regarder le risque
qui est liée à l'exposition à ces
substances donc le classement reach il
est pris en compte
ensuite sur l'évaluation de
l'installation par les services de
l'état et des risques associés soit en
termes d'entreposage soit en terme
d'utilisation
bien entendu le classement dedans j'ai
pris en compte et ensuite l'état
les services de l'état en fait rendre un
avis sur la sûreté en fait de ses
installations classées nous ce qu'on le
regarde c'est par rapport à l' incendie
c'est quels sont les produits qui sont
générés auquel on est exposé chacun de
ses produits pour autant qu'on les
connaisse un et pour autant qu'on est la
composition initiale
le terme source précis en fait des
produits qui ont brûlé
c'est à dire que on a bien la
composition des produits qui ont brûlé
en nature la question c'est quelles sont
les produits qui sont émis or la
modélisation qui permet qui doit tenir
compte à la fois de la température de l'
incendie à la fois du niveau de
dispersion qui permet de passer des
produits qui ont brûlé aux substances
émises et auquel on a été exposée ça
c'est une difficulté
donc c'est là où il faut parfaitement
connaître le terme source pour pouvoir
mesurer l'impact
par exemple prenons les dioxines sur
lequel on a beaucoup travaillé puisque
dans le lait le principal risque est lié
aux dioxines qui s'accumulent dans les
graisses il est clair que la quantité de
dioxine produite par l' incendie restent
aujourd'hui inconnue donc c'est
difficile ensuite mais forcément il ya
des dioxines qui ont été produites comme
des achats paix comme un ensemble de
produits qui ont été recherchées c'est
vrai qu'on en a trouvé peu en tout cas
dans le lait on a vu que c'est dioxine
ne dépassait pas la moyenne des
contaminations dioxine du lait produit
sur territoire français pour autant en
fait la question c'est quelle a été la
quantité produite et en fonction du
niveau dispersion des fumées et des
retombées ou c'est dioxine se retrouve
dans l'environnement c'est pour ça que
nous avons demandé d'avoir des contrôles
environnementaux des mesures sur le
terrain pour pouvoir avoir une
cartographie plus précise des retombées
mais il faut un moment donné qu'on
puisse faire une corrélation entre le
terme source
les quantités émises et en fait les
quantités retrouvées pour autant que les
systèmes de dispersion permettent de
corréler les deux voilà donc je dirais
le classement reach est pris en compte
ensuite nous ce qu'on regarde c'est
l'exposition aux produits qui finalement
amène au risque donc
alors alors pour le moment nous n'avons
pas fait d'évaluation de risques en tant
que tel parce que pour faire une
évaluation de risques il faut des
quantités de données dont nous ne
disposions pas et dont nous disposons
toujours pas c'est pour ça que on a
demandé des plans de surveillance et
avec des données des plans renforcer sur
le moyen et long terme pour pouvoir
une évaluation driss ne se fait jamais
en quinze jours on sa demande des mois
de travail
on peut voir parler d'expérience qui a
eu sur des feux des incendies par
exemple l'évoquera mais où en fait on a
besoin de plusieurs mois pour arriver à
recenser en fait l'ensemble des données
à faire une évaluation du risque
quantitative
donc là on n'a pas produit d'évaluation
de risques quantitative on a analysé les
données qui étaient fournis et ça c'est
un point le deuxième point sur les
effets cocktails je veux être
parfaitement clair parce que ce qui est
pris en compte dans les analyses de
risques c'est l'effet cumulé des
substances par rapport au niveau de
danger intrinsèque de chacune ce qui est
dans l'effet cocktail crains c'est des
effets synergiques de substances qui
ensemble ont un effet supérieur à la
simple addiktv t&d du niveau de danger
de chacune prises séparément
alors effectivement on trouve des effets
synergiques de substances comme on
trouve des effets antagonistes on trouve
par rapport à une fonction biologique on
va avoir des substances qui sentent
agonise dons qui sont finalement qui ça
ni l'une l'autre
on va aussi avoir des substances qui
ensemble ont un effet synergique et qui
ont un effet supérieur au simple effet
de substances cumulé on peut travailler
sur ses effets à l'échelle de deux trois
quatre cinq substances quand on a des
dizaines et des dizaines de substance
est impossible à prendre en compte un
effet du mélange aujourd'hui dans les
modèles donc il ya beaucoup de travaux
qui sont conduits au niveau
international pour arriver à mieux
prendre en compte avec des modèles
mathématiques en fait un effet de ces
substances
il faut pour ça avoir identifié les
effets de chacune
les effets sur chaque type de fonctions
biologiques et les effets synergiques ou
antagonistes pour les rentrer dans des
modèles
donc c'est pour ça que l'effet cocktail
dont on parle en tant que tel on l'
approche par la modélisation aujourd'hui
qui permettent de prendre en compte
l'effet addictif
deux substances de l'ensemble des
substances qui composent un mélange mais
c'est très difficile de aujourd'hui de
disposer des données qui permettrait de
montrer qu'il ya un effet synergique en
fait de substances auxquelles elles
peuvent ces effets peuvent exister comme
le contraire se souvient clément
non simplement en complément par rapport
à rich effectivement le ce que ce casque
apporte quelque part le travail la
réglementation reach qui donc est un
enregistrement des substances du fait du
fait des acteurs économiques et des
industriels
c'est encore une fois rond oui c'est ça
non mais c'est que eux ils ont ils vont
avoir construit les dossiers ils vont
avoir 10 ou définis tels et tels types
de tel niveau de danger dans ces
substances
effectivement nous en tant qu'agent
agence nationale en lien avec les cas
donc l' agence européenne des produits
chimiques
on va on va passer une partie de notre
activité au long cours indépendamment de
lubrizol sur le le fait de contre
expertise et ce qui a été fait mais ça
ne couvre pas 100% des substances reach
ou le mécanisme d'enregistrement fait
que l'action publique elle vérifie à un
certain pourcentage c'est entre une
dizaine de pourcents des dossiers
évidemment on recherche les plus les
plus critiques à notre sens et ça s'est
lassé de ces mécanismes de reach ensuite
dans le cadre de lubrizol on a
finalement le débat n'est pas de savoir
est ce que il ya débat entre grisolles
où l'action publique sur le niveau de
danger que représente une dioxine ou un
achat paix la question c'est quel est le
niveau d'exposition qui a été générée
par cette situation particulière qu'est
un incendie avec une partie des produits
qui ont été qu'ils ont été
je dirais dispersé dans l'atmosphère et
donc c'est pour ça qu'on a effectivement
ces dispositifs alors qui par ailleurs
sont issus de la manière dont la don le
don la préfecture a géré le le post
accident pourrait effectivement avoir
une image il ya d'une part ce que fait
la modélisation ça c'est le travail qu'a
fait des mairies sur le panache d'après
les meilleurs codes de calcul verrous
par tilda qu'elle avec quel niveau
d'intensité ce dépôt style et donc
ensuite en fonction le cas quels sont
les quelles sont les retombées que le
qui ont pu être mesurés concrètement et
c'est ça qui va prendre plus
ultérieurement la manière d'apprécier
d'évaluer les risques
merci madame confronté de ça messieurs
merci vous avez émis donc des
recommandations sur un plan de
surveillance de moyenne et de long terme
et vous dites que l'impact va se juger
sur les risques chroniques avec la
nécessité d'une cartographie très
précise des retombées et vous avez
d'ailleurs évoqué et envisagé pour cela
la désignation d'un service unique
capable de centraliser l'ensemble de ces
données de les harmoniser
vous parliez tout à l'heure de de
transparence et de confiance se retrouve
effectivement ça me paraît un outil
important
je voudrais savoir ce qu'il allait
aujourd'hui de ce que vous avez demandé
et puis je voudrais savoir pourquoi
risques deviennent chroniques qu'il faut
combien de temps ce que là on est à deux
mois donc j'aimerais que vous
m'expliquer un peu ça et puis vous
parliez tout à l'heure de l'eau moi
j'avais une question effectivement à
vous poser sur la surveillance de l'eau
qui est destiné à la consommation
quotidienne
alors on a vu et cela ne vous a pas
aidés des réseaux sociaux passés en
boucle ainsi que des chaînes de grande
écoute
un robinet qui s'ouvrait avec de l'eau
total manoir en disant voilà s'est
défait du brésil etc
ça a dû effectivement
un peu pour rire un peu tout ce que vous
avez toutes les études que vous avez
fait aujourd'hui qu en est il et quels
sont les moyens que vous avez à votre
disposition pour vraiment assurer la
confiance des personnes qui au vu de ces
de ces documents se disent c'est pas
possible on va nous sommes foisonner et
dans ce peut-être pas boire aujourd'hui
l'eau de ce robinet que vous avez
pourtant nommé comme et en consommables
alors même la rapporteure il est clair
que la responsabilité première vis-à-vis
des consommateurs de loups qui est
consommé comme des produits alimentaires
c'est les services de l'état la rs la
dréal qui a la responsabilité
d'autoriser la consommation s'est
produit ces pâles en 16 langues cesse
intervient comme expert scientifique et
en appui aux pouvoirs publics donc on va
mener en fait sur la base des encore une
fois sur la base des données disponibles
cirque il faut qu'on ait des jeux de
données des jeux d'analystes suffisant
pour pouvoir avoir des avis qui sont
circonstancié suffisamment solide
statistiquement c'est toute la question
d'ailleurs j'ai entendu en fait une
impatience sur un certain nombre de
libérations de l'autre produit qui s'est
exprimée vis-à-vis de l'inde c'est ce
qui est lié à une méconnaissance
simplement du rôle de l'agent ce parce
que prenons par exemple le lait le être
précis sur les dates mais nous avons
vendu notre avis sur les risques
potentiels liés au lait le 14 novembre
le 14 octobre le le comité transparence
avait été installé le vendredi 11 et la
saisine nous demandons en fait de
préciser les risques potentiels dérouler
sa date du vendredi jour du comité
d'installation du comité du du comité
transparence simplement parce que les
saisines que nous avions reçu le 1er
octobre ne nous demandez pas de
d'appuyer les pouvoirs publics sur les
levées des mesures de restriction ce qui
est une décision du gestionnaire de
risques et on a dans notre pays
une séparation claire entre l'évaluateur
de risque et le gestionnaire du risque
nous en tant qu évaluateurs de risques
on peut dire c'est qu'elle est
l'aggravation du risque lié à ces
produits à partir de l'analyse fin des
analyses dont on dispose donc le jeudi
10 octobre nous avions 90 prélèvements
de lait sur une séquence de sept jours
sur l'ensemble du territoire et nous en
avons eu le vendredi 130 vous voyez que
la représentation statistiques sur sept
jours sur le nombre d'exploitations 380
et est quand même faible et qu'il nous
fallait a suffisamment quand même
d'informations pour pouvoir dire que la
de la représentativité des mesures que
nous avions étaient suffisantes pour
pouvoir rendre un avis effectivement
aucune de ces mesures
pour le lait ne dépassant en fait ni les
normes sanitaires loin de là ni même la
moyenne des prélèvements qui sont faits
au niveau national en terme de
contamination du lait s'agissant des
dioxines a permis de dire que si en tout
cas à par rapport aux analyses que nous
avions qu'on avait un degré en fait de
certitudes suffisant et les pouvoirs
publics ont pris la décision de lever
les mesures de restriction sur la base
cet avis pour autant vous avez vu en
fait les cartographies qui ont été
faites un peu en léopard sur les
retombées un certain nombre de troupeaux
sont restés au chant donc on a besoin
d'avoir des mesures sur la durée précise
sur les ailes les contaminations
potentiel lié aux retombées à cause de
fourrage contaminés ou à cause des
ravages contaminés et pour ça on a
besoin d'avoir des cartographie précise
des zones de retombées d'avoir des
mesures environnementales sur les
contaminations et d'avoir des plans de
suivi sur la durée qui nous permettent
de confirmer qu'effectivement il n'y a
pas de problème spécifique
voilà donc c'est ce pourquoi une analyse
de dioxine ça prend quatre jours donc il
fallait un délai suffisant pour qu'on
ait du recul sur ces analyses pour
pouvoir dire simplement si
donner aux pouvoirs publics du recul là
dessus alors on l'a fait aussi sur les
produits alimentaires sur les végétaux
quelques jours plus tard on l'a fait sur
l'eau de boisson
en tout état de cause c'est vraiment là
la confiance qu'on peut faire d'une part
elle est liée à la qualité du plan
statistique du plan de prélèvement et de
l'analyse qu'en fait ces résultats elle
nie aussi à la méthodologie
j'ai entendu effectivement un certain
nombre d'associations demandé la
désignation d'experts
je pense qu'il faut vraiment qu'on
travaille en proximité avec les
organisations les associations mais la
différence avec ce qu'on a eu à ce que
ce que le gouvernement ce que pouvoirs
publics en france ont mis en oeuvre avec
les agences sanitaires
c'est justement l'organisation d'une
expertise publique collective et
contradictoires la différence dans la
composition de l'expertisé expertise que
rend lagence avec des experts individuel
intuiti personae c'est que nous avons au
sein de nos collectif d'experts des
spécialistes de différentes disciplines
qui ont un point de vue qui permet de
toucher en fait une question avec
différents angles et d'apporter au
travers d'une expertise contradictoire
des visions pour construire en fait un
avis qui soit suffisamment étayée nous
avions huit spécialistes en fait dans ce
groupe d'experts collectif en urgence
qui a travaillé tous les jours en fait
pendant cette période pour à la fois des
vétérinaires à la fois des agronomes des
chimistes des toxicologues pour pouvoir
apporter une vision complément
collective créée entre les officiels et
les citoyens et travailler en bonne
intelligence ensemble pour qu'il n'y ait
pas de suspicion et que justement on
retrouve la confiance auprès d'eux des
concitoyens sellers en tout cas alors
bon la difficulté on l'a vu
depuis que va tenter dé les agents
sanitaires existants c'est d'arriver à
avoir un cadre à la fois des autos
logique et d'autres termes de prévention
des conflits d'intérêt avec une
expertise indépendante et c'est très
difficile à mobiliser sa en 48 heures si
le cadre n'est pas déjà défini nos
groupes collectif d'experts sont formés
sur appel à candidatures donc on fait
des appels à candidatures on sélectionne
bien sûr leurs compétences scientifiques
et ensuite les îles
il commence déclare au travers de
déclarations publiques d'intérêts sur le
site du ministère de la santé l'ensemble
de leurs liens d'intérêts et on screen
en fait l'ensemble des liens qui peuvent
avoir pour écarter tous les experts qui
peuvent avoir un lien majeur et prévenir
ainsi tout conflit d'intérêts donc c'est
mécanique qu'on a mis en place qui
permet d'avoir une commune une expertise
indépendante c'est difficile de la
mobiliser ses cadres n'existe pas le
jour de la crise par contre ça n'empêche
absolument pas et c'est ce qu'ont fait
régulièrement d'auditionner des
scientifiques ou des collectifs j'espère
dans le cadre ses comités d'experts on
le fait très régulièrement ce qui permet
d'avoir des échanges avec des
scientifiques pour autant la
délibération se fait uniquement au sein
du du collectif d'experts donc il y a
des moyens
je veux dire pour travailler ensemble
mais c'est vrai que là pour une gestion
de crise comme celle-ci je pense que
l'association des parties prenantes
elle relève plus de l'échelon local au
final que de l'échelon national comme
l'inde 16 puisque finalement on est dans
une perspective temporelle qui est un
peu décalé par rapport à la gestion de
crise vous voyez bien que m certaines
barrières entre les annonces
à vouloir mettre ou à mettre des
barrières sans le vouloir
entre les citoyens et les agences il ya
cette espèce de fossés qui se creusent
et qui conduit à cette situation qui est
de mon point de vue pas pas saine de
dire voilà il ya les expertises
indépendantes et expertise citoyenne
d'un côté et puis de l'autre des
expertises officiel et c'est vrai que je
crois qu'il faut arriver à hama mettre
un terme à cela
en plus c'est ce que je voulais exprimer
toute heure c'est quand même très très
compliqué pour les citoyens de s'y
retrouver dans la multitude de
l'information fournie quasiment tous les
jours voire plusieurs fois par jour sur
sur le site celle-ci de la préfecture le
site donne hélas je sais plus où il ya
la préfecture où il ya vos analyses
celle de la rs celle de l'ineris mme est
donc une espèce de de trop plein
d'informations qui en plus comme je le
disais n'est pas forcément
compréhensible et accessible pour pour
chacun et je crois qu'il faut trouver
des solutions pour arriver à ce que les
choses soient soient plus claires plus
fluide et plus plus plus audible quoi ai
je bien consciente pour un scientifique
c c'est toujours une difficulté de
rendre son son propos parfaitement
compréhensible de tous et et que la
prudence en plus vous conduit à avoir
souvent des propos et a fortiori des
écrits extrêmement mesure et permettez
peut répondre sur ce point bon alors
d'abord au partage complètement et c'est
vrai que si vous voulez sur beaucoup de
questions qui sont très sensibles
aujourd'hui l'âge ans a construit ses
comités de dialogue en associant toutes
les parties prenantes et des
scientifiques qui ceux qui viennent de
l'organisation de la société
la question de l'organisation de ce
débat
en temps de crise où nos équipes étaient
mobilisés 24 heures sur 24 pour répondre
dans l'urgence en appui aux politiques
publiques organisées à côté le dialogue
est complexe pour nous enfin en tant en
termes de réaction ou on nous demande
d'avoir une très grande réactivité en
fait pour pouvoir s'organiser et
répondre
sur le temps de la crise je pense
néanmoins que parlait là les initiatives
de sciences citoyennes
il faudrait que l'on puisse organiser
près organiser un lieu d'échangé où d'un
outil des changes qui permettent de
tenir compte en fait des propositions
qui peuvent remonter de la société ou de
deux scientifiques qui veulent produire
des données en fait justement en temps
de crise cc c'est une question qui est à
la fois qui touche à la fin je pense
qu'il faut séparer les questions de
communication
effectivement et les questions
d'associations al'expertise par des
modalités particulières qui sont à
définir pour tenir compte de l'art de la
contribution effective que les citoyens
peuvent avoir et qui peut être
extrêmement utile on le voit les
errances de science participative sont
de plus en plus développée et très
productive
la question c'est d'arriver à organiser
ça en temps de crise qui rend la chose
très compliqué sur la communication
lagence habituellement ne communique pas
sur les avis qu'elle rend en appui aux
mots aux pouvoirs publics en cas de
crise tombe sur les crises sanitaires
grippe aviaire peste porcine africaine
on rend nos avis qu'ils sur notre site
internet public mais on ne communique
pas mon laisse des ministères en fait
communiquer puisque c'est eux qui gèrent
la crise là en l'occurrence continu du
contenu du format particulier de cette
crise de l'eau du souhait du
gouvernement d'une transparence totale
notamment et de l'installation du comité
nous avons fait un point d'actualité à
l' usage des médias et du grand public
sur chacun de nos avis pour expliciter
nos avis et nous avons rendu public nos
avis en communiquant sur le rôle de
l'ansès pour essayer justement
d'apporter une clarification sur le rôle
de chacun
monsieur ça va vous fêtiez intervenir
pour illustrer un peu en quoi
en quoi la communication avec les
citoyens pourraient nous être utile dans
la façon d'aborder l'évaluation de
risques
en fait les citoyens vont pas nous faire
remonter des résultats des analyses si
on fait une analyse de dioxine comme l'a
très bien expliqué roger il faut quatre
jours pour le faire faut des chaînes des
analyses complexes qui coûte très cher
ya pas enfin on n'a pas les moyens de
déployer des systèmes analytiques simple
vers les citoyens pour sa part contre
savoir où est ce qu'il faut aller faire
les prélèvements ou est ce qu'il ya eu
des retombées de suie ce qui est ce qui
est un vrai problème dans ce type de
crise on a un incendie trois jours après
l incendie
on a des gros orages sur toute cette
zone donc des pluies localisées qui vont
faire retomber dès suis en taches de
léopard comme on l'a dit on peut pas
envoyer la gendarmerie partout pour
mesurer où sont ses tâches de léopard
par contre la personne qui voit des
tâches de suis au fond de son jardin
peut très bien le signaler le signaler
par une application
il faudrait qu'on ait un squelette
d'application qu'ils soient déployables
en temps de crise ça veut dire en gros
il faut une application qui géolocalise
l'endroit où effet signalement le type
de signalement conseil ne tient qu'à
vous de le faire non je parle ne tient
qu'à vous de le faire alors il ne tient
qu'à nous de le faire un homme s'est
fait un proche c'est non mais on l'a dit
j'en fais on a urgé cité tout à l'heure
on l'a fait avec l'inra sur sur l'ailé
le signalement des piqûres de tiques
vous avez une application que j'ai sur
mon smartphone que vous êtes piqué par
une tique vous fait un signalement vous
êtes si vous souhaitez géolocalisés donc
on a su comme ça que les gens étaient
autant piqué dans les jardins que dans
les forêts vous pouvez envoyer la tique
qui vous a piqué en enlevant bien avec
un terreau tic dans une enveloppe à un
laboratoire qui va faire une analyse de
tous les pathogènes qui a dans cette
optique ce qui va nous nous permettre
d'avoir des données mais dans le cas
d'une crise comme ça aiguë si on avait
ce type d'application à déployer
effectivement il faut qu'on développe
les technologies simplement nous on peut
développer des choses après il faut
qu'ils effacés nous on ne peut pas le
déployer
on a pas on n'a pas la force de frappe
d'un service de l'état pour le déployer
évidemment par contre ça nous
permettrait d'avoir des informations sur
là où il faut aller faire les
prélèvements sur les sols par exemple
parce qu'on parlait de chronicité dans
la question de madame bonfanti dossat la
question sur les dioxines c'est que la
demi vie des dioxines sur un organisme
qui les a absorbé dans les grès elle est
de 7 ans donc une vache qui absorbent
des dioxines on a une demi vie des
molécules qui allait absorber qui est de
7 ans lala le passage dans le lait le
pic de passage dans le la et quinze
jours après l'exposition à peu près ça
mathieu donc on a forcément on peut
faire des ont peut donner des premières
données après sept jours comme on l'a
fait parce qu'on voit à peu près comment
montre la courbe dans le lait et on sait
que si elle monte pas elle va pas monter
tout d'un coup ça monte de façon assez
c'est assez linéaire après l'exposition
par le sol savoir pour ça qu'on demande
des analyses de sol aussi elle est sur
le long terme parce que les vaches elles
broutent de l'herbe mais elle mange du
sol aussi les poules en liberté elle
elle picore et donc elle picore du sol
donc on a besoin de savoir où les sols
sont contaminés pour voir où les animaux
sont exposés pour voir où on va faire
les analyses pour voir à long terme
l'exposition de la population avec des
produits il est pas question de
condamner et tous les produits delà de
cette grande région qui a été sous le
panache
ça n'aurait pas de sens par contre s'il
ya des zones plus à risque il faut qu'on
le sache et c'est pour ça qu'on souhaite
rendre des avis sur la surveillance à
long terme points la difficulté en fait
dans l' incendie qu'on a eues à gérer
c'est qu'il a été
il n'a pas été possible de 10 de mettre
en évidence de substances traceur qui
permettait d'identifier que les
contaminations mesurer provenaient bien
de cet incendie
c'est que 1,1 point très important c'est
de voir quelle est la surcontamination
la sueur pollution qui est liée
directement à l' incendie or il faut
pour cela disposer du bruit de fond
c'est à dire de la situation pré
accidentelle ou bien de traceurs
spécifique de l'incident qui permettent
de voir que ce que l'on mesure est bien
lié à l'instant
or sur ces deux points aujourd'hui nous
manquons de données c'est à dire que
nous avons des données statistiques au
niveau du territoire national mais nous
n'avons pas de lait précise sur la
contamination près accidentelle et donc
des difficultés à mesurer quelle est la
la surexposition liées à l'incendié
lui-même
voilà donc c'est toutes ces données là
qui sont nécessaires pour vraiment voir
le niveau d'impact de l'incendié
lui-même
quant à la proposition que douteuse à
faire avant fait on l'apportera de
développer ce type d'outil simplement la
gestion de crise n'est pas dans nos
missions cercle le gestionnaire de crise
c'est l'état ce sont des services de
l'état dont on peut développer le
produit et faire des propositions mais
il ne nous appartient évidemment pas de
décider de son utilisation
si je devais résumer en termes simples
ce votre propos on peut considérer
qu'aujourd'hui à votre connaissance n'y
a pas de problèmes notamment sur les
produits qui sont commercialisés mais
que vous n'excluez pas qu'il y en ait et
que ce sont les études ou les analyses
ou les prélèvements qui qui sont en
cours qui seront effectuées dans les
prochains mois qui permettront de de
dire si effectivement il y assure
certains sur certains produits ou sur
certains certes certains éléments du
vivant au du végétal d'été des risques
ou des dangers
mathieu schiller bas intervenir sur les
aspects risques chroniques risque aigu
mais ce qu'on peut dire aujourd'hui
c'est qu'à partir des données dont nous
disposons on n'a pas mirent en évidence
effectivement de sur risque qui
potentiellement font courir un risque
immédiat la population mais pour autant
il faut qu'on ait donné plus précise des
cartographies plus précises pour mesurer
véritablement un impact potentiel et
être sûrs et certains en fait que
tout risque sur la durée peut être
écartée peut-être qu'en complément
monsieur le président quelques quelques
éléments c'est à dire qu'en fait les la
surveillance des denrées alimentaires de
l'eau elles existent indépendamment de
l'accident effectivement avant avant
l'incendié de lubrizol
il y avait un dispositif de surveillance
normal que ce soit dans l'eau destinée à
la consommation humaine dans ses
aliments dans l'immédiat de phase post
accident il ya une densification très
importante de ces contrôles et
effectivement ce qu'on appelle parfois
première phase dans nos avis mais qui
étaient les termes de les acteurs de la
gestion post accidentelle et 7 ces
résultats que nous avons analysés en
première intention
d'abord les services de l'état ont fait
leur part ils ont constaté l'absence de
points qui dépassaient les normes
réglementaires et ensuite nous on a
analysé en deuxième rideau en deuxième
phase si au delà du fait que tous ces
mesures étaient conformes
elle était porteuse d'une d'un indice ou
de traces d'une dune surcontamination et
si oui laquelle
en fait les avis qu'on produit sur la
surveillance moyen ou long terme
c'est effectivement est ce qu'à un
moment donné le filet de surveillance
détendant après la phase
post-accidentelle il est à même
d'identifier un mécanisme par lequel les
contaminants se retrouveraient où se
concentrerait à travers l'environnement
soit vers l'eau soit vers les aliments
et c'est exactement ce que dans cette
logique là que se situe et par exemple
notre avis du 16 octobre sur le
consommation humaine
on est passé dans la phase avant
accident d'un contrôle suivant laich qui
règle et la production des centres de
traitement d'eau de 2
hebdomadaire a plutôt plutôt un mois ou
tous les deux mois suivant la nature des
contrôles à quelque chose de beaucoup
plus dense et ce que nous avons
recommandé après avoir fait une analyse
finalement avec des hydrogéologues de la
configuration du bassin seine normandie
dans quels étaient les risques on a on a
un bassin karstique on a pas de risque
de deux passages delà du lit de la scène
vers l'est vers le vernon de
consommation vers les nappes mais par
contre on peut avoir des progressions
rapides dans les cartes
d'où un certain nombre de préconisations
très précises pour dire mettez des
captages sentinelle que vous
surveillerez toutes les semaines et a
contrario sur les autres il est possible
de passer à une surveillance mensuelle
donc c'est un petit peu ça mais c'est un
mécanisme avec une surveillance qui ceux
qui essaient d'avoir des des signes
avant coureurs s'il devait y en avoir et
ensuite avant de repasser à un
dispositif plus plus normal et 7 c'est
exactement la même logique qu'il y a
dans l'eau et qui a également dans les
aliments une petite différence entre les
deux c'est que en alimentation il peut y
avoir soit parlée par les sols soit par
part parlé par les animaux des
phénomènes d'accumulation et là encore
c'est ce qui nous a c'est ce qui guide
les préconisations que nous faisons aux
pouvoirs publics pour éviter d'avoir une
contamination qui s'accumulent
contamination chronique c'est ça et
finalement quand on a dans notre premier
avis du 4 octobre formulé un certain
nombre de préconisations ou examiner les
produits qui ont été recherchées en
première intention par là les ddpp donc
la demande du ministère de l'agriculture
c'était non seulement ceux qui étaient
susceptibles d'être émis par l' incendie
ça c'est notamment nos collègues de
l'ineris qui ont qui on avait sept cette
compétence de cette connaissance des
mécanismes d'un 110 mais nous on a été
regardée dans nos bases de données et
notamment les expositions usuels par la
boîte par la consommation je dirais de
tout un chacun de nos concitoyens à ceux
qui étaient éventuellement pour
des limites chronique on sait que les
expositions au plomb au cadmium par
exemple sont des contaminants qui
indépendamment de tout incendies peuvent
être assez proche des limites d'où les
préconisations de dire ça ce sont des
substances à surveiller plus
particulièrement
mais c'est ça qui est ça la philosophie
derrière c'est finalement que est ce que
les résultats de contrôles nous
interpelle ou interpelle nos experts
pour dire c'est vers là qu'il faut
porter l'attention et je voudrais
terminer sur 7 sur cette notion de
partage
finalement des données et des résultats
d'analysés parce que je pense que c'est
là qu'il peut y avoir un mécanisme nous
résignons tout de robustesse y compris
impliquant et impliquant les les
citoyens c'est à dire que finalement de
la même manière que nous agence d'
expertise nationale on est on a été sur
ses plans de contrôle aussi bien aux
qu'alimentation en back up bar dont hull
terme anglo saxon en deuxième niveau d'
analyse par rapport à ce qu'ont fait les
acteurs publics territoriaux
ben moi je trouverai pas illogique ou
pas illégitime que finalement ces
résultats soient partagées encore plus
largement et plus rapidement de manière
à ce que des citoyens les regardent en
se posant des questions puisque nous
dire attendez là on a quelque chose qui
nous qui nous interpellent et qui
éventuellement on rentre un dialogue
autour de ça est ce qui a motivé ce qui
serait peut-être ce qui pourrait avoir
du sens encore une fois par rapport au
rôle qu'on a chacun
est-ce que compte tenu des incertitudes
qui existe encore aujourd'hui ça n'a pas
été un petit peu prématuré de lever
aussi rapidement toutes les restrictions
sur les produits agricoles et
alimentaires
alors bien entendu en fait la question
elle est pour la poser au ministre
l'agriculture c'est à dire que d'une
certaine façon nous ce qu'on peut dire
c'est dans le avec le délai et le nombre
d' analyse c'est pour ça que nos avis
sont très précis sur ce qu'on a pris en
considération pour donner un avis global
dix jours douze jours après l incendie
donc c'était comme on l'a dit le pic
d'accumulation dans le lait de dioxine
ces quinze jours donc au bout de 12
jours on peut être certain que s'il y
avait une exposition en fait aux
dioxines pendant les premiers jours on
verrait une augmentation dans le lait
donc c'était suffisant pour pouvoir
montrer qu'effectivement pendant cette
première phase il n'y avait pas de
risque d'accumulation dans l'est bien
entendu ça repose sur un nombre
d'analystes qui est quand même restreint
et donc avec des données statistiques
évidemment on n'a pas des données à
l'exploitation et donc on a une vision
statistiques je pense qu'ensuite
évidemment il ya une analyse d'une
analyse bénéfices/risques qui qui
intervient qui est celle du gestionnaire
de risque sur finalement s'il y avait eu
des signaux qui pouvait laisser entendre
qu'une contamination par dioxine pouvait
être détectées je pense que la mesure
la décision du ministre aurait pu être
tout autre
là alors les dix les données dont on
avait sur une séquence de temps encore
une fois je le dis parce que c'était
légitime que notamment les producteurs
de lait attendent avec impatience notre
décision mais les résultats qui ont été
collectés couvraient une période quand
même relativement courte et à par
rapport à ces analyses on a mis 48
heures pour rendre notre évaluation
on ne pouvait pas la rendre avant parce
qu'il n'y avait pas assez de données et
à ce moment là
je pense qu'on avait j'aurai une vision
statistiques des échantillons suffisante
pour pouvoir prendre la décision
d'autant qu' aucun échantillon ne
montrait une augmentation du taux de
dioxine par rapport à l'ensemble des
collectes de lait au niveau national
donc je pense que la décision en tout
cas j'ai pas donné d'avis sur les autres
2010 mais elle apparaît légitime d'un
point de vue scientifique
dernière question à quelle échéance
selon vous on pourra avoir une vision
claire et stabiliser des risques à moyen
long terme des risques chroniques je
vais insister sur le fait qu'aujourd'hui
on n'a pas de substance dont on demande
le suivi qui soit différent des
polluants que auquel on doit faire face
dans la pollution classique dans les
sites industriels
donc on a un suivi de la population
renforcer pour tenir compte alors la
meilleure cartographie passible dans le
panache mais qui est finalement renforcé
par rapport à la surveillance de la
population que l'on fait classiquement
nous n'avons pas de mesures qui indique
une surexposition donc et bien entendu
une agence comme la nôtre ne dira jamais
qu'il n'y a pas de risque on est quand
même dans une exposition et des produits
polluants qu'il faut surveiller de près
l'objectif des plans de contrôle c'est
de s'assurer effectivement qu'on est à
un niveau d'exposition qui ne dépasse
pas les salades les deux les seuils
d'exposition que nous avons
classiquement au niveau là au niveau de
la région
pourtant je le rappelle on est face à
des polluants les dioxines et à chapet
les métaux lourds auxquels on est exposé
par la pollution et donc nous on a une
vigilance constante en fait sur
l'exposition de la population c'est par
rapport à cette vigilance que l'on
demande une surveillance renforcée du
fait de
cette de l'intérieur de la survenue de
cet incident il n'y a pas de signal
aujourd'hui qui nous laisse à entendre
qu'il pourrait y avoir un risque une
augmentation du risque par rapport à ces
biens sabots une augmentation du risque
par rapport aux risques classiques
auxquels en fait nos concitoyens sont
soumis compte tenu de décontamination
environnementale
qui qui sont qui existe aujourd'hui
donc encore une fois on a pas de signal
d élévation du risque mais on souhaite
compte tenu de la nature de l'incident
une surveillance renforcée sur la durée
pour pouvoir nous assurer qu'eux on
n'aura pas ultérieurement de signalement
d'une survenue d'un risque particulier
voilà pour cette édition de l'inceste l'
agence nationale de sécurité sanitaire
qui s'est donc exprimé hier devant les
sénateurs de la commission d' enquête
sur lubrizol après l incendie qui a pris
place à rouen au mois de septembre à 18h
ne manquez pas allons plus loin avec
rebecca fitoussi avec notamment un grand
débat qui sera consacrée à la question
des retraites très bonne soirée sur les
chaînes parlementaires
[Musique]